[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Alors Noa
Manoir 45 ans, fonction ex futur ex
fonction fonctionnaire de police. Donc
euh dizaine d'années aux renseignements
généraux, donc à la DRPP, un peu de
contreerrorisme, encadrement des
mouvements sociaux, suivi des
déplacements ministériels et cetera et
cetera. Euh un peu de police aux
frontières, un peu de sécurité publique
et une bonne part de syndicalisme dans
c'est un syndicat d'exception Vigipolis
dont Alexandre est le secrétaire
général.
Alexandre Langlois. Ben bonsoir. Donc
Alexandre Langlois, agent de
renseignement euh toujours sur le
terrain même si je suis syndicaliste,
aussi également bientôt futur
ex-policier, enfin j'espère euh parce
que je j'avais dit que tant qu'on
pourrait essayer de réformer
l'institution de l'intérieur, je
resterai à l'intérieur. Et là, je crois
que les derniers événements montrent que
ce n'est plus possible. Donc le combat
va continuer de d'autres façons.
Alors ce soir, on a décidé de vous
rassembler tous les deux parce que vous
êtes déjà venus sur la chaîne et et vous
avez toujours des des choses
intéressantes à à nous raconter.
On va parler de la police, des violences
policières, de l'intérieur de la police.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Quels sont les
mal-êtres, où va la police, où va le
gouvernement et où va la population avec
sa police.
Je vais poser la première question à
Noamanoir. Est-ce qu'on peut gouverner
sans police ?
En théorie, oui. Bon, après
effectivement la nature humaine étant ce
qu'elle est, on a toujours besoin d'une
force supérieure, on va dire d'une d'une
force publique pour contenir les Excels,
les dérives, je dirais, les entors à la
loi.
Mais la différence en fait fondamentale
au-delà de nos expériences et de notre
francité, notre amour pour notre pays
entre Alexandre et moi, c'est que moi
j'ai j'ai il y a un peu de mon ADN qui
qui est de l'autre côté du Maghreb et si
tu veux, j'ai une sorte de 6e sens qui
me permet à un moment bah de jauger la
politique qui sert plus à rien en fait
parce que tu sais le monde arabe et le
Maghreb en fait c'est de la politique,
tu as un parlement, tu as une assemblée
nationale, tu as des ministres et cetera
mais ça sert absolument à rien. On sait
très bien qu'il y a en fin de compte un
monarque, un dictateur qui contrôle tout
de A à Z, que la loi ne s'applique nulle
part, que les procès sont des parodies
finalement de procès. Et donc ça, moi tu
vois c'est même si j'ai jamais vécu au
Maghreb, en fait, c'est des choses que
je peux sentir parce que c'est dans mon
ADN en fait et c'est un peu ce qui est
en train de se passer en France. Donc
effectivement, tu sais, on peut là, j'ai
j'ai même l'impression que finalement la
manifestation de voie publique, le vote
et cetera ne sert plus à rien.
C'est-à-dire que euh on s'est vu il y a
presque 2 ans au début du mouvement des
gilets jaunes. Bon, qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé entre-temps ? Vingtaines de
mutilés, des éborniers. Je crois qu'il y
en a encore eu un à mutil samedi
dernier. Je veux dire peut-être 200 300
de mes collègues qui se sont suicidés
entre-temps. Euh un collègue, je parle
pas des têtes tranchées, du collègue de
la DRPP, de mon service qui a qui a buté
quatre collaborateurs au nom d'Allah.
Donc du coup, je veux dire que est-ce
qu'il y a eu une seule personne qui a
été désignée pour responsable de tout ce
qui s'est passé ? Est-ce qu'il y a une
personne qui a fait un seul jour de
prison entre-temps dans tout ça, je veux
dire dans tous ces événements ? Parce
que là, en 2 ans de temps, je pense
qu'on a eu 30 ans d'histoire. En fait,
sur les 30 dernières années, on avait
pas eu tout ça. Donc bah quand j'ai
envie de dire que théoriquement, on
devrait pouvoir gouverner sans police
pour répondre à ta question, mais
aujourd'hui on ne gouverne qu'avec la
police en fait et c'est une nuance
extrêmement importante.
Hélas. Voilà.
Alexandre, on peut gouverner sans police
?
Ben, je pense pas. Enfin, si dans des
petites communautés où tout le monde se
connaît, pourquoi pas ? Après, dès qu'on
vient à plus grande échelle, je pense
pas. Et moi, j'aime bien Rousseau et je
pense qu'il y a besoin d'une force
publique nécessaire pour appliquer les
lois qui sont normalement l'émanation de
la volonté populaire. Maintenant, c'est
la vraie débat qui est aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'on a l'impression qu'il y a des
lois qui sont votées mais qui ne sont
pas du tout l'émanation populaire et qui
sont au contraire la police est utilisée
pour les forcer à les appliquer contre
leur volonté. Et ça a été dit par
exemple par madame Sibetia quand elle
était porte-parole du gouvernement. Si
euh pour faire passer nos réformes, on
doit user de violence, je l'assume.
Alors que moi ma conception c'est plutôt
l'inverse. C'est ce qu'avait dit Louis
Blanc au 19e siècle. Il avait dit le
bulletin de vote a remplacer la violence
dans la rue parce que c'est le consensus
national à l'Assemblée nationale qui
permet d'avoir des lois à peu près
équilibrées qui permettent à tout le
monde de s'y retrouver sauf quelques
personnes qui voudront continuer de
contester de façon violente mais ce sera
des minorités et justement la police
sera là pour faire respecter pour faire
respecter l'ordre. Et puis il y avait
une anecdote qu'on m'a raconté
récemment, c'était Jean-Pierre
Chavement. qui était avec des militants
plutôt à gauche ou d'extrême gauche en
tous les cas et qui leur avait posé la
question, il leur avait dit bah voilà,
vous êtes plutôt pour faire des lois
progressives et avancer au niveau de la
société. Tout le monde leur aur dit "Aui
oui bien sûr, on est pour ça." Il a dit
"Demain, qui c'est qui va faire
appliquer vos lois si jamais ils veulent
pas ?" Il c'est la police. Et là,
personne n'a répondu. Ils ont dit
"effectivement,
donc on a choisi comme titre la police
en déconfiture.
Est-ce que la police est réellement en
déconfiture ?"
Noam,
en fait, j'ai envie de dire oui parce
que
elle est la police au-delà de ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur des murs de
l'institution, elle est quand même
garante justement de l'application de la
loi, on va dire quelque part de l'ordre
et de la morale chez les autres. C'est
et aujourd'hui euh en fait, on est dans
une une société vraiment de valeur
inversée. C'est-à-dire que tu vois pour
venir ici euh je suis arrivé avec un
petit peu d'avance donc j'ai eré dans
les rues de Paris pendant une heure
parce qu'aujourd'hui bah les cafés sont
fermés et cera. On peut plus aujourd'hui
être en attente à Paris quelque part. Je
veux dire si tu es pas parisien, si tu
as pas ton logement sur place, il y a
pas un café, il y a pas à part peut-être
des toilettes publiques, tu peux pas te
réfugier quelque part pour attendre. Et
en fait, même si tu es propre au sens
pénal du terme, je veux dire, tu tu as
rien à te reprocher ou quoi que ce soit,
bah tu sais, tu as un sentiment de
culpabilité. Tu marches dans Paris en
disant "Mince, si je croise une
patrouille, on va me demander une
attestation, on va me demander où je
vais, on va me demander de prouver mes
mes mes dir euh je me suis arrêté, j'ai
bu un café en bas là dans la petite
boutique. Je veux dire, il y a un moment
bah j'ai tombé le masque pour boire mon
café mais j'étais en train de regarder
et tu vois, tu es en fait,
tu as un sentiment de de
d'intranquillité de de culpabilité. à
vivre normalement et en fait euh bah
oui, tu crains de de croiser les
patrouilles de police et puis en même
temps bah compte tenu de l'actualité
récente Michel Zcler, tu te dis bah un
simple défaut de port de masque, tu sais
pas où ça peut t'amener aujourd'hui. Tu
sais Michel Zécler c'était il est passé
il est pas passé très très loin de la
mort et de la prison, je veux dire, tu
vois. Donc c'est c'est très c'est devenu
très compliqué. Maintenant, oui, de
l'intérieur la police c'est devenue du
grand n'importe quoi. Je veux dire,
honnêtement euh tu sais, nous on a un
petit peu décrié parce que les gens
disent "Oui, vous êtes un peu loin du
terrain." En parlant de moi, il y a des
il y a des policiers, tu sais la milice
de Twitter là qui oui, ça fait 3 ans que
tu as pas bossé, tu connais rien et
cetera. et et on te présente les
organisations policières euh dites
majoritaires comme étant euh légitime
pour représenter la police. Mais
honnêtement euh moi je suis désolé mais
aujourd'hui quand je regarde ce qui se
présente sur les plateaux télé, les
discours et cetera, je je j'arrive pas à
faire la connexion avec le terrain, avec
ce que j'ai connu sur le terrain. Je
veux dire honnêtement, tu prends
n'importe quel syndicat majoritaire.
Moi, pour moi, c'est des pores-paroles
de la place Bovau, quoi. Je veux dire,
ils sont pas ils sont absolument pas
légitimes pour défendre les intérêts de
la profession. les les policiers qui ont
un petit peu de conscience aujourd'hui,
bah soit ils se mettent en off,
malheureusement dans le pire des cas,
ils se suicident. Euh je veux dire, mais
clairement aujourd'hui la les intérêts
de la police sont pas défendus. Les
policiers sont livrés à eux-mêmes.
C'estàd qu'aujourd'h on est dans une
logique de marche ou crève. Soit tu
appliques les ordres, si tu commences à
réfléchir, à contester ou quoi que ce
soit, bah tu as deux exemples vivants
devant toi de ce que ça peut donner et
de de de là où ça peut conduire en fait.
Alexandre
Oui, la police est en pleine des
confitures parce que c'est pas la police
pour laquelle je me suis engagé déjà.
Les valeurs sont les une perte des
repères, une perte des valeurs, il y a
plus rien. Et c'est pas pour rien que
les le taux de suicide a explosé depuis
que monsieur Castner avait été ministre
et du coup il reste stable. Je veux
dire, il y a une perte de sens, il y a
des ordres contradictoires, il y a on ne
sait plus où aller. Moi, quand j'ai
envoyé ma lettre de rupture
conventionnelle, j'ai eu plein de
collègues qui m'ont envoyé des messages
en me disant bah nous on a démissionné
il y a quelques années pour les mêmes
raisons et d'autres qui m'ont dit "On
veut partir où tu en es pour dans ta
rupture conventionnelle parce qu'on a
fait la même demande et on peut plus
rester là, on veut partir." Et en fait,
en fait, il y a plein de policiers qui
veulent pas rester en fait qui ne s'y
reconnaissent plus, qui veulent partir.
On m'a aussi raconté l'anecdote de de
collèges qui étaient partis en
disponibilité qui sont revenus, c'est
qu'ils avaient fait autre chose et puis
ils avaient leur passe qui était gardé
au chaud. Mais c'est pas la police qu'on
a quitté en fait. On a quitté 5 6 ans et
on revient dans un truc ça ne ressemble
plus à rien. Et effectivement la police
est en pleine déconfiture parce qu'une
police doit être exemplaire si on veut
faire appliquer la loi et aujourd'hui
elle n'est pas exemplaire. Ça commence
dès la tête de l'État. On a nommé un
ministre qui était poursuivi pour viol.
Alors au final on ne saura jamais s'il
il a fait quelque chose ou pas.
C'est ce que j'allais dire. Mais ce que
j'allais dire c'était euh la la
suspicion derrière. Si jamais il est
innocenté ou qu' a l'enfer l'affaire est
enterrée comme ça s'est passé. il y aura
toujours la suspicion. Est-ce qu'il a
étudié son pouvoir pour l'enterrer ou
pas ? Et en fait, c'est pas qu'
finalement qu'il soit coupable ou
innocent, ça c'est à la justice de le
décider, mais c'est cette suspicion dans
l'opinion publique. Et je veux dire, dès
qu'il a été nommé ministre, les
policiers avaient déjà assez de choses à
gérer. On a eu aussi les associations de
féministes qui à chaque fois qu'il
passait ont commencé à venir essayer de
l'approcher. Donc la police est en
déconfiture parce que benah, elle
n'assure plus ses missions en fait. Et
j'en veux pour preuve, c'est comme a dit
Noam, c'est qu'on est en fait dirigé par
des bureaucrates. Aujourd'hui, la police
est faite pour normalement initialement
faire appliquer le code pénal et on a eu
le préfet de police de Marseille qui a
déclaré "À Marseille, tout le monde a
son attestation, sauf les dealers." Donc
on leur a mis 135 € d'amende. Mais non à
de on le met pas 135 € d'amende ou alors
peut-être en plus mais surtout on le
présente à la justice parce qu'il commet
une action illégale. Et en fait on est
là avec des gens qui sont tellement
bornés sur leurs choses c'est que sur le
terrain on sait plus comment s'en
sortir. Les policiers beaucoup de
syndicats majoritaires arrêtent pas de
marteler partout où il passe la police
nationale est la fonction publique la
plus sanctionnée. Oui, c'est vrai.
Pourquoi les policiers sont sanctionnés
? En fait, je m'étais jamais posé la
question et j'ai retombé un vieil
article de médiia part 2013. Ils ont dit
il y a 5 % des policiers qui sont
sanctionnés euh parce qu'ils ont commis
des violences illégitimes et illégales.
Mais qu'est-ce qui reste dans le 95 % en
restant ? Et ben, il y a notamment une
bonne partie, c'est parce qu'on a manqué
de loyauté envers nos chefs, parce qu'on
a dénoncé l'idfonctionnement. On a porté
atteinte au crédit renom de la police
nationale, y compris dans notre vie
privée. C'estàd qu'en fait un policier
n'a pas le droit d'avoir d'avis dans sa
vie privée, contraire à sa hiérarchie en
tous les cas de l'exprimer publiquement.
Cette petite chose sur le crédit et
renom de la police nationale, c'est une
reprise de l'article 5 du statut général
de la fonction publique de 1941. Je veux
dire, ils sont allés chercher loin pour
museler les fonctionnaires de police.
Donc ça veut dire qu'à partir de là, il
y a une déconfiture de la police qui a
une inversion des valeurs. Et
aujourd'hui, l'inversion des valeurs est
tellement complète, c'est qu'on m'avait
dit à un moment la peur va changer de
camp parce qu'on avait l'impression que
c'était les policiers qui avaient peur
et pas les délinquants. Effectivement,
la peur a changé de camp. Maintenant,
c'est les honnêtes citoyens qui ont peur
de la police et toujours pas les
délinquants.
Je je vais vous lire euh un passage du
canard enchaîné. Et ensuite, on va on va
enchaîner sur les violences policières.
Ça s'appelle flic en fuite. Alors, 34
ans plus tard, l'atmosphère est
similaire. Le 30 novembre dernier, le la
commission de loi de l'Assemblée
d'Armanin adressé un bilan amer. Réduire
la formation des troupes a été une
erreur fondamentale.
Autre péché capital, la faiblesse de
l'encadrement. 8000 officiers contre
18000 alors inspecteur en 1986.
Quant aux vaations, elles se font rares.
Pour recruter un flic en tenue, il a
fallu abaisser la note éliminatoire de 7
à 5/ 20.
Déjà, premier passage. C'est vrai ça, on
a abaissé la note éliminatoire de 7 à 5/
20.
C'est possible. En 2017, ils avaient
passé à 8 de moyenne.
2018, ils ont baissé le niveau du
concours. Ils ont encore recruté à 8 de
moyenne. Sachant que la première année,
ils ont pas pu pouvoir 300 postes, la
deuxième année 200 postes. Donc, je ne
sais pas à quelle date le l'article du
Canard enchaîné, mais c'est fort
possible qu'on continue sur cette lancée
parce que on ne veut pas attirer les
gens qui ont le profil pour passer le
concours. À tel point que même le
directeur de la formation en 2017
s'était alerté dans le monde en disant
les gens qu'on m'envoie en formation, je
pourrais rien en faire. Et le niveau, on
peut voir qu'il a baissé. Il y a l'école
de Nî qui a récemment défrayé la
déffrayé la chronique avec des élèves
gardiens qui ne respectaient pas le
confinement
et même ça va plus loin. qu'on a des
dans le poste de garde, nos collègues
ont affiché en disant si vous fumez du
stup,
vous êtes pas viré ni quoi que ce soit.
Si vous buvez en état d'ivresse, voilà.
Donc c'est que l'administration a a
conceptualisé en disant ils vont
commettre des infractions pénales, mais
on va tout faire pour les garder parce
que bah du coup, on a plus que cela donc
faut qu'ils sortent et mes collègues
là-bas me disent on sort avec des
gazeuses pour faire les tours dans
l'école de police. Je veux dire qu'on
est à ce niveau-là. Et une fois, il a dû
faire usage de sa gazeuse parce qu'il a
été pris à parti par des élèves gardiens
sur place.
C'était dans quelle école de police ?
Anime aussi. Donc en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est pas un épiphénomène qui est
sorti dans la presse. Si il est sorti
dans la presse mais c'est parce qu'il y
avait des vidéos et c'est le collègue
qui a utilisé la gazeuse qui a dû
écrire. Il a dit on veut pas de vague.
Faut qu'ils sortent tous. Il commenc à
dire qu'on les forme mal ou que c'est
des incapables ou que c'est des gens qui
n'ont pas les valeurs pour entrer dans
la police va pas le faire. Donc du coup,
c'est une inversion des valeurs dès
l'école de police.
Alors la suite de l'article Noam, je te
donne la par tout suite.
Dès qu'un gardien de la paix, dès qu'un
gardien a un peu de bouteille, il se
dépêche d'aller voir ailleurs. Sur le
terrain, il n'y a plus d'ancien pour
dire stop, déplore un commandant. Le
chef de groupe, celui qui a dégoupillé
la grenade, est un simple gardien de la
paix qui n'a que 5 ans d'expérience.
Côté officier, le bilan n'est guère plus
reluisant. En région parisienne, faute
de candidat, 30 % des postes ne sont pas
pourvus. Noam ! Mais en fait après, je
pense qu'il faut pas sous-estimer sans
faire de voilà de de ce qu'on ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le complotisme. J'ai
qu' une notion un peu à la mode. Tu sais
quand tu discutes avec les les bah
certains de nos aspirants, on va dire
gardiens de la paix ou nos adhérents ou
autres, tu t'aperçois que c'est
peut-être voulu parce que tu regardes le
niveau déjà du bac clairement, c'est le
qui est exigé pour le concours.
Clairement, tu prends le bac d'il y a 20
ans déjà avant de parler de génération.
Absolu, c'est pas possible. Non mais
aujourd'hui quand tu discutes avec un
gardien de la paix, le le type te dit
"Attends, j'ai un bac pro vente ou un
bac pro commerce, on me donne 2000 € par
mois à Paris euh dans la fonction
publique avec des tickets à Noël, une
mutuelle, la possibilité d'accéder à des
crédits et cetera." Le type dit "Mais
jamais, je mets je remettrai ça en
cause. Si demain je vais bosser chez
Carouf, bah j'aurais peut-être pas
exactement les mêmes conditions
d'emploi." Donc tu sais, quelque part
c'est beaucoup plus simple de faire ça,
c'est-à-dire d'aller recruter. Bon, je
vais pas si si effectivement la moyenne
d'obtention c'est 5/ 20 sur un concours
niveau bac pour quand on sait ce que le
bac, ce qui est devenu le bac
aujourd'hui. Je veux dire, c'est
catastrophique. C'est peut-être voulu
parce que si demain tu veux, on va dire
des gens qui sortent de prépa, tu sais,
par exemple pour les commissaires de
police, c'est c'est oui voilà, il va
falloir passer à la caisse. Les
commissaires de police aujourd'hui,
c'est Science Po si tu es pas passé par
Science Po globalement sur les promos
des écoles commissaires, je pense que
c'est allez, tu dois avoir peut-être un
élève commissaire sur 10 qui est passé
par un autre cursus mais la plupart
viennent de l'IP. C'est d'ailleurs des
gens qui ont raté le concours de l'ENAT.
Donc tu sais, on sait faire de
l'excellence au niveau du corps
justement de de euh on va dire du corps
de conception et de direction. Mais pour
les gardiens de la paix, c'est normal,
on si tu veux. Bon, globalement,
je te coupe.
Ouais. Et ça ne s'arrange pas lorsque le
grade s'élève dans le 17e arrondissement
de Paris par exemple où sévissaient les
agents cogneurs. Seul un poste de
commissaire sur deux est pourvu. Pas
étonnant comme dirait encore Dormanin
que ça déconne dans la police. Alors les
journalistes qui ont écrit ça c'est
Didier Assou et Christophe Labé.
H
ça déconne à ce point-là où il y a quand
même des choses bonnes dans la police
là. essayer de défendre un peu la
police.
Alors si tu défends la police, si il y a
des choses qui sont bien, il y a
beaucoup de gens qui pour des raisons
idéologiques détestent la police. Très
bien. Et qui disent voilà tous les
policiers sont de plus en plus violents,
il y a de plus en plus de dérives, la
majorité de la police est gangrainée. Il
y a 150000 fonctionnaires de police. Si
75000 déconnent à bloc, je pense que le
pays ce serait pas comment il est tenu
aujourd'hui. Donc il y a une grande
majorité de policiers qui essayent de
faire leur travail au mieux avec en
naviguant entre les gouttes, c'estàdire
les sanctions disciplinaires parce
qu'ils appliquent pas forcément tous les
ordres qu'on leur donne, y compris des
ordres des fois la limite de la légalité
et à côté de ça qui essaent de faire
leur travail comme ils peuvent en
conscience. Le le drame des policiers
sur le terrain, c'est aujourd'hui de
faire un choix entre les valeurs pour
lesquelles ils sont engagés et les
ordres qu'on qu'ils reçoivent et qui
sont managés par la peur. Et en fait, la
peur ne donne jamais le bon aiguillon
pour diriger les gens. Donc, il y a des
choses à sauver dans la police, oui,
mais malheureusement, il y a tout un
encadrement au-dessus et une main mise
qui empêche les policiers de faire leur
travail pour une partie et on encourage
les comportements desviants, ce qui est
dramatique.
Et ça, vous avez des preuves de
l'encouragement des comportements
déviant ?
Ben, on va le donner très simplement
de plusieurs exemples. L'exemple de
monsieur l'allemand, monsieur l'Allemand
à Bordeaux, il était à Bordeaux avant
d'arriver préfet de police de Paris. à
Bordeaux, il a menti pour couvrir les
policiers qui ont tiré sur Olivier
Beziade, un pompier volontaire qui était
sur une manifestation gilet jaune. Il a
déclaré haut et fort euh non, il il
s'est fait tirer dessus parce qu'il
était dans c'était le chaos, les
vitrines étaient brisées et cetera. Le
monde a fait l'enquête plus vite que les
GPN pour montrer que le gars était en
train de partir conformément aux
instructions de la police qui s'est fait
tirer dans le dos. Ce préfet de police a
une enfin ce préfet de Bordeaux a une
promotion à Paris. préfet de police.
L'autre exactement chose aussi euh Noam
et moi-même euh on a été euh attaqué
pénalement par l'administration pour des
faits de faute professionnell enfin des
faites de diffamation, des tractes
syndicaux pour avoir dénoncé des graves
disonfonctionnements internes et on a
demandé la protection fonctionnelle dans
l'admin
l'Allemand a accordé récemment.
Voilà, c'est ce que je dire. C'était le
parallèle que je voulais faire, c'est
que Didier l'Allemand l'a accordé très
aux policiers qui ont tabassé monsieur
Scler ce qui est la loi. Donc là, il
peut y avoir un débat, c'est
l'application stricte de la loi. Le
problème, c'est que la loi n'est pas
appliquée à tout le monde. Tous ceux qui
dénoncent des dysfonctionnements, qui
ont des problèmes hiérarchiques, qui
sont qui souffrent de harcèlement, la
loi, il y a même des jugements du
Conseil d'État qui disent "Oui, les
fonctionnaires doivent avoir la
protection fonctionnelle pour faire
valoir l'ordre contre leur propre
administration. La police nationale le
refuse systématiquement." Donc voilà,
donc faut commettre des fautes
professionnelles pour y avoir le droit.
Alors, ils se sont même pas donnés la
peine de refuser, hein, euh, par me
concernant concernant euh Sabine, ma
collègue ou d'autres euh adhérents de
notre syndicat, en fait, ils répondent
pas. C'est-à-dire que les délais de
l'administration, c'est que bah si euh
dans les de mois, ils ont pas répondu,
c'est un refus tacite. Et donc bah c'est
vraiment l'idée de te de te manifester
du mépris, c'est-à-dire que tu leur fais
une demande et puis hop, ils laissent
couler, ils mettent ça dans un tiroir et
au bout de 2 mois, tu as pas de réponse,
donc tu tu sais que ça équivaut à un
refus. Et là effectivement pour les
trois euh fonctionnaires qui ont tabassé
Michel euh là il se voilà nous c'est les
cagnotes hein. D'ailleurs, on en
remercie tous les contributeurs qui nous
ont permis de de survivre dans
l'institution parce que bah on a pu se
défendre, on n pas été révoqué, je veux
dire on a on a on a été sanctionné grâce
au contributeur mais je veux dire
honnêtement à la base si si on comptait
sur l'administration, on était mort
hein. Je veux dire clairement la la le
chemin était tracé et là l'énergie avec
laquelle les syndicats,
l'administration, la préfecture de
police défend les personnes qui ont fait
ça. C'estàd qu'à un moment tu as Macron
qui tweet "Ces images me font honte,
c'est de la violence et cetera" et le
préfet de police qui passe à la caisse
pour leur payer des avocats. Donc il y a
un moment où tu dis "Attends, il y a un
problème, faut être cohérent dans le
discours." Je veux dire, s'ils te
fondent, tu leur payes pas un avocat. Tu
vois, c'est si tu t'es permis de pas
nous le payer à nous, il y a aucune
raison que tu le le payes, tu vois.
C'est
est-ce que c'est une façon aussi de
manifester et de faire passer un message
pour ceux qui sont encore en poste
genre on est derrière vous inquiétez
pas. Non, le message en fait, je pense
qu'il faut même pas les surestimer. Je
pense que le message c'est
qu'aujourd'hui et bon nombre d'experts
d'avocats le disent, c'est que le
ministre de l'intérieur n'est pas le
chef à bord. Et tu le sais très bien, tu
me poses la question mais en fait c'est
pas c'est c'est un exécutant en réalité.
C'est triste à dire mais il est là, il y
a un moment où tu as envie de lui dire
copain arrête quoi c'est bon quoi. Je
veux dire, il a il est toujours en train
de brosser la police, les syndicats et
cetera. Il y a un moment tu dis "C'est
toi le chef quoi, mets tes couilles sur
la table et arrête de te laisser driver
comme ça quoi." Je veux dire, il y a un
moment tu vois c'est après compte tenu
ce qu'à de l'affaire pénale en cours qui
a évoqué Alexandre tout à l'heure, on
peut supposer que c'est peut-être aussi
un jeu d'équilibriste de la part du
ministre. Il sait très bien que
on va pas évoquer une affaire en cours.
Je vais juste vous Oui.
Non mais je veux dire on effectivement
he toute réserve gardée, je veux dire
mais l'affaire en cours, elle va être
traitée par la police hein que tu le
veuilles ou non. Après les on peut pas
présumer de ce qui va se passer mais ça
crée un conflit d'intérêt indéiablement.
Donc après moi je suis pas dans la tête
du ministre et je veux dire aujourd'hui
très clairement que ce soit sur la loi
sécurité globale ou sur beaucoup
d'autres dossiers, il a une tendance à
défendre la police de façon
inconditionnelle qui est presque
douteuse, qui est presque suspecte parce
que à la base effectivement on défend la
police dans la mesure où elle défend
elle-même l'intérêt des citoyens. Je
veux dire, il y a un moment où quand la
police est dans son action en divergence
totale avec les intérêts de de la masse,
il y a un moment où il faut savoir
trancher et c'est le rôle du ministre de
l'intérieur que de pouvoir trancher. On
dit police depuis tout à l'heure mais la
gendarmerie, moi j'en entends pas
parler. J'ai jamais entendu un gilet
jaune ou quelqu'un d'autre me dit "Ah
bah la gendarmerie tout à CABS, c'est
HCOPS. C'est il y a pas l'équivalent
pour les gendarmes, ni pour les
douiniers, ni pour les polices
municipales. Il y a un problème de qui
est inhérent, qui est propre à notre
institution, à la police nationale, qui
existe en sans doute mais beaucoup
moins, en tout cas en moindre mesure
dans les autres institutions qui sont
chargées de l'application de la loi et
ça mérite un questionnement. Je veux
dire, il y a un moment, pardon, vous
az déjà fait contrôler par la
gendarmerie ?
Bien sûr, ouais, ça arrive.
C'est la classe quand même. Bonjour
monsieur, le salut.
J'ai même eu le j'ai j'ai déjà eu le
cas. Euh je sais plus, il y avait un
médecin, j'ai un ami qui est médecin
généraliste qui est médecin de voilà de
proximité. Et à un moment, je lui disais
"Ouais, c'est bizarre avec ton confrère
là, il y a un rapport qui est bizarre.
Il est un peu glacial avec moi, je sais
pas si c'est sa nature, est-ce qu'il a
pas Il me dit Non non, il me dit "Tu
sais chez nous les médecins, il y a même
pas à se poser la question, il y a des
personnalités différentes." Mais on a
prêté serment, il y a le serment
d'Hippocrate qui fait que même si le mec
et je veux dire, je vais pas dire
néonazie, mais frontiste, ce que tu
veux, il va recevoir un mec qui est noir
foncé, il va le soigner comme s'il
soignait un un blanc phosphorescent. Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? Globalement,
il me dit il y a pas de différence dans
le traitement, dans l'application des
soins. Chez nous, il y a même pas à se
poser la question. C'est une porte que
tu peux refermer tout de suite. Et la
gendarmerie, je pense qu'ils sont un peu
formatés de la même manière. Franchement
euh moi j'ai je je veux dire j'ai du
respect pour eux pour ça parce que
justement tu sens il y a des tendances
il y a mais je veux dire tu t'en rends
pas compte parce que quand tu as affaire
à eux bah tu es reçu de tu vois je veux
dire à chaque fois que j'ai été contrôlé
que j'ai été verbalisé ça m'est arrivé
un excès de vitesse ou quoi que ce soit
bah tu t'as rien à dire je veux dire tu
étais en excè ça a été mesuré tu peux
pas tu vas te retrancher derrière des
interprétations fumeuses ou je ne sais
quoi. Et je pense que de ce point de
vue- là, bah leur formatage militaire a
aidé à ce que bah tu sens que c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne.
C'est-à-dire que s'il y a un souci, tu
vas à l'IGGN, tu sais très bien qu'il y
a un mécanisme qui va fonctionner et qui
va descendre du haut vers le bas dans la
police. Tu sais pas, tu as des
syndicats, on te dit que les syndicats
sont en opposition les uns avec les
autres, mais tu te rends bien compte que
c'est pas tout à fait vrai, que le
directeur, tu vois, il y a des vœux du
des syndicats.
Le ministre va se prosterner, je veux
dire régulièrement, pas forcément
d'Armana parce que c'est son premier
mandat, mais à chaque fois qu'il y a les
vœux du SCSI, de Synergie ou quoi que ce
soit, les ministres vont se prosterner.
Il y a un moment où ça va, tu vois. Je
veux dire, c'est bon quoi. Si ça veut
dire
c'est le syndicat des cadres de la
sécurité intérieure. C'est l'ancien SNOP
en fait qui a changé. Tu veux dire
le syndicat national des officiers de
police.
Revenons à l'affaire Michel Zécler.
Alexandre Langlois. Euh quand vous voyez
les images, quand vous voyez une une
grenade lacrimau balancée dans un milieu
fermé, explosé dans un milieu fermé qui
pouvait [__] le feu à tout l'immeuble.
En tant que gardien de la paix,
quelles ont été les fautes pour vous ?
Bah les fautes déjà, il y a plusieurs
choses. Ils ont dit qu'au début, ils
portaient pas son masque, après ils ont
dit ils avaient senti du stup. Bah, ils
ont sorti du stup, c'était je pense pour
justifier après de pouvoir être pénétré
dans son domicile. Mais je veux dire
pour avoir vu la quantité de cannabis
qui a été retrouvé, il fallait avoir un
nez euh très très fin avec le masque
dans la voiture. Donc, je veux dire là,
faut être très très fort, faut qu'ils
aillent trava stup, même les chiens stup
feraient pas mieux. Euh donc les fautes
professionnels c'est déjà que c'est de
la juste mesure. Si quelqu'un a pas son
masque et ben on voit, on le suit, il
est rentré là. Bah je veux dire, on
parle du contraventionnel. Je veux dire,
on va pas commencer à rentrer chez les
gens pour une faute de masque ou alors
pour quelques grammes de cannabis. C'est
également du contraventionnel. Imaginons
qu'ils avaient un super nez et qu'ils
l'ont bien senti. C'est du
contraventionnel. Je veux dire, on va
pas euh maîtriser un théoriste tout ça.
Donc c'est un usage complètement euh
disproportionné de la force et après en
plus c'est d'appeler des renforts.
Toujours pour une contravention. Je veux
dire, les autres collègues, ils avaient
vraiment d'autres choses à faire et eux,
il doit faire confiance au primo
intervenant qui étaient déjà sur place
et qui leur disent "Attendez, il faut
sortir." Donc, il y a des sorties
d'armes, il tirent une grenade et le tir
de la grenade, c'est encore plus
choquant. Euh parce que notre syndicat a
vigie, euh, on a s'été battu sur les gaz
lacrymogènes qui sont euh avec euh des
composés CS dedans, qui est un agent CS
qui est dangereux pour la santé et
l'Agence européenne des risques
industriels chimiques dit que ce gaz là
tiré en vas clos est mortel. Donc tirer
cette gaz ça dans un vas close un
sérieux problème de lucidité. Savoir que
les policiers sont pas formés non plus
au contenu de leur grenade. Donc voilà
et que le fabricant de la grenade qui
donc elle satex pour la plupart des
grenades françaises avait été pris la
main dans le sac en trafiquant ses
normes il y a quelques années. Ça fait
la une des journaux depuis il a dit
c'est plus le cas mais l'État français
laisse les entreprises privées
s'autocontrôler quasiment. Donc ça pose
des problèmes aussi de concentration et
de ce qu'il y a comme matériel utilisé
par les policiers. Donc ça me pose un
problème de il a été poursuivi aussi
mais moi je pense que si jamais on
allait au plus loin, moi ce serait
homicide à volontaire qu'on pourrait
retenir parce que c'est l'Agence
européenne des risques chimiques dit
c'est mortel ce gaz là cette agence CS
qui est dans les grenades lacrymogènes.
Donc voilà donc il y a beaucoup de
fautes et je veux dire on fait tout un
pâte à caisse sur ça mais ce qui est
normal et la et les réactions tabassent
pas quelqu'un au sol. Je veux dire pour
quelqu'un qui finalement on sait où il
habite enfin debout ils l'ont mis debout
ils l'ont tabassé debout on le tabasse
pas quelqu'un. Je veux dire pour une
contravention, je veux dire si quelqu'un
allait commettre un acte terroriste ou
quelque chose de grave, un braquage de
banque, je dis pas s'il faut maîtriser
la personne par tout moyen pour
préserver des vies. Effectivement, on
peut faire usage de violence dans le
cadre légal. Là, non, je veux dire, à
partir de là, on est sur quelque chose
de bah, ils savent même pas comment s'en
tirer. Ils étaient tellement embêtés
qu'ils ont fait des fois en écriture.
Est-ce qui est finalement l'infraction
pénale quasiment la plus grave de ce
qu'ils ont fait ? Bah c'est départ
dépositaires de l'autorité publique.
Faire un en écriture, c'est la cour
d'assise. Donc du coup
c'est 30 ans,
ils peuvent aller jusqu'à 30 ans. Donc
voilà.
En fait pour résumer pardon moi j'ai
fini
sans sans rentrer dans les détails. Bon
le mec il porte pas de masque. OK soit
je veux dire bon il mérite une
contravention de 135 €. Tu es tu es tu
es agent de police judiciaire, ils sont
trois donc ils peuvent constater
l'infraction. il va vers son domicile,
bon ben tu peux très bien le convoquer.
Je veux dire, il y a pas de souci, tu es
pas obligé de pénétrer au domicile. Donc
déjà, on était en dehors des horaires
parce qu'il y a des horaires qui
autorisent la perquisition à domicile
hein, mais effectivement passer 21h leur
de 21h à 6h,
sauf mais sauf état d'urgence entre 21h
et 6h,
l'entrée au domicile par effraction de
la part des policiers est interdite
strictement réglementée. Il y a un cas
hors état d'urgence qui qui fait pas
jurisprudence qui a été ordonné par le
ministre de l'intérieur à l'époque
Claude Guillant. C'était Mohamed Mer
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont rentrés chez
lui à 3h du matin parce que ça avait été
ordonné. Il y avait procureur sur place,
il y avait un juge et cetera. Donc
c'était un cas d'exception. Je veux dire
en dehors de hors état d'urgence entre
21h et ce soir, tu peux pas t'introduire
au domicile de quelqu'un. Et en plus je
dirais que pour perquisitionner il faut
ça la perquisition en tout cas nécessite
le statut d'officier de police
judiciaire. aucun d'eux n'était au PJ et
de toute façon il y avait pas le motif à
un masque c'est une contravention c'est
une infraction contraventionnelle he
donc euh du coup bon l'odeur de stupe et
que ça je pense que c'est du c'est du
flanc quoi. Il faut même pas rentrer
là-dedans. Je veux dire franchement et
j'ai entendu alors je demande à la
communauté de me faire checker. J'ai
entendu je crois que j'ai lu euh que les
policiers avaient dit que le monsieur
Michel avait essayé de se saisir de leur
armes.
C'est vrai ? C'est pas vrai ?
Non. Bah les les la vidéo le montre pas
en tout cas et puis on nous sa moi alors
j'ai regardé les associations de police
de défense des policiers ont édité des
vidéos en disant oui mais regardez vous
avez pas tout vu. Il y a des séquences
donc j'ai regardé moi j'ai pas vu de
séquence qui n'avaient pas été diffusées
précédemment par le loopsider. Il y a
pas de d'éléments nouveaux, il y a pas
de nouvelles images. Et bon, de toute
façon, je pense que ça ça justifie le
faux en écriture. C'est-à-dire que le
mec, non seulement il rentre chez lui
illégalement, il le tabasse. Le seul
cadre légal d'usage de la force, c'est
la légitime défense. On peut pas s'en
servir dans un autre contexte et je
pense pas que Michel Zcler ait attaqué
le premier. En tout cas, je l'ai pas
constaté sur les images. Et au-delà de
ça, bon ben après l'idée c'était qu'il
fallait bien justifier justement bah le
fait de l'avoir abîmé. Et donc bon, ils
ont écrit un roman. Don je veux dire,
moi j'ai déminé le terrain sur j'étais
confrères du média la semaine dernière
euh parce que j'ai eu quelques échos en
interne où ils ont dit qu'ils avaient
consulté justement ces ces antécédents
au traitement des antécédents
judiciaires. Ils ont dit bon bah c'est
cool, il est connu pour association de
malfaiteurs, pour vol à ma armée, même
si ça date de 15 ans, bon bah on aura
juste à à laisser suggéré que finalement
bon bah durant 15 ans, il s'est pas du
tout assagi. Il a juste évité de se
faire guler et puis finalement bah ce
soir c'est le grand soir puisqu'on l'a
pris la main dans le sac et puis voilà,
il a essayé de nous voler nos arbres.
C'est inventé, je veux dire clairement,
ils l'ont tabassé, ils ont cherché à à à
raccrocher les wagons. Oui, voilà, c'est
tout. Après, je veux dire, bon
euh moi ce qui voilà, il y a il y a le
fond en écriture, c'est-à-dire que tu te
dis [__] euh bah aujourd'hui euh je
veux dire tu as intérêt à installer des
caméras y compris chez toi quoi. Je veux
dire c'est tu vois euh c'est quand même
tu il y avait pas les caméras, il était
mort quoi. Je veux dire franchement avec
ce qu'ils étaient en train de lui
coller, je veux dire, il dormait en
prison pour un bon moment, quoi. Donc ça
fait un peu flipper quand ça vient de la
police parce que en théorie la police
c'est quand même bah c'est la parole à
sermenter. Donc du coup bah il y a plein
de gens qui commencent à se poser la
question de savoir s'il y a pas des gens
qui dorment en prison injustement qui
devraient pas y être. Incontestablement,
il y a plein de gens qui devraient y
être mais qui n'y sont pas. Donc tu
vois, ça s'ajoute pas forcément en notre
faveur he je veux dire en faveur de
l'institution. Et puis donc bah c'est
une période où ça va mal quoi. Je veux
dire les gens se disent "Attends, il y a
plein de gens qui devraient y être en
prison mais qui n'y sont pas." Il y a
des gens bah y compris des gilets jaunes
et cetera, qui dorment en prison alors
qu'ils ont pas fait grand-chose. Il y a
des policiers voyou, il y a des patrons
de la police, il y a des préfet qui ont
des positions qui sont pas forcément
transparentes.
Donc puis en plus, on essaie de nous
faire passer un texte de loi qui vise à
à laisser penser que le problème c'est
les images, c'est pas l'IGPN, c'est pas
l'action des policiers. Je veux dire à
un moment on pourrait dire oui,
on fait tout un RAMDAM sur la la loi
sécurité mais sur sur le fait de filmer
les policiers, on peut mais il faut pas
diffuser pour les discréditer. C'est ça.
Alors le problème, c'est qu'il y a déjà
des lois qui existent. Si jamais il y a
des gens qui diffusent des vidéos de
policiers ou qui dans le but de leur
nuire, c'est bah c'est le harcèlement.
C'estàd que dans le but de Mais c'est
pas que sur les policiers, c'est sur
n'importe quel citoyen, c'est 2 ans de
prison. S'il y a des menaces, c'est
entre 3 et 5 ans. 5 ans, c'est pour les
menaces de mort. Donc c'est des lois qui
existent. Et on a une collègue en 2019
qui est au tribunal parce qu'elle avait
été suivie à Versailles euh par
quelqu'un qui avait fait des photos de
chez elle qui l'avait suivi en disant
"J'essayer de voir où elle habitait pour
essayer de la" donc la personne voulait
lui nuire. Voilà, c'était avéré, c'était
un fait, c'était pas on était pas comme
dans la rédaction de l'article 24 où on
imagine que la personne fait ça pour
nuir. Que là, on est dans minority
report, c'està dire un film où on
anticipe les actes criminels. Là, on
avait les preuves et les faits. La
personne s'est pré retrouvé 17 mois en
prison. Donc 17 mois en prison, c'est
important. La loi de monsieur Darmin
prévoyait 12 mois maximum. Donc en fait
on est sur ça. Donc en fait il y a déjà
des lois qui protègent le citoyen
lambda, donc le policier. Quand elles
sont appliquées, elles marchent. Donc là
le la la le le l'article de loi vous
voulait en disant on ajoutait du flou de
l'arbitraire en disant sur un soupçon
que vous allez faire ça et ben vous avez
pas le droit de filmer. Et à partir de
là chaque journaliste ou chaque personne
qui va filmer bah aura toujours le
doute. Est-ce que ils vont pas dire que
j'avais un but malintentionné ? Et c'est
pas pour rien que dans le nouveau schéma
du maintien de l'ordre, il y avait
marqué "Si vous voulez aller filmer en
tant que journaliste les manifestations,
déjà quand il y a des ordres de
dispersion, vous partez avec tout le
monde, vous avez pas le droit de
rester." Et puis demander carrément des
accréditations au ministère qui les
donnera ou pas pour bah comme ça vous
serez protégé. C'est pour la protection
des journalistes.
C'est l'intention malveillante qui est
difficile à caractériser. C'est-à-dire
que nous on est on est aussi agent de
police judiciaire. Donc à un moment
quand on te demande de caractériser
l'intention malveillante d'un type qui
tient un téléphone pour filmer, c'est
impossible. Je veux dire euh donc euh
est-ce que tout tous les toutes les
personnes qui vont utiliser leur
smartphone pour filmer euh une scène de
violence policière ont une intention
malveillante ou pas ? Et donc il à ce
moment-là bah vous avez l'autorisation
de faire cesser l'infraction euh parce
que quand on constate une infraction bah
avant de la relever, de la verbaliser,
il faut la faire cesser. C'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on procède par
exemple à des enlèvements de véhicules
et cetera quand le véhicule gêne, il
faut faire cesser l'infraction. Donc il
faut le retirer. Donc là c'est un peu la
même chose. On va dire bah vous filmez
mais comme votre intention est
malveillante, j'ai le devoir de faire
cesser l'infraction. Donc soit je casse
le téléphone, soit je me saisis du
téléphone et j'efface les images. Donc
ça ouvre une porte en fait euh je dirais
qui qui est un petit peu bon de toute
façon je pense que ça passera pas je
dirais c'est c'est une loi qui sera des
des crées anticonstitutionnel mais je
veux dire ça ça a déjà créé le doute sur
les terrains de manifestation. Les gens
ont peur aujourd'hui de sortir leur
smartphone. Et quand je te parlais un
petit peu du bah des exemples du
Maghreb, des pays totalites, tout à
l'heure, c'était pas exagéré hein. Je
veux dire très clairement que là
aujourd'hui on on donne tous les
pouvoirs à la police et le seul niveau
de contrôle bah à la base avant c'était
le défenseur des droits et l'IGPM mais
clairement ça ne fonctionne pas. Je veux
dire là on veut créer une troisème
plateforme, il y en a déjà deux, les
deux fonctionnent pas. Je vois pas
pourquoi la troisième donnerait des
résultats. Mais très clairement là bah
le contrôle c'est le coup de matraque
quoi. Je veux dire he tu filmes, tu vas
te prendre un coup de matraque dans ton
téléphone à 600 € tu vas le faire une
fois, tu le feras pas deux fois quoi.
C'est dissuasif hein tout simplement.
Après le fait qu'on convoque les
fantômes de Mané en ville, je trouve ça
extrêmement déplacé de la part des
syndicats.
Rappelez rapp il faut il faut que tu
rappelles ce que c'est.
Alors c'est un un alors c'était un
délinquant de droit commun qui s'est
islamisé. La Rossia Abala, originaire de
Mantel la jolie, fiché s euh revenant de
Syrie, qui bah pour une raison
aujourd'hui qui qui apparaît encore
assez flou, s'est introduit au domicile
de deux policiers, donc d'un couple de
policiers Jean-Baptiste Salvin et
Jessica Schneeder et donc les a égorgé à
leur domicile en présence de leur
enfant. Voilà, tout simplement. et donc
euh il a été abattu par le raid ensuite
euh donc à leur domicile. L'enquête a
révélé que bah la fuite ne de leur donné
personnelle pourrait euh a priori
provenir du d'une clé USB qui aurait été
conservée au domicile d'une déléguée
syndicale euh qui a euh hébergé chez
elle de façon, je dirais inconsciente,
hein, mais une amie de sa fille qui
était fichier S et donc en relation avec
la mouvance islamiste radicale. C'est
c'est pas un problème d'internet, c'est
pas un problème de liberté publique ou
de liberté de la presse. Là, c'était un
problème très particulier d'ailleurs de
filtration puré simple.
Voilà, c'est ça. De tamponnage, ce qu'on
appelle du tamponnage. Oui,
effectivement c'est c'est c'est même une
faute en fait qui a été commise en
réalité dans le process. et donc aller
rappeler Manville à l'Assemblée
nationale pour justifier de de on va
dire de l'usage de ce texte de loi. Pour
ceux qui connaissent le dossier, c'est
un petit peu déplacé quand même très
honnêtement. Je sais pas, j'aurais bien
aimé entendre la réaction du père de
Jean-Baptiste Salvin puisqu'il
s'exprimait régulièrement dans les
médias euh parce que moi je pense que
c'est assez inconvenant. Voilà,
j'ai j'ai des copains journalistes qui
ont été appelés par la police pour que
ils donnent leur rush auprès de la
police. Alors, la première question que
je me suis posé, c'est comment ils
avaient eu leur numéro de téléphone ?
Est-ce qu'ils utilisent des stingray sur
les manifestations ? Est-ce que est-ce
que c'est possible ça ? Est-ce que la
police déploie des stingray sur les
manifestations ?
Euh, probablement, je veux dire,
c'est quoi les stinger ? C'est c'est pas
ce alors moi j'utilise pas ce terme au
regard de la terminologie que tu
emploch. Je pense que tu fais référence
au MIC catcher. C'est ça ?
Oui. Voilà. Donc bon, en gros, c'est un
appareil pour nos auditeurs qui est qui
se dissimule dans un sac à dos en fait
et qui capte sur un rayon qui est
variable en fonction du modèle, qui peut
aller de 10 à 20 m à peu près hein, qui
capte toutes les données des téléphones
mobiles qu'il y a autour, c'est qu' les
trace, donc qui capture les fichiers
enregistrés, les contacts, les
communications en cours, les SMS et
cetera. Donc voilà qui qui met tout ça
dans un disque dans un fichier dans un
dossier en fait Windows et puis bon le
policier rentre et bah il a toute
liberté justement d'aller exploiter tout
ce qui a été collecté.
Ça c'est sûr de ça là. Il chopent même
ce qu'il y a dedans les
Oui. D'ailleurs, il y avait même eu un
article de presse qui était qui qui
était pas dans le point où à un moment
la DRPP avait essayé de faire des
économies. C'est-à-dire que ça c'était
un appareil à l'époque euh qui était
produit par des Américains par une
société américaine qui coûtait environ
50 à 60000 €. Et je crois qu'il y a eu
un modèle d'une société concurrente, je
sais pas, je crois que c'était une
société asiatique qui avait produit un
modèle à 15000 € et ils avaient fourni
la DRPP sans mode d'emploi. Et donc bon
un moment le le la la DRPP avait été un
peu la risée des médias parce qu'il y
avait une fuite où un officier de
l'antitéro de la section T1 avait appelé
les la presse en disant regardez ils
nous ont commandé du matos mais on sait
pas s'en servir. C'était dans 2016
pendant la le cycle infernal, on va
dire, de d'attaque terroriste. Et puis
donc je pense qu'entre-temps, bon, ils
ont dû palier à on va dire à la
difficulté. Je pense qu'ils savent s'en
servir et je pense pas qu'ils s'en
privent beaucoup. Après pour répondre à
ta question, oui euh bah naturellement
je veux dire quand tu fais une écoute
téléphonique he pour avoir pratiqué ce
qu'on appelle logique, c'est le centre
d'écoute. C'était pas ma spécialité mais
j'en ai fait un peu. Je veux dire bah
quand tu branches un téléphone, tu as
accès à toutes les communications, hein.
Le JC se stoppe pas automatiquement
quand le le on va dire la cible
correspond avec son avocat. Donc a toute
liberté d'écouter. Après tu peux pas
retranscrire par contre tu peux pas
retranscrire une conversation entre bah
une cible et son avocat. Pour la presse,
c'est pareil. si tu as un contact comme
je l'ai été hein, moi j'ai été ciblé par
la DRPP sur une écoute téléphonique sur
plusieurs interceptions de sécurité et
il recherchait justement
mes incointances avec des journalistes
mais à un moment euh parce que j'ai
coécrit un livre entre-temps avec le le
chef du service police justice de
libération comme tu le sais et donc du
coup bah il cherchait à savoir si
j'avais été à la source de certaines
informations pour la presse et donc bah
naturellement ils écoutent les
conversations. Après, je veux dire euh
ils font ce que tu dis. C'està-dire
qu'il convoquent les journalistes, ils
convoquent les bon ils convoquent pas
les avocats parce que les avocats par
contre il se défendent, tu vois. C'est
pas la même chose. Ils leur disent
"Ouais, ben voilà, qui est votre source
sur tel dossier ? Qui est votre source
?" Et bon, les journalistes répondent
pas la plupart du temps. Quoi qu'il y en
a qui répondent, attention, il y en a
qui disent, "Tu sais, c'est aussi un
commerce et qui disent "OK, je veux bien
vous le dire en off, mais par contre,
est-ce que vous vous me garantissez
Bon bref euh mais oui oui c'est la en
fait la les les le numérique c'estàdire
que les appareils, les M catcher les les
écoutes téléphoniques et cetera font pas
de filtre hein. C'est c'est
quand tu dis ils interceptent les SMS
tout ça il ild que c'est comme si
j'avais ton téléphone dans la main sans
mot de passe. Ah bah oui bien sûr. Ouais
ouais ça choque tout. C'est-à-dire que
tu sais en France, je crois qu'on en
avait déjà parlé, euh on a une
spécialité en France qui nous est enviée
par tous les services de renseignement
au monde. D'ailleurs, c'est pour ça que
la DRM est sur des terrains d'opération
comme en Afghanistan ou ailleurs,
c'est l'exploitation des
hyperfréquences. C'est-à-dire que nous
avons inventé via bah les sociétés
françaises, Thomson et cetera, les bah
ce qu'on appelle les bandes
d'hyperfréquence, tu sais, tu as des
bandes notamment la bande K, bon, sans
rentrer dans les détails qui est la
bande au temp et il y a que nous qui
savons faire. C'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui tous les systèmes de
détection, les systèmes radar et cetera,
ça fonctionne sur justement des des des
fréquences euh donc qu'on appelle
hyperfréquence ou micro-ondes. C'est
exactement la même chose sans rentrer
dans les détails. Et la alors la
techniciens français, les ingénieurs
français ont la maîtrise totale des
ondes hyperfréquen et on est les seuls.
C'estàd que c'est une spécialité que
personne pourra nous enlever et euh et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on est on
est on n'est pas sur les terrains
d'opération pour fournir des troupes. On
n'est pas équipé en la matière, on est
là pour faire du renseignement et ça on
sait le faire. Et donc globalement
exploiter un téléphone portable à
distance bah via le Bluetooth, c'est un
jeu d'enfant. C'est-à-dire qu'on a des
des des fonctionnaires de la DGSI qui
viennent parfois dans les entreprises
dans le cadre si c'est un Samsung.
Ah bon ? Ouais. Bon, je pense pas que ça
fasse beaucoup de différences. Très
honnêtement, Apple,
c'est plus compliqué.
Ouais. Mais bon, en tout cas, ça on sait
faire via le Bluetooth. Mais après, par
contre, sans passer par le Bluetooth et
via justement les ondes hyperfréquences,
c'est-à-dire les ondes bah 3G, 4G, 5G et
cetera, rentrer dans un téléphone, bah
apparemment ça se fait de plus en plus
et les résultats sont assez probants.
C'est après, je veux dire, tout dépend
de qui on a en face de nous. Bon,
effectivement, tout le monde utilise son
téléphone portable aujourd'hui. C'est
pratique, mais c'est aussi une faiblesse
pour les gens qui ont des choses à se
reprocher.
Mais bon, bah par exemple dans les
cellules terroristes ou quoi que ce
soit, les gars ont bien compris que bah
il y avait rien de mieux que le pigeon
voyageur, le papier ou la parole hein,
je dirais encore la parole et
la parole fragmentée
fragmentée ou avec des interlocuteurs,
on va dire bon, on va dire qu'on a bien
entre guillemets débriefé, checké
dans un cadre sécurisé, je veux dire.
Voilà. Mais le numérique c'est une
faiblesse très clairement dans la
transmission d'info.
Alexandre B. Alors moi du coup je suis
sur les Yvelines, je travaille dans les
manifes mais du coup dans les Yvelines
on n pas des assez grosses manifes pour
avoir du matériel comme ça. Sur la
préfecture de police. La préfecture de
police a une particularité sur Paris,
c'est que ils font à la fois le rôle du
renseignement territorial les anciens RG
et à la fois le rôle de la DGSI. Donc en
fait ils ont le matériel et tout le
monde peut se mixer. Donc c'est ils sont
sous le même commandement, ils ont les
moyens de le faire.
Vous avez le droit d'en parler de ça
d'ailleurs ? Ben c'estd que c'est des
choses, c'est de l'organisationnel qu'on
peut trouver sur Wikipédia quasiment en
disant voilà c'est structuré comme ça,
c'est structuré comme ça. Enfin, je veux
dire là, il y a pas de secret d'état sur
le fait qu'ils ont les ils ont les
choses qui peuvent se passer sans
difficulté sur euh sur Paris. Après, sur
les autres endroits de France, c'est
plus compliqué parce qu'il y a la DG ici
qui a le matériel et le renseignement
territorial qui dépend de la sécurité
publique où c'est plus compliqué parce
que là, il y a pas de matériel, on
travaille avec pas grand-chose. Donc une
fois de plus, ça dépend des endroits,
mais les centres de pouvoir à ce qui
intéresse le gouvernement, c'est le
périmètre des lieux de pouvoir et de
leur lieu d'habitation. Donc sur Paris,
c'est fort problème mais en tout cas ils
ont la possibilité de le faire. Sur le
reste de la France, les manifestations
sont soit pas assez grandes, soit c'est
une gagère de service. Donc chacun fait
son truc dans son coin.
On dit on dit on dit souvent que la
police on a gros gros sur la patate
quand on voit des tirs de mortiers sur
des policiers
quand on voit des pétards
on va dire améliorés avec des bouteilles
de déodorant quand on voit des
projections d'acid quand on voit des
choses comme ça est-ce que c'est une
réponse aux techniques
contrainsurrectionnelles qu'il y a eu
sur la la population c'est-à-dire C'està
dire tir en pleine tête, nuucléation,
mutilation, gazage et donc la population
monte en puissance parce que l'armement
de la police monte en puissance ou c'est
l'inverse ?
Euh je dirais que alors entre les
lignes, je réponds à ta question juste
après. Euh les deux derniers samedis en
fait pour moi sont une mascarade.
C'est-à-dire que après l'affaire Michel
Zcler, je pense que il y a eu quelque
chose qui a été occulté par la presse
mais qui a certainement pas été
sous-estimé par les services de
renseignement. C'était un élan en fait
populaire en fait de ranqueur même
populaire et de haine contre la police.
C'està-dire qu'on peut pas occulter le
fait que si on était pas confiné, je
pense qu'on aurait eu des émeutes
urbaines façon clichés sous-bois ou même
peut-être même des émeutes
ethniquraciales façon rodnaking ou
autres. Et donc je pense que la police
bah elle a servi encore une fois à
apaiser la soif la colère populaire en
fait la soif de sang et de justice. Et
je pense que objectivement c'est pas une
accusation, c'est une suspicion mais je
pense que les deux derniers dispositifs
de répression de manifestation à Paris
ont été sous-dimensionnés et je pense
que ça a été fait volontairement. En
fait 1500 fonctionnaires de police
samedi dernier, c'est c'est une
plaisanterie, je veux dire mais je pense
que on
envoyé au carton. Bah oui, on avait
besoin d'imag et d'ailleurs ça a été le
discours des autorités et des syndicats
après de dire "Regardez euh finalement
vous plaignez pour Michel mais il y a
pas eu un seul mot pour notre collègue
là qui s'est fait lycher. Je veux dire
clairement on a créé les conditions qui
ont fait que ce collègue puisse se faire
lych parce que si c'est pas arrivé
depuis 2 ans, c'est bizarre que ça
arrive au même moment hein. Quand je dis
bizarre, c'est toute proportion gardée.
Mais quand effectivement on donne le
chiffre du dispositif policier, on
pouvait pas. Et d'ailleurs celui qui se
fait lycher, on entend wesh les gars à
un moment sur la vidéo. Donc on sait
très bien que c'est des populations de
banlieu qui sont venues venger justement
ce qui s'était passé au moment de
l'affaire Michel Zcler. Mais ça a été
voulu c'estàd que ce collègue là s'est
fait casser les dents parce qu'il a
fallu à un moment qu'on puisse sacrifier
un type je dirais pour créer justement
de l'image de l'émotion et dire mais
voilà bah finalement la violence elle
est des deux côtés.
Ah de la supputation. Effectivement, je
dis bien que c'est pas une accusation,
pour moi, c'est une hypothèse, mais si
on a été capable de de bah de mobiliser
sur certaines manifestations sans
escadrons ou 155 escadrons aux forces
maximale à un moment comme ça a été le
cas au début de la crise des gilets
jaunes, 1500 fonctionnaires sur Paris
dans un contexte qui est celui qu'on a
connu ces deux derniers samedis, je
pense que bah de toute façon, tu
parlais, tu poses la question de savoir
si la police é en déconfiture. Il y a un
moment où je pense qu'il faut arrêter la
philosophie, c'est-à-dire qu'il faut euh
fonctionner un petit peu à l'américaine
comme dans dans toutes les logiques
d'entreprise de rentabilité, c'est
est-ce que ça fonctionne ou est-ce que
ça fonctionne pas ? Quand à un moment tu
as Paris qui brûle, je veux dire tous
les samedis ou plusieurs samedis
d'affilé, c'est qu'il y a un problème,
c'est qu'il y a un type quelque part qui
prend une décision qui est pas la bonne.
Je veux dire, que ce soit sur la
répartition des forces, sur euh la
quantification justement des forces ou
autres, il y a un problème. Je veux
dire, si ça fonctionne pas, si on en
arrive à ce qu'une cinquantaine ou
peut-être 500, d'ailleurs, je j'ai le
comptage est pas du tout fiable. S'ils
étaient 5000 à Paris la semaine
dernière, pour moi, c'est une
circonstance aggravante. C'estàdire que
si on n'est pas capable de maîtriser
5000 personnes euh sur la capitale, je
veux dire que et que les mecs arrivent à
tout cramer, à mettre Paris à feu et à
sang sur deux arrondissements, je veux
dire qu'il y a un problème. Je pense que
et encore une fois, comme je te le
disais, bah moi depuis samedi dernier,
j'ai pas entendu le nom d'un
responsable. J'ai pas entendu que
quelque chose ait pu changer ou être
entrepris.
Tout de suite, je te donne la parole.
Est-ce que Est-ce que je vais poser une
question volontairement provoque, est-ce
que les black ne sont pas les idiots
utiles pour faire une victimisation de
la police et faire une victimisation de
la politique du gouvernement en disant
voilà on se fait taper dessus, on se
fait caillasser, ils nous lancent des
cailloux, ils sont très très organisés,
on narrive pas à les attraper, il faut
plus de sécurité, c'est à cause de ces
petits merdeux qui cassent des vitres
avec des petits marteaux, qui décrochent
les pa les les pavasses, qui nous
envoient de l'acide. Est-ce que c'est
pas les idiots utiles qui servent en fin
de compte les intérêts qui ne sont qui
desservent la police ? Euh moi je
toujours dit que c'était les idiots
utiles et ça fait des années depuis que
les méthodes de gestion du maintien de
l'ordre donc depuis Vals donc les lois
travail ont changé. Euh du coup oui,
c'est les idiots utiles parce qu'ils
permettent de faire des images choc
comme ça a été dit. Moi, je vais plus
loin sur ce que disait euh Noam, c'est
que effectivement quand on a des
collègues qui se retrouvent en unité
constituée sur un maintien de l'ordre en
difficulté de se faire lycher, je
rappelle que les unités constituées
agissent que sur ordre de la salle de
commandement. Ils peuvent pas prendre
d'initiative sur le terrain. C'est que
s'ils sont mis en difficulté, c'est
qu'il y a quelqu'un, soit un incompétent
qui sait pas donner les ordres, c'est
tout possible. Soit c'est quelqu'un qui
est dans la guerre de l'image. Ça aurait
été une unité de la BAC ou une unité en
civil qui est dans la manifestation qui
agit d'initiative. On aurait pu dire bah
voilà là ils sont fait prendre à partie
dans un coin. Là c'est pas possible si
on est bien dirigé de se faire prendre à
partie en unité constituée. Donc on est
dans cette garde de l'image et en plus
c'est très mauvais parce que le débat
est poussé sur vous êtes pour ou contre
la police. Suivant l'image que vous avez
Michel Zcler ou le policier lych et ben
vous allez répondre oui ou non. Alors
que le débat devrait être quelle police
on veut ? À quoi doit servir la police ?
Question internet. Comment les citoyens
pourraient reprendre le contrôle de la
police qui est à la main de l'État ?
Bah, il y a je moi sais qu'on se bat
depuis des années pour un IGPN citoyen.
Ce serait le premier domino à faire
tomber. Pourquoi ? Euh pour avoir
discuté avec des collègues anglais
britanniques, ils ont dit "Nous, on a
une un organisme indépendant de
contrôle." Et comment ça se passe ? Du
coup, c'est trois effets qui sont tout
de suite positifs. Premier effet, quand
les citoyens portent plainte, c'est pas
la police qu'enquête sur la police.
Nous, pour l'avoir fait, j'avais sé pour
des dysfonctionnements graves internes
de fait directeur. Finalement, c'est moi
qui suis retrouvé à l'IGPN pour manque
de loyauté et pas le directeur qui avait
couvert des manquements. Donc là, cette
transparence et ce contrôle citoyen
permet bah justement d'avoir confiance
en tous les cas dans la dans
l'institution. Et d'ailleurs la France a
signé un code éthique de police
européenne en 2001. Il y a marqué la
police n'a pas enquêté sur la police
parce que même si les fonctionnaires
font leur travail de façon objective et
très conscientieusement, il y aura
toujours une suspicion et une suspicion
n'est pas tolérable dans une démocratie.
D'ailleurs, les syndicats majoritaires
euh si tu regardes bien dans les médias,
ils défendent l'IGPN. Tu vois, en
théorie, euh c'est toujours "Ah, l'IGPN,
attention hein, quand on y va, on y va
un petit peu la boule au ventre. He !
C'est jamais de gaié de cœur."
C'est ça. Les bœufs carottes.
Ouais.
Oui, les bœufs carottes. Oui.
Et après la deuxième chose que permet
unpen citoyen donc déjà transparence
pour les citoyens. Voilà. avec bien sûr
dedans, il faut quand même un petit peu
comme les cours d'assise, il y a des
juris qui sont tirés au sort mais il
reste des magistrats professionnels pour
encadrer là. Il faut quand même des
policiers professionnels de terrain et
pas des bureaucrates de JPN parce que
ceux qui sont à l'égen qu'ils ont pas
mis un doigt de pied sur le terrain pour
la plupart. Deuxième chose immédiatement
positive, ça
c'est une accusation gratuite peut-être
non pas tu peux aller à l'IGPN te
promener les directeurs, les machins qui
sont là-bas.
De toute façon, l'IGPM le grade minimum
c'est brigadier chef et en général c'est
plutôt au minimum des officiers voir des
commissaires. C'estàdire que tu peux
pas, tu as pas de gardien de la paix.
par exemple à l'PNC en bas, voilà, celui
qui garde la porte ou qui fait
l'accueil, tu as des ADS, des gardiennes
de la paix, mais à la base euh il y a un
niveau minimum de grade qui est requis
pour pouvoir justement travailler comme
enquêteur parce que il faut quand même
qu'il y ait une autorité du grade sur la
personne justement qui est enquêtée, si
je puis dire. Voilà. Après, oui, ça
fonctionne pas. Après, je voulais finir
du coup
parce que mais sur euh pour les
policiers, les policiers en fait quand
il y a un problème dans un service,
quelqu'un qui dénonce un
dysfonctionnement, des actes de racisme,
ce qu'il veut en général, on lui dit il
faut mieux de taire sinon on t'envoie
l'Égyp parce que tu seras sanctionné
pour manque de loyauté, tu seras
sanctionné pour tenter de porter
atteinte au crédit renon de la police
nationale. Effectivement, le directeur,
il passe un coup de fil à son copain qui
est de l'autre côté et affaire régler.
Maintenant, si c'est un IGPN citoyen,
bah du coup, il y a plus cette pression
hiérarchique. Et les flics qui veulent
faire leur travail correctement, qui
veulent dénoncer les dysfonctionnements
des brebis galeuses, pourront le faire.
parce queils ils auront la l'appui
derrière d'une institution indépendante
et ils pourront expliquer les choses
pour faire changer les choses. Et 3è
point, ce que m'ont dit mes collègues
britanniques, c'est que bah du coup euh
un organisme indépendant permet
d'améliorer le service public. Ils m'ont
dit "En Angleterre, on a eu des émeutes
urbaines en 2012" de mémoire euh grave,
ils ont agi dans l'action, ils ont tiré
dans le tas, ils ont fait enfin ils ont
fait enfin tirer dans le tas, ils ont
utilisé de la manière forte pour établir
l'ordre. Ils ont dit après il y a eu un
retour d'expérience, qu'est-ce qui a
marché ? Qu'est-ce qui était pertinent ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on a bien fait pour que la
prochaine fois que ça se reproduise, ben
on commette pas les mêmes erreurs, que
ce qu'à marché on le garde et qu'on
essaie de trouver des solutions pour là
où on a merdé. En France, c'est
exactement l'inverse de l'IGPN puisque
l'PN aussi un rôle d'inspection des
services pour dans le but
d'amélioration. Mais comme me dit un de
mes copains commissaires, il m'a dit
"Regarde les notes de service des
directeurs. À chaque fois c'est marqué à
la fin, veuillez me rendre compte de
toute difficulté dans la l'application
de la présente note de service. Il m'a
dit je te fais la traduction en français
moyen. Ça veut dire si jamais vous
appliquez pas mes ordres, c'est vous qui
êtes incompétent. Donc ta carrière et ta
mutation, tu l'auras pas." Donc c'està
dire qu'un directeur peut dire très
clairement à une caméra "Moi, j'ai fait
une note de service et tout va bien
parce que j'ai pas de retour négatif."
En Angleterre, c'est l'inverse. Le chef
de service qui donne un ordre, il va
vérifier qu'il est bien impliqué,
comment ça se passe ? Parce que c'est
lui qui a donné l'ordre. Donc il
vérifie. Chez nous, on est en fait, on
inverse le truc en disant si jamais tu
me dis que ça va pas, bah c'est de ta
faute. Si tu me dis rien, c'est que ça
va. Donc c'est parfait. Donc on est dans
le déni, on ment et on ne regarde pas
les choses.
De toute façon, il y a un problème
structurel parce que nous par exemple
quand on travaillant au renseignement,
tu à un moment tu es bah quand tu
travailles quand tu es recruté par le
renseignement, tu es candidat à une
habilitation. Donc bah on fait une
enquête d'environnement sur toi, on te
demande qui est ta femme, euh qui sont
tes sœurs, avec qui est-ce que tu
couches.
Ouais. Voilà. Est-ce que tu manges du
cochon, est-ce que tu préfères le vin
rouge ? Je veux dire, tu vois, il
s'intéresse à des détails de ta vie
complètement insignifiants. Tu regardes
les deux dernières directrices de l'IGPN
contre qui j'ai absolument rien.
Marie-France Monéger qui était bon,
c'était la femme du directeur de la PAF
d'Orly d'ailleurs qui a été infiltré qui
a été tamponné par le Maroc et par les
Israéliens. Tu sais, ça avit fait
l'objet d'un article dans Libé.
Magnifique.
Voilà. Donc du coup
donc du coup il y avait un lien tu vois
tu peux pas à un moment il y avait un
conflit d'intérêt c'estàd que lui il est
directeur
justement du d'une d'une institution la
pave d'Orli qui est quand même un
service actif donc il
voilà clé d'ailleurs. Et donc il il est
marié à la à la directrice de l'IGPN.
Donc tu peux tu peux j'ai j'ai aucun
doute sur leur honnêteté ou leur probité
mais je veux dire
tu vois c'est bon voilà il y a des liens
quand même il y a un lien qui est quand
même qui peut être un peu vie privé il
mais je vais rebondir sur les que tu
donnes parce qu'en fait il est très
important et très intéressant c'est que
le juge d'instruction en charge du
dossier en juilleta août de cet été
s'est plein en disant mon enquête a été
orientée par l'IGPN parce que il y avait
le son mari l'ancienne directrice qui
était là-bas et il s'en est plein dans
les colones du Parisien donc pour juge
d'instruction s'en plaign dans les
colonnes d'un journal je veux dire grand
public, je veux dire, on en est là. Donc
c'est ce problème de l'IGPN.
Effectivement, il y a des conflits
d'intérêt à tous les étages et un
contrôle indépendant permettrait de les
éviter. Et
la nouvelle directrice au Brigitte
Julien que je connais pas était
l'ancienne épouse de René B qui est
l'ancien des RPP, donc directeur du
renseignement de la de la procture de
police.
Mais je veux dire non mais c'est tu peux
pas, tu sais c'est elle est l'IGPN est
là pour enquêter sur les services
actifs. Donc tu as la femme est
directrice d'un service qui va enquêter
sur des fonctionnaires de la DRPP. Donc
il y a il y a quand même bien sûr on
peut pas présumer
d'un passage d'information de discussion
autour de la table ou sur l'oreiller. On
va dire bah tiens, tu sais quoi ? J'ai
une enquête en ce moment sur ton mec là
qui tuis mais c'est il y a un problème,
je veux dire on peut on peut présumer de
rien. Et d'ailleurs il se dit dans à la
DRPP puisque c'est un petit peu bah
c'est un service qui a une histoire
queah à l'époque je crois que c'était un
mari un peu jaloux et qu'il avait
branché sur écoute. Donc si on a des
sources qui peuvent voilà mais c'est
quelque chose qui se disait dans les
murs de la DRPP. C'est pas du tout une
accusation, c'était une rumeur.
Beaucoup de couloirs qui qui voilà c'est
magazine de la PP quoi si tu veux. Si tu
veux rebondir sur les collusions entre
service enquêteurs ou pas, même sans
aller chepen le fait que la police
s'enquête sur elle-même, on a l'affaire
jeun Viève le gayet, je veux dire voilà,
là c'est la femme qui enquête sur le
mari ou dans je sais plus dans quel sens
mais du coup ça fait voilà et je veux
dire on voit pas le conflit d'intérêt
donc si il y a un conflit d'intérêt donc
à partir de là c'est toutes ces
suspicions c'estàd que c'est leur vie
privée oui mais c'est un impact sur la
leur vie et leur fonction publique et
leur qualité de l'enquête
donc une fois de plus un IGPN citoyen,
un contrôle citoyen de la police
permettrait d'éviter tous ces conflits
d'intérêt toutes ces susp
On va dire tu es chef de service par
exemple. Allez, tu t'appelles René B, tu
as envie de plomber un de tes effectifs.
Bon bah, tu as ta femme qui a le soir
qui rentre à la maison qui est
directrice de l'IGPN. Je veux dire,
j'aimerais pas être à la place du mec
que René a envie de plomber. Tu vois ce
que je veux dire ?
C'est des suputations.
Oui, mais non mais on peut pas ne pas se
poser la question, tu vois. Je veux
dire, quand le mec passait dans les
couleurs, on dire fais gaffe, lui, tu
sais, sa femme, c'est la chef de l'IGPN.
Bon, elle l'était pas à l'époque, je
veux dire. Mais ce que je veux dire par
là, c'est que en théorie, bah c'est pour
ça qu'il faudrait de l'indépendance
justement de la part de cette
institution. Je suis même pas sûr
qu'elle devrait en réalité être dirigée
par des des des haut fonctionnaires de
la police nationale. Tu sais par
exemple, tu as le le Centre national de
traitement automatisé des infractions
qui a à Renn. Je veux dire, il est il
est la le chef de service a un statut de
de magistrat, c'est que c'est un
procureur, tu sais, qui gère ce truclà
et puis après tu as des employés, tu as
de la sous-traitance et je veux dire et
l'IGPN effectivement ce sont des
fonctionnaires de police donc ça pose un
problème. Je ça a pas fait ses preuves,
ça fonctionne pas. C'est pas, tu vois,
on peut parler de supputation, de ce que
tu veux, mais ça marche pas. Je
Zinebouan, elle est morte aujourd'hui.
On sait pas qui a tiré. Il suffit que
les gars disent non, c'est pas moi et
puis on va pas chercher plus loin alors
qu'on a des vidéos, on a des images.
Couvre régulièrement
et c'est même plus fort que ça parce que
pour revenir tout à l'heure, tu disais
est-ce que c'est une volonté ou pas de
couvrir les agissements les plus
dégueulasses. Le capitaine qui encadrait
les CRS qu'on tiré par exemple chez
Zinem sur Zinem Redan a refusé de donner
les armes à l'IGPN et il a eu une
promotion derrière. Il est passé euh
capitaine sur un poste pour devenir
commandant dans une compagnie à Lyon. Et
les gars, ils disent voilà donc en fait
c'est compliqué de récompenser ces
comportements là. Et si on veut
l'honnêteté de l'IGPN, on peut voir une
enquête, c'était sur l'affaire Steve
Nant, il y a la partie IGPN. Donc le
commandant de CRS qui est le spécialiste
de matière Lud qui est sur place, donc
c'était un jeune donc Steve qui est mort
dans la Loire un 21 juin pour la fête de
la musique dans un endroit où autour il
y a personne qui habite. Donc voilà, ils
ont déjà de la famille à Nant qui me
disent là-bas c'est habituel que la fête
de la musique dépasse. Effectivement
c'est pas légal mais ça gêne personne.
Et le commandant de CRS qui était sur
place a dit on va pas faire ça, il y a
la loire derrière, c'est dangereux. Les
GPN a annexé son rapport à la fin du
rapport et ils ont dit non, il y a pas
de faute de la police, il y a pas de
problème. Avec un deuxième problème que
l'IGPN a eu, c'est que l'IGPN n'est pas
capable et n'a pas dans ses pouvoirs
d'attribution l'enquête sur les préfets.
C'est quand on attaque le corps
préfectoral, c'est circuler, il y a rien
à voir. Là, faut saisir l'inspection
générale de l'administration. Et du
coup, on a eu l'enquête judiciaire.
Donc, c'est quand même la police
judiciaire qui a fait l'enquête, mais
pas sous tutelle administrative d'un
commissaire, mais d'un magistrat. Et les
conclusions de l'enquête ont été un peu
diamétralement opposées. Donc, on voit
bien qu'il y a ce côté biaisé. euh de
l'enquête même sans aller chercher très
loin et que c'est bien au niveau de la
tête et la direction de l'enquête que ça
pose problème, pas forcément les
fonctionnaires qui la font parce qu'il y
a des fonctionnaires de la police
judiciaire qui ont fait l'enquête de
l'autre côté de l'GPN mais les
conclusions en fonction de qui dirige
l'enquête sont pas les mêmes.
Mais même tu te mets à la place du du
citoyen français, je veux dire, tu
regardes ces affaireslà comme l'affaire
Zinebréan, tu t'aperçois qu'il y avait
un substitut du procureur sur place, que
le mec a un petit peu caché la poussière
sous le tapis. Finalement, il s'est fait
prendre la main dans le sac par une
vidéo amateur justement donc article 24
et à la fin il se fait épingler par
Mediapart et donc il est muté je crois
dans le grand test. Euh tu as le rapport
d'autopsie de Zinebouan qui précise que
elle est morte d'un choc anaphylactique
ou quelque chose dans ce genre et puis à
la fin les Algériens disent "Attendez,
on va quand même regarder ce qui se
passe." Tu as les services médicaux
légaux algériens qui disent "Ah non,
elle a reçu un projectile en pleine
tête. Elle a des os visage qui sont
brisées. Elle est morte à la suite
justement d'un tir." Tu vois, ça donne
pas confiance. Je veux dire, tu te dis
tiens mais tu es citoyen français, tu
dis merde c'est une mafia ce truc ou
quoi ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe quoi ?
même pire sur Fin c'est qu'on a le
ministre Castaner à l'époque qui a dit
elle est morte à cause de le l'opération
c'est dire qu'en fait il a accusé les
médecins et pas les policiers donc je
veux dire je rappelle la petite séquence
donc je veux dire voilà on est dans le
déni de ce qui se passe dans la police
et là on a fêté il y a les la mort de
Malikusikim qui était mort 6 décembre en
on a pas fêté on a commémoré
on a commémoré pardon oui voilà je veux
dire on fêté dans le sens commémoration
ou merci de me reprendre et mais je veux
dire voilà c'est là où on a quand on a
un personnel politique à l'époque
c'était Charles Pasquois le ministre de
l'intérieur
Voilà donc personne pourra taxer de
laxisme. Voilà donc ça sur le truc. Par
contre ce qu'il a fait, il a fait un
acte politique derrière. Il a dit "Je
dissou les voltigeur.
Alors provenons la
et je et je présente mes excuses à la
famille et nous on fait la brave et on
ne présente pas d'excuses." Donc voilà.
Alors qu'est-ce qui se passe là ? On a
l'impression que là moi on voit passer
des vidéos sur internet la brave sont
vraiment sont ils prennent beaucoup de
caféine. Non
moi j'invite les gens tu prends un coup
de tonfa. Je veux dire même à faible. Tu
sais, nous quand on s'entraînait à
l'école de police, c avec des tonf en
mousse.
Attends, je te coupe, tu veux une petite
blague là, histoire que
tu sais pourquoi les policiers ils
tapent jamais au tonfa sur les les
légionnaires qui font un peu trop la
fête ? Parce que tout le temps le tonfa,
ils se leur prennent dans la gueule.
Donc ils ont arrêté.
D'accord.
Vas-y, continue.
Ça m'étonne pas. Après, tu sais, tu
prends un coup de ton phare, je veux
dire, un ton phare bois classique, même
tu sais si tu si c'est un coup
d'entraînement ou de juste pour de
sensibilité, ça fait mal. Franchement,
ça fait mal. Euh si on accélère un petit
peu la vitesse du cou, ça fait très très
mal honnêtement dans sur les extrémités,
sur les eaux, ça fait mal. Si tu ajoutes
ça à la vitesse quand même euh
centrifuge, tu as d'une moto, je veux
dire qui roule déjà à 30 ou 50 km/h, ah,
ça fait très très mal. Ça tue même hein,
je veux dire, Malikusekin, je veux dire,
il s'en est pas relevé hein. À 22 ans,
ils l'ont et d'ailleurs, tu sais, c'est
c'est Pierre Joc en 86 qui a fait en
fait qui qui a mis en place le code de
déontologie. À l'époque, il y avait euh
des mouvements de rue, des mouvements
populaires, mais il y avait le sentiment
d'une véritable interaction avec le
gouvernement, ce qui a complètement
disparu aujourd'hui. C'est
qu'aujourd'hui, c'est cause toujours
hein. Je veux dire, comme le disait
Rafarain à l'époque, c'est pas la rue
qui gouverne, mais au moins Rafarin, il
répondait là aujourd'hui, tu as
l'impression de crier dans le désert.
Mais bon, il y avait une réaction de de
Pierre Jox à l'époque he qui a mis en
place un code de déontologie. D'ailleurs
aujourd'hui, je pense qu'il serait
raisonnable peut-être de bah de faire
une remise à plat comme ça a été fait à
l'époque.
Mais je veux dire, Malikusekin, sais, il
y a un symbole. C'estàdire que moi je
suis pas de cette génération parce qu'à
l'époque j'étais à l'école primaire mais
je me souviens des grands frères lycéens
universitaires qui allaient manifester à
l'époque et Malik Kousekin en fait
c'était à l'époque des cités en 86 à
l'époque de la marche pour l'égalité
quelqu'un qui avait eu accès aux études
supérieures. Donc c'était quand même un
cas d'exception. C'est le mec c'était
une tronche. Il avait réussi à prendre
la tête d'un syndicat universitaire.
C'était quelqu'un qui avait un
engagement politique et en plus il avait
délaissé la culture de ses parents.
C'estd qu'il était plus musulman, il
allait être intronisé prêtre. Il allait
devenir prêtre. Et donc les mecs de cité
à l'époque se sont dit merde [__] le
mec il a donné il a coché toutes les
cases de l'intégration finalement et la
réponse à tout ça ça a été de le
massacrer à coup de parce que c'est pas
une mort si tu veux tu vois c'est une
mort à façon afghane hein ce qu'ils
l'ont fait ils l'ont massacré hémorragie
cérébrale et cetera il il s'est vidé de
son sang à coup de tonfa je veux dire
donc et tu vois à l'époque je pense que
ça la l'intégration à l'époque he
puisque c'était quelque chose qui était
recherché par ces population c'est une
volonté d'intégration d'écoute de la
part des gouvernement c'est quelque
chose parce qu'elle a fait 10 pas en
arrière à cette époque avec la mort de
Malikusekin. Même moi je m'en souviens
pour te dire alors que j'étais gamin à
l'époque, ils sont dit bah tiens, tu
vois il y a un arabe, il est devenu
prêtre, il a fait des études, il s'est
engagé, il avait pas de casier
judiciaire et ils l'ont massacré comme
un animal sur la voie publique. Et on
m'a dit bah tu vois à l'époque les mecs
de cité disaient "Bah fais gaffe, il y a
un moment où bah tu t'apercevras que aux
yeux des policiers, tu seras toujours un
arabe." Bon ça m'a pas empêché de
devenir flic par la suite.
Subi du racisme.
Ah bah bien entendu. Bah oui. Bah
évidemment. Non mais c'est c'est dans la
police nationale les gens qui te disent
"J'ai jamais connu le racisme", ils sont
payés pour ça. Je veux dire c'est pas
possible. Tu sais c'est le racisme
existe. Je dis pas que ça doit tout
justifier, tout expliquer, mais bien
entendu
partout. Mais je veux dire, est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est une explication
suffisante de dire que c'est pas partout
? Bien sûr, en France, il y a du racisme
et toi tu es pas raciste. Lui, il vous
l'aide pas, je veux dire. Mais ça veut
pas dire qu'il y en a pas et qu'il faut
pas s'en occuper. Donc dans la police
aujourd'hui, le discours officiel, c'est
de dire d'une part, il y a pas de
violence policière. Je m'étouffe quand
je prononce le terme de violence
policière. Il y a pas de racisme. C'est
magnifique. Suivant quoi. Je veux dire,
non mais attends en fait et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça moi tu parlait de la
police en difficulte. C'est pour ça que
moi j'ai décidé de jeter l'éponge parce
qu'il y a un moment où tu te dis ça y
est quoi. Je veux dire tu là tu es à un
stade où tu peux plus lutter. Je veux
dire à ce niveau de de de déniis tu peux
rien faire. Je veux dire là on n'est pas
sur du pefinage ou sur du détail. Le mec
te dit il y a pas de violence policière,
il y a pas de racisme dans la police.
Bon bah tu dis c'est bon quoi. Je veux
dire là on part de trop loin tu vois. Ça
serrage
mais
voilà
pour je vais rebondir sur la réponse sur
les braves. Ils font peur. Oui mais
c'est des volontaires donc forcément ça
attire un certain type de personnes qui
veulent aller dans ces unités. C'estd
que quand tu as une unité de CRS, une
unité de la BAC ou ce que tu veux, c'est
des collègues qui ont l'habitude de
travailler ensemble qui se connaissent
et tu as toujours souvent un
contrepoids. Enfin il y a un équilibre
qui peut se créer en disant même des
règlements de compte après tu as
déconné. Voilà c'est que des volontaires
qui se voient pour une journée qui le
soir il y en a plus. Et en fait c'est
les techniques de un petit peu des
régiments de marche qu'elle avait été
utile. C'est qu'on met des gens pour une
mission et après dispersion. C'est des
mecs qui sont cagoulés avec des cases de
moto. Tu sais a priori en plus c'est
souvent des cases personnelles. Ils ont
pas de numéro, ils ont rien. Ils peuvent
faire le coup de main derrière et du
coup à partir de là oui ça atre un
certain profil et des fois ils en
avaient pas assez. Donc ça c'est la
bonne nouvelle c'est que des fois ils
arrivent pas à en recruter assez. Il y a
des collègues qu'on leur a forcé, on
leur dit "Tu vas être volontaire pour y
aller." Et ben il y en a qui ont dit
"Non, mais ils ont pris des sanctions du
coup parce qu'ils avaient pas été
volontaires pour conduire les motos des
braves." Ils ont dit "Moi, je suis
rentré pour être motard de la police
nationale, pas pour aller faire le coup
de main en manif." Donc voilà où on en
est. Donc voilà. Oui, les braves sont
dangereux. Oui, les braves ont été mis
là pour ça. Et oui, en plus, tout est
fait pour pas qu'on les retrouve. Donc
après, en plus, ils sont doublement
protégés. Donc ça pose un problème. Et
pour rebondir sur le racisme, c'est dès
l'école de police. On a une collègue à
l'école d'onim encore parce que c'est la
plus grosse école de France donc c'est
normal que ça consente aussi une gros
partie des problèmes. Euh sa famille
était arqu, elle a dit "Moi, je vais
m'engager pour servir la France comme ma
famille. À l'école de police, ça s'est
fait traiter de bigot, de salle arabe et
cetera. Elle a commencé à vouloir dire
"Mais attendez de moi, elle se laissait
faire parce qu'elle dit "Bon ben, je
veux rester, je veux pas casser le
groupe, je veux" puis bon, nor on a eu
marre, elle a fait un rapport mais du
coup on lui a dit que c'est celle qu'on
va poursuivre. Ils lu ont monté une
cabale. Elles ont dit voilà, elle a été
convoquée par son supérieur. Ils lui ont
dit bah voilà, tu avais une cartouche
dans ton sac, elle est là là la photo.
Elle a dit le sac là, vous l'avez pris
en photo. J'étais en examen, j'étais pas
à côté. S'il y avait un doute, fallait
tout de suite.
J'imagine bien que dans le sac d'une
musulmane, c'est ça monte he ça la
mayonnaise, elle prend hein. Résultat
des courses, les gens qui ont tenu les
propos racistes à son encontre, on a dit
voilà tu cherches la merde, tu es le pot
de terre contre le pot de fer, on va te
briser et cetera. Et c'est ce qu'ils ont
essayé de faire. Et là même, ils ont
dit, ils ont prétexté euh du coup suite
à ça, ça lui a fait un choc
psychologique. Euh résultat des courses,
ils lui ont coupé son salaire parce
qu'il lui ont mis un abandon de poste en
disant "Ah ben oui, on n'a pas eu le
truc de la médecine statutaire, donc on
savait pas que tu étais en arrêt
maladie. Du coup, on t'a coupé ton
salaire."
Donc du coup, résultat des courses, on
s'en est mêlé. Résultat des courses, ça
va intégrer une autre école de police.
Ils vont régulariser la situation. Mais
je veux dire, la personne qui est toute
seule, qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ? Bah,
elle est foutue en fait parce que il lui
coupe tout et cetera. Et donc là même
une sénatrice a posé la question au
gouvernement attend toujours sa réponse
et c'était en juillet dernier pour
savoir cette situation est-ce que c'est
normal des gens qui veulent service la
France qui se sont intégré ces gens-là
se font encore insultés et c'est ceux
qui insultent qui sont protégés. Non
mais voilà et en cette école il y avait
un autre groupe Pois il y a quelques
années qui avait aussi tenu des propos
racistes pareil parce que fallait for
sortir les gens de l'école de police.
Ils ont juste été dispatchés dans
différents endroits et la personne
victime en plus était un quelqu'un avec
un grade d'officiers. D'habitude la
hiérarchie, on nous dit toujours dans la
police c'est des dieux sur terre et de
toute façon vous on soutiendra toujours
la hiérarchie quoi qu'il arrive. Là du
coup bah non, on a soutenu les euh je
dans une manifestation euh à l'époque
George Flotte, j'ai croisé une
journaliste, bon je vais pas la citer.
George Floyd, il faut expliquer.
Oui, c'est le le ce ce noir américain
qui avait été étouffé, qui avait
prononcé les moyen anden breath au
moment où il a été étouffé par policiers
américains. Et donc ça avait déclenché
voilà, c'est ça. Et donc ça avait
déclenché un élan euh de de solidarité,
d'émotion dans dans à travers la
planète. Et on a eu des manifes en
France. Et après on au même moment bah
on a eu l'affaire du TGI de Rouan où on
avait un policier noir du tribunal de
grandance de Rouan. On avait un policier
de couleur qui avait été ciblé par ses
collègues et puis ensuite on avait eu un
déchaînement de haine raciste. C'est
Street Press qui avait sorti le le
dossier et bon les fonctionnaires sont
restés en poste pendant 6 mois et quand
il y a eu cette affaire George Floyd,
bon au niveau de la DGPN, ils ont
commencé à se dire "Bon, on va quand
même essayer de faire un petit peu de
semblant de ménage dans nos rangs et
donc les fonctionnaires bon pour trois
d'entre eux en tout cas sont passés en
discipline, ont été révoqués. Et à un
moment quand il y a eu bah justement ce
rebond de
ils ont pas fait de tôle.
Ah non non. Oh non. Bah non faut pas
trop en demander non plus. Déjà ils ont
été révoqués. C'est pour trois d'entre
eux pas les six parce qu'ils étaient six
mises en cause. Bon c'est déjà assez
exceptionnel. Je pense que bah il y
avait à ce moment-là justement des notes
DRG qui disaient "Attention on a on a la
minorérité noire qui risque de monter au
créneau et cetera." Donc ils ont flippé.
Puis en plus bon les fonseurs du TG Dron
ont eu la maladresse aussi de parler de
Youupin. Ils ont mis les juifs dans
l'histoire. Donc je pense que ça ça
alourdi un petit peu leur fardeau. Et
justement bah j'allais revenir là, la
journaliste qui est quand même une
personne assez connue dans le monde du
journalisme me dit "On était habitué au
racisme antimagrébain mais là c'est
quand même surprenant qu'ils aient mis
les noirs et les juifs dans le même sac
si ça avait été que les maghrébas." Et
tu vois c'est un truc qui est rentré
dans la dans la conso collective c'est
que les maghrébains, tu peux t'essuyer
les pieds dessus, tu peux cracher
dessus, il y a pas de problème. Les
noirs c'est un peu plus étonnant. On se
dit tiens ben c'est bizarre, il y a des
noirs dans la police. Et les juifs là,
alors là ça a été leur voilà. Mais après
euh global
il y a il y a du racisme antigay, il y a
du racisme anti toutous ou pas ?
Euh oui euh je pense que c'est pas du
racisme mais c'est effectivement de la
sur les genres et cetera et c'est pas
pour rien qu'il y ait une association
flaque dans la police qui se bat contre
les discriminations LGBT parce qu'il y
en a malheureusement aussi. Donc en fait
c'est voilà ils ont ils imaginent qu'il
y a une norme et si tu rentres pas dans
cette norme bah ils vont tout faire pour
te problème de la police aujourd'hui à
mon avis l'un des problèmes c'est que
c'est une institution qui est un peu
vieillotte. C'estàdire que quand tu
arrives à l'école, tu as l'impression
que tu vois limite, tu sais les
procédures, on les faisait à la main
avec un ancreur et tout. Tu vois, tuas
tu l'impression qu' on va te sortir la
machine à écrire, tu sais, des années 80
pour taper les procédures. Moi quand
j'ai appris, j'ai été formé, toi aussi
peut-être d'ailleurs, on a été formé sur
une application qui s'appelait LRP pour
taper les procédures judiciaires. LP, ça
fonctionnait sous MS dos. Alors pour
ceux les les alors les gens qui sauront
ce que c'est, c'est un langage
informatique. Ça c'était l'Amstrade là à
l'époque quand on était gamin. Bah
c'est en basique.
Ouais c'est ça. Bah c'est du MS DOS.
C'était un logiciel qui fonctionnait
sous MS, qui avait été créé par un
gendarme à l'époque dans son garage et
puis qui avait été et je crois que ça a
été le le LRP a été aboli, je crois en
2011, mais jusque là on utilisait encore
cette application là et tu vois et dans
la police c'était un petit peu la même
chose, c'est le ceinturon en cuir, les
Rangers en cuir alors qu'au tu vois les
les Rangers en cuir va courir avec ça
quoi. Je veux dire, c'est impossible. Et
euh en dotation aujourd'hui, tu as ça.
Ils savent pas qu'il y a des trucs en
toile, tu sais, qui sont aussi
imperméables, tu vois. Je veux dire, ils
sont restés sur des schémas très
anciens, très traditionnels et idem sur
bah la chaîne hiérarchique, sur
l'émission et ca. Il y a plein de trucs
en fait qui sont qui sont plus au goût
du jour, tu sais. Et et je pense que
c'est un petit peu ça. L'administration
policière en fait, elle a elle a pas su
prendre le pas de la modernité à mon
sens.
Revenons revenons à à nos black block.
On dit tout le temps, on entend souvent
qu'il y aurait des agents provocateurs.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu parler
d'agents provocateurs ? Des mecs qui se
déguisent en black block qui vont aller
tout péter ?
Alors moi, j'ai jamais entendu parler
mais pour après, c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure, c'est qu'il y a déjà
assez d'idiots utiles qui permettent de
le faire. Donc pourquoi s'embêter
envoyer des agents provocateurs ? Après
chaque image qui ont été tourné à chaque
fois, il y avait eu par exemple des
policiers avec des marteaux qui ont été
tournés mais parce qu'ils avaient
confisqué des marteaux a priori, il y
avait des une vitrine de banque qui
était cassée avec des policiers dedans.
Oui. Bah parce qu'ils essayaient de
faire le flagrant des lit avec les gens
dedans. Donc en fait on a eu plein de
légendes urbaines qui ont été écrites
sur ça, mais il y a eu aucune preuve et
moi je n'en ai jamais vu. Je me suis
renseigné pour essayer de savoir. Je
n'ai pas eu non plus. Mais après ça veut
pas dire que ça n'existe pas. Mais moi
je n'ai pas les preuves et je n'ai pas
eu les choses. Et à l'heure actuelle je
ne pense pas que ce soit utile parce que
par contre il y a les Black Block
peuvent déjà faire ce qu'ils veulent.
Ouais, il suffit il suffit de moduler le
dispositif de maintien de l'ordre et les
mecs ils démarrent tout seul. Il y a pas
besoin à mon sens.
Par contre des sources dans les
mouvements contestatair, il y en a plein
franchement.
Alors, c'est un peu choquant ce que je
vais dire peut-être hein parce que c'est
valable aussi pour les milieux cités et
cetera
que comme pour les mouvements gilets
jaunes. D'ailleurs, je tes confrères du
média ont sorti une vidéo, tu sais, d'un
d'un dialogue téléphonique entre un une
source du RT et un agent traitant où il
lui dit "Attention, je vais te remettre
dans le charter, faut que tu fasses c,
faut que tu fasses ça." Voilà. Et euh en
fait, tu peux pas euh alors pour l'avoir
vécu hein, moi ce que je retiens de de
tout ça, du tout cet élan associatif,
politique, tu il faut pas sous-estimer
euh la capacité de compromission en fait
de l'être humain. C'est-à-dire que tous
les milieux et c'est ce qui fait la
force de l'État français euh au travers
sa de sa capacité justement à corrompre
les individus par euh la résolution de
problèmes judiciaires, administratifs,
par le paiement aussi en numéraire, la
la capacité de compromission des gens.
C'est-à-dire que tu as des balances
partout, les cités sont truffé de
balance. Tu vois, on dit souvent oui la
balance, il y a un profil type, ça peut
être une nana, ça peut être un gros
black de 2 m qui qui boxe et qui pèse
130 kg, ça peut mais tu as des balances
partout. Alors là, les candidats à la
délation en France ne manquent pas et
c'est pas propre à la France. Je pense
que c'est partout mais je veux dire
quand même une grande
Oh là là là mon dieu ! Mais sais c'est
et je pense que les mouvements type
gilets jaune et d'ailleurs ça se
perçoit, je veux dire je pense sont très
largement infiltrés comme les mouvements
black et cetera. Donc je pense que les
autorités ouais sont largement au
courant de de ce qui se trame en
général. Après tu peux verrouiller les
dispositifs et cetera, mais je pense que
ils sont pas à ce niveau qui leur permet
justement de pouvoir avancer sans sans
être anticipé. Et tu disais tu disais
que si on module le dispositif, il
partent tout seul. Ça veut dire quoi ça
? Bah
tu sais très bien que c'est des
mouvements, je dirais à potentialité
violente hein. Clairement, je veux dire
que quand ils viennent dans une
manifestation, ils sont équipés. Bon
après, ils ont des stratégies.
C'est-à-dire que c'est sur les terrains
de manifestation pour en avoir encadré
quelques-unes, he je pense ça fait
partie aussi de notre boulot. Bah en
amont, quand tu as des parcours qui sont
prédéfinis ou qui sont tracés, des fois
tu passes le la veille, tu vas fouiller
sous les bancs et cetera, tu vas trouver
des marteaux, des pierres. Bon, des fois
les terrains sont préparés. Donc en
général, bah c'est des gens qui
demandent juste à démarrer hein, il faut
juste l'étincelle et puis ça part tout
seul. Bon après, si tu as envie que ça
parte en live, tu as pas besoin
d'infiltrer des agences. C'est-à-dire
que globalement je pense hein, tu tu
écartes un petit peu le dispositif quand
tu repères un petit peu les profils
d'excité, tuenvoies une grenade
lacrymogène et ça démarre hein. Je veux
dire globalement
même sans ça parce queon a eu des cas en
fait très particuliers où c'est même
voulu, c'était bon en 2014 là, il y a eu
le le parcours type de comment on veut
faire pour que les Blackbox fassent ce
qu'ils veulent. Il y avait les services
de renseignement qu' on dit il y a à peu
près 2 300 personnes qui arrivent gard
du nord mouvance black block et j'avais
un des collègues en CRS à ce momentl qui
on dit c'est génial ils arrivent droit
sur nous parce qu'ils voulaient
rejoindre place de la République où il y
avait une nuit debout euh on leur a
donné l'ordre vous vous poussez et vous
les laissez passer
qui a donné l'ordre
la préfecture de police dans la salle de
commandement après sur le terrain ils
savent pas ça descend de
il a des sources il y a des sources de
ça
ah mais c'est même sorti dans la presse
donc il y a pas de problème. Et résultat
des courses, ils vont place de la
République, ces braves gens. Comme ils
ont la possibilité d'y aller sans être
inquiété, là-bas, ils engrainent
quelques personnes, quelques
dégradations. Ils vont dégrader le
commissariat de quartier, toujours pas
de réaction des autorités publiques. Et
puis après dans la foule, ils entendent
"Allez, on va prendre l'apéro chevals
qui habite dans le quartier." 30
minutes, tout le monde a été serré,
dispersion, dizaine d'interpellation,
fin du mouvement. Donc en fait quand on
veut le faire, on sait faire. Encore
faut-il qu'on ait les ordres.
Par exemple, je donne un exemple pour
rebondir sur l'affaire. Moi à l'époque,
bon, j'avais déjà quitté le
renseignement mais j'étais toujours en
lien avec bah j'habite à côté d'Ol
sousois donc j'étais allé faire un petit
tour et j'avais le député de la Circo
qui faisait partie de mes contacts
amicaux. C'est quelqu'un que j'aimais
bien. Il s'inquiétait pour la situation.
Il m'a dit "Bah tenez, est-ce que ça
vous dit de de passer voir ce qui se
passe parce que votre avis m'intéresse
et j'y vais."
Bon, il y avait pas eu les les les les
premiers débordements avaient pas eu
lieu, c'est-à-dire qu'on savait qu'il y
avait un risque important et donc moi,
je vais sur la cité du Gallion à Holné
sous-bois pour prendre la température et
bizarrement je l'appelle et je dis
"Monsieur, il y a un problème, c'est que
toutes les lumières sont éteintes. On
était dans le c'était le blackout total.
Il y avait pas une lumière allumée. Même
moi, j'avançais, je savais pas, j'avais
peur de me prendre une voiture ou un
truc parce que c'était il faisait nuit
noire, c'était voilà. Et donc à un
moment, je dis mais est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Est-ce que
c'est un dysfonctionnement ? Est-ce que
c'est une volonté ? Je sais pas,
j'aurais jamais la réponse. Mais il
faisait noir donc c'est bon quoi. Je
veux dire les mecs avaient juste à
comment bon d'ailleurs ça a pas loupé
hein. Ils ils ont cramé tout ce qui tout
tout ce qu'il y avait autour. Donc tu
vois c'est comme je te dis, il y a pas
besoin en fait d'infiltrer des gens. Tu
crées les conditions pour que ça arrive
ou en tout cas tu autorises les
conditions pour que ça arrive et puis ça
ça arrive hein. Je veux dire il y a pas
besoin de
quand on laisse Avenue des Champsisé en
travaux.
Ouais ce que je te dire. Ouais
Alexandre
justement qu'on laisse les travaux
partout et c'est encore reproduit là les
weekends précédents où il y a des
chantiers qui sont laissés avec tout le
dispositif, les pavés tout. Donc je veux
dire ça arrivé place de l'étoile
Champs-Élysée, ça arrivait place
d'Italie aussi un peu plus tard quand le
préfet l'allemand a interdit la banif en
cours de route et puis c'est arrivé là
le weekend dernier où il y a 15 jours,
je sais plus, il y avait pareil un
chantier où c'était open bar en fait.
Donc il y a deux solutions. Quand il y a
un chantier, soit on demande aux gens du
chantier de fermer le chantier et de
ranger tout ce qui est dangereux, soit
la manifestation ne va pas là ou si la
manifestation vient là parce qu'ils ont
le nombre et cetera, bah on protège le
site pour éviter qu'il puisse se servir
en munition. Donc ça c'est des puis
après chacun se renvoie la faute sur les
Champsélysées. C'était la mairie de
Paris qui avait dit "Ah bah nous on a
voilà donc un manque de coordination ou
une mauvaise foi entre chacun qui veut
se renvoyer la balle." Mais en tous les
cas, ça pose problème et à tel point que
c'est tellement bête de laisser ça,
c'est que même il y a un ministère celui
de c'était monsieur Grivotu à l'époque,
il fait prendre un Fenwick dans la porte
avec le Fenwick avait les clés dessus,
je veux dire, dans le chantier à côté.
Donc je veux dire si on met tout pour
que ça dérape effectivement les gens
vont vont venir se servir, vont
l'utiliser.
C'est plus de l'incompétence, c'est pas
c'est pas de de la
au bout de la 30 fois, tu te poses la
question. Après, je vais pas faire comme
je disais de complotisme. C'est pas
intéressant d'ailleurs, tu vois en fait
le le renseignement, la faculté en tout
cas qu'on a et c'est valable aussi dans
le cadre des affaires terroristes, c'est
que bon, ça peut l'avis à postériori est
intéressant, mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est le travail préventif. C'est que
l'existence même, l'essence même de
l'existence d'un service de
renseignement, c'est la prévention. Je
après une fois que les choses arrivent,
on peut se dire "Oui, est-ce que c'est
arrivé par omission, par incompétence,
par négligence ou de façon volontaire
Ça après ça reste que comme tu le disais
de la suputation mais la faculté du
service de renseignement c'est avant
tout l'anticipation et c'est vrai que
des fois il y a des nonsens qu'on peut
pas comprendre. Je veux dire on parle de
renseignement tiens et et de contre
terro. Vous avez pas entendu l'histoire
de de du gars qui écoutait les
terroristes et qui disait "Oh là il y a
un monsieur il s'appelle Rouya
Ari Harry." Ouais Harry. Ouais. Ouais.
Bah je j'ai lu le la procédure. Ouais.
C'est dans le cadre de l'affaire Iness
Madani, c'est la jeune fille qui a qui a
qui a qui a qui a essayé de faire
exploser sa caisse là à côté de l'église
Notredame qui a mis du gasoil au lieu de
mettre de l'essence, tu vois pour dire
enfin c'est c'est elle a sauvé la vie de
200 personnes en fait en choisissant le
gasoile ce jour-là. Donc voilà, c'était
peut-être parce que c'était moins cher
hein. C'est donc bon bref, on va pas
faire de l'humour là-dessus mais je veux
dire Oui. Oui. Effectivement, elle a
elle a eu euh Ouais. Alors c'était ça
c'était une affaire en fait qui était
gérée par l'ASdat en France mais
également par le
alors l'ASdat qui veut dire
la sous-direction antiterroriste qui un
serv de la police judiciaire et par les
services belges parce qu'en fait elle
communiquait aussi avec Abbaoud et et
d'autres personnes bon qui étaient qui
faisaient partie de la de la filière
état islamique hein mais en Belgique et
quand elle leur parlait elle elle elle
les appelait Ahi qui signifiait en arabe
littéral mon frère donc voilà et quand
elle les appelait Ari les types qui
écoutaient bon je pense devaiit pas être
arabophones et ils écrivaient Harry Et
comme elle appelait plusieurs types
plusieurs mecs et qu'elle les appelait
parce que c'est l'appelation usulière
usuelle les mecs disaient "Mince mais il
y a un mec qui s'appelle Harry qui
change souvent de numéro de téléphone et
on arrive pas à l'identifier et il
recherchait le dénommer Harry H A2Y et à
un moment moi je lis la procédure et
puis on me dit ouais tiens regarde le
type qui qui m'a fait lire la procédure
tu vois c'était une blague il voulait me
faire rire et je dis ouais il cherche un
certain Harry je dis c'est un cononverti
non parce que en général ils changent de
prénom les types et tout et après il me
dit non regarde écoute maintenant il me
fait écouter la bande et puis c'était
j'étais mort de rire quoi, je me dis wou
c'est quoi ce truc quoi tu vois ? Mais
en fait ça fait flipper en même temps,
c'est drôle tu vois c'est c'est
compétence à ce niveau-là de mettre des
mecs qui sont pas arabophones.
Bah on a été prisonnier de nos propres
démons. C'est-à-dire qu'en France, on a
une vraie difficulté avec la diversité.
C'est-à-dire qu'on fait de la diversité
mais c'est de la diversité creuse.
C'estàd qu'on prend des tokars. Ouais.
Des tokars, des burets brushing et
cetera et puis on dit "Bah voyez, on
n'est pas raciste, regardez, on a la
Ziza là au gouvernement ou je sais pas."
Et bon, globalement, bah en fait, ça
sert absolument à rien alors qu'on a des
gens qui sont réellement compétents.
Mais en fait, ces gens-là, bah par
réflexe, ils s'écarteent justement de ce
type de mission parce que ça les
intéresse pas d'être des symboles. Tu
sais, moi j'ai des copains médecins,
ingénieurs, avocats, ils veulent pas de
ça les intéresse pas d'être des icônes.
C'est des gens qui ont des compétences,
ils veulent être respectés pour ça. Et
dans la police, bah on a choisi un
moment parce que c'est l'institution qui
compte,
on va dire d'un point de vue du de
l'idéologie dominante, il y a énormément
de gens qui sont racistes et qui ont
choisi notamment après l'affaire Michael
Harpon de bah de se laisser aller un
petit peu he le préfet l'a dit lui-même,
le préfet allemand quand on lu a dit oui
mais vous craignez pas quand même de de
culpabiliser des gens qui il a dit oui
je préfère l'injustice au drame donc ça
a été ces mots il est c'est auprès de
France info. Oh bah après à la fin tu te
retrouves avec ça je veux dire très
clairement
et même à ce momentl il y a eu une
chasse aux sorcières de musulmans il y a
un capitaine qui a été
parce qu'il était mar il était français
mais il était marié à une marocaine.
Donc ils l'ont allumé lui le pauvre. Oui
mais plusieurs ils sont au tribunal
après qui étaient compétents.
Vous êtes désarmé on a un soupçon de
terrorisme sur vous ce qu'il y avait des
ordres de castana faut que vous me
donniez des radicalisés donc faut que je
puisse communiquer à la presse. Donc on
est sur cette communication émotionnelle
et on brise des vies et on brise des
gens en fait juste pour chercher des
choses et après au tribunal en plus il
gagnent la plupart du temps. Donc en
fait je veux dire on se prive de
compétence on les humilie après l'État
français paye enfin nos impôts du coup
les pots cassés et voilà où on en est.
C'est cette idéthologie complètement
perverse qu'on a. Et la plupart du
temps, c'estàd qu'il y en a qui perdent
quand même.
Qui perdent,
c'estàd qu'ils se sont fait toper parce
que il fray avec machin ou ils sont fait
tamponner, ils sont fait balancer.
Alors ouais, alors ça il faut voir parce
que c'est la géométrie variable. C'estàd
que à un moment, il y a Mounir Majubi
qui s'est fait guler par la presse, par
le journal Le Point parce qu'il avait
dans son équipe de campagne off parce
qu'il disait que le mec avait pas de
statut dans son équipe de campagne mais
il avait un fichier S qui distribuait
des tracts avec lui qui était visible en
photo sur les réseaux sociaux mais qui
était un ancien du GIA apparemment.
C'est ce qui ressortait du journal. Etth
alors ça c'est une information off. Il y
a Laurent Nunz qui appelle le journal.
C'est off légal ou off pas légal ?
Off légal. Alors moi moi je je pose la
question au journaliste, je lui dis
"Ouais c'est vrai, c'est un fou, c'est
c'est quand même flippant." Et le
journaliste me dit "Il a Laurent Nunes
qui vient de m'appeler, il a désactivé
la fiche du mec, tu vois, pour faire
mentir l'article." En fait, ils ont
désactivé la fiche S. Donc à un moment
euh tu vois, c'est quand même
Ouais. Voilà. Apparemment, bah moi, on
me pose souvent la question pour
Goussinville, comme je suis originaire
de Goussinville, le maire et cetera.
Bon, apparemment la fiche aurait été
désactivée en 2019. c'est un journaliste
qui me qui est venu m'apprendre ça. Donc
au moment où il se présente aux
élections, il y a un peu, tu vois, il y
a des quand même une proximité avec la
République en marche.
Donc c'est tu en fait, il faut pas non
plus négliger, comme je le disais tout à
l'heure, la capacité de compromission
des politiques aussi. Tu sais, des fois
bah ils ont bien compris que 10 % de
musulmans en France, bah c'est pas rien
et que parfois bah voilà, il faut se les
mettre dans la poche pour assurer sa
réélection. euh moyennant quelques bon
quelques gestes, c'est désactiver une
fichesse, c'est gratos hein. Tu passes
un coup de fil quand tu es des GSI euh
ça va vite. Donc euh dire que le mec est
devenu gentil et puis que voilà, il a
changé de nature et que finalement on
s'est peut-être trompé dans l'évaluation
du risque. Bon donc ouais bah écoute,
c'est compliqué hein, tu sais euh parce
que là en attendant les
les moyens de contre terrorisme c'est on
fait des planques dans des cuves, on
fait des planques dans des sous-marins,
on fait quoi ? Bah ça marche pas déjà
hein. Euh
la cuve ou le sous-marin.
Non, l'antiterrorisme actuellement en
France ça marche pas. Je veux dire que
franchement si euh là allez on va faire
la je vais me faire l'avocat du diable.
Le discours que tiennent tous les petits
rigolos sur les plateaux télé qui sont
soudoyés par le gouvernement qui te
disent mais attention
c'est gratuit ça.
Non c'est la vérité. Ils te disent
attention. Oui Samuel Patti a été
décapité mais il faut pas oublier que la
DGSI a prévenu 32 attentats depuis
janvier 2015. Tu vois ? Bon je veux dire
tu vois
c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai ? Bon,
c'est alors quand on a posé la question
Cast, il a dit "Oui, on vient de déjouer
le 11 septembre à la française." Tu
connais la suite he je veux dire un ados
qui dit sur Telegram je cherche à
acheter un flingue avec lequel je vais
détourner un avion pour faire le 11
septembre. Tu vois, un mec, je veux dire
et après oui, on a déj joué le 11
septembre à la française. Je veux dire
bah à un moment si c'est ça les 32
attentats des jouets, c'est pas gagné.
Je veux dire à un moment attends là on
est en France quand même.
Je veux dire tu parles à un titre de un
Algérien d'origine, tu vois. Je veux
dire ça, je l'ai vu moi en Algérie, j'y
allais quasiment tous les ans en
vacances jusqu'aux années 90. Quand à un
moment, on a décidé de plus mettre un
pied là-bas, c'est parce que ils ont
massacrer les professeurs, les
intellectuels, les journalistes et
cetera. Ce qui se passe en France
actuellement, je veux dire sur Nice, le
terro a eu le temps d'envoyer une image
de ce qui s'était passé dans l'église.
Je veux dire, il les a décapité, hein.
Il y a pas photo, hein. Je veux dire,
comme Samuel Patti, comme d'autres. Donc
là, en France, on est sur l'Algérie des
années 90 actuellement, tu vois. Et le
mec, on se l' dit hein, je suis désolé
d'avoir eu raison parce que j'aurais
souhaité me tromper. Quand tu m'as posé
la question sur notre dernière
interview, c'est vérifiable. Je t'ai dit
l'espace Schengen, c'est difficile. Si
on mutualise pas les fichiers, c'est
autant ne pas en créer, ça sert à rien.
Le mec, il a créé, il a pris un train à
Barry en Italie et jusqu'à Nice,
personne l'a arrêté. Il est rentré dans
l'église avec son couteau. Il a juste
changé de vêtement à la gare et il les a
décapité. Personne ne l'en a pêché. Tu
vois donc je vais te dire euh la France
d'aujourd'hui sans frontière, sans
process de sécurité et cetera, c'est une
passoire et euh ouais, on n'est pas à
l'abri hein là je veux te dire
clairement
c'est la menace écarlate là
mais la menace écarlate mais même à côté
de ça on est dans l'abattage de
ça change. Je veux dire qu'est-ce que ça
signifie la menace écarlate ? Je veux
dire qu'est-ce qui empêche
pardon je suis désolé Alexandre de te
couper mais qu'est-ce qui empêche que ça
se reproduise ? C'est freeoui, moi je le
connais depuis 2009, tu vois. C'est
froui, je l'ai surveillé en 2009. On
s'est connu au RG, toi et moi en 2009.
Il est venu à Drancy pendant 9 mois, il
a allé épiné sur scène pendant 3 mois.
Ensuite, on l'a suivi au Bourget, il a
embêté le sénateur du Bourget pendant un
temps. Ensuite, il avait une librairie à
Montreuil à Robespierre. Après, il est
parti à la mosquée de Paris, quoi. La
mosquée de Paris, c'était à vendrancy.
On l'a bien suivi. Moi, je le connais.
Si je le croisais dans la rue, je veux
dire, on n'est pas des inconnus l'un
pour l'autre. Il savait très bien qu'à
un moment je le filais à la trace. Il
était à Montreuil aussi sur une soirée
pugila là où il y avait ni [__] ni
soumise. Il les a tabassé avec ses
militants. Je veux dire à un moment
c'est pas un mec qui est arrivé de nulle
part. Schnina sa sœur était la femme de
Ben Galem. Il y en avait une autre. Bon
bref, ils sont assez connus dans le 78
aussi hein. Tu me contrôleras pas
là-dessus. Je te dire à un moment c'est
pas arrivé de nulle part. Qu'est-ce qui
empêche aujourd'hui que ça ne se
reproduise pas ? Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
entre-temps ? On a fermé deux mosquées
ou trois. Je veux dire on a
une association.
Oui. Baraca City. Ouais. toujours en
fait le punching
légitime ou pas légitime ?
Alors c'est une autre parenthèse. Pour
moi le lien entre le radicalisme
religieux et le terrorisme est pas
spécialement avéré je veux dire au plan
opérationnel c'està-dire que Baraka City
pour moi le bon je vais pas l'insulter
mais le président franchement il aurait
mieux fait de la boucler depuis toutes
ces années. Bon il était peut-être doué
pour collecter des fonds parce que si
effectivement il a collecté 16 millions
d'euros en 3 ans, c'est que le mec il a
quand même un talent pour un talent
d'escroquerie. Je veux dire très
honnêtement. gratuit ça.
Non mais attends 16 millions d'euros en
3 ans, je veux dire et le qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ? Je veux dire
quel bilan il présente à partir de tout
ça ? Je veux dire est-ce qu'il y a moins
de famine en Palestine ou ailleurs ou au
Maghreb ? Je suis pas sûr mais
je crois qu'il fait des puits, il fait
tout ça. Non
bah ouais mais c'est dans des pays où on
peut pas les vérifier. Je veux dire moi
quand j'ai je suis allé au Bourget une
fois pour voir un petit peu écouter ce
qu'il avait à dire. Il voulait
construire des puits au Togo. Mais moi,
j'ai pas de potes togolais en France qui
peuvent me dire "Ah ouais [__] j'ai
vu des mecs si je l'ai croisé une fois.
Euh je les ai chassé euh lui et Nabil et
Nasril là un prédicateur qui est du 93
parce qu'en fait c'était après le 13
novembre la semaine d'après, on a
enterré une nana qui était d'origine
africaine qui s'appelait Astadakité à la
mosquée de Pentin justement à la mosquée
qui a été fermée et les types sont
arrivés avec leur gilet Baraca City et
cetera. Ils ont ils sont arrivés en meut
et ils ont commencé à prendre les médias
à parti pour prendre pour prononcer des
discours. Et moi, j'ai dit aux médias,
attention, c'est des mecs qu'on a jamais
vu ici, ils sont du 91, ils viennent
pour profiter des caméras, ils sont pas
du tout d'ici, c'est pas une c'est pas
une compassion sincère. Je leur ai dit
donc attention. Et le responsable de la
Mosqu a dit "Oui, moi ils sont pas de
chez moi, je les ai jamais vu. Donc il
faut pas qu'il monopolise la parole
parce que c'est pas leur rôle." Et donc
du coup bah j'apparais, il y a un
article de Génie Bastier dans le Figaro
qui fait état de justement de cette
intervention que j'ai eu ce jour-là pour
justement les avec le préfet Deleski
pour les dégager de de la de de ce
moment-là, même s'ils étaient libres
d'être là, je veux dire pour en tout cas
ce type là. Oui, moi je pense que c'est
un mec qui a fait beaucoup de mal aux
musulmans. Les musulmans de France, ils
comprennent pas que qu' se font bernés
par ce genre de type. Le mec a une
tribune chez Alibadou, je veux dire à un
moment il vient, il dit "Moi, je cher
pas la main des femmes." Tu vois ? Je
veux dire à un moment franchement quelle
image il donne c'est une image qui est
complètement désastreuse. Je veux dire
tu as des tas de types qui cherchent à
s'intégrer à qui cherche du boulot qui
cherche à c'est quand même assez
difficile pour tous ces mecs
faire l'avocat du diable. Les prêtres on
leur demande pas d'avoir des femmes.
C'est c'est sa croyance, il fait ce
qu'il veut.
Ouais mais je pense qu'un prêtre ou un
rabin aurait serré la main des femmes
parce que le mec quand on lui dit ouais
mais vous vous rendez compte on est
quand même en France la mixité le mec
dit ouais mais vous demandez pas au
rabin lu toi tu me parles du prêtre. lui
il a dit rabin. Donc ça a renforcé le
caractère antisémite, on va dire du
propos parce qu'il se dit "Attends,
merde, le rabin, il a rien demandé, le
mec, il va nous chercher le rabin." Et
je pense qu'un prêtre ou un rabin aurait
été assez intelligent, même si ça allait
à l'encontre des principes de sa
religion pour se dire "Bon écoute, tu as
le choix entre faire une polémique,
créer la polémique et tu sais qu'on va
parler de ça pendant 3 semaines ou
serrer la main et puis point bas, on
passe à autre chose." Je pense que les
mecs auraient serré la main, tu vois,
ils ont quand même le niveau
d'intelligence situationnelle qui aurait
fait que ils auraient pas ils seraient
pas comportés de la sorte. Puis bon
après il a continué sur Zin et Belrazoui
tout ça c'est c'est du n'importe quoi.
Je veux dire franchement
moi j'ai pris beaucoup de distance
depuis beaucoup depuis un certain temps
avec la communauté musulmane parce que
ça m'intéresse pas. C'est franchement je
pense que c'est un combat que j'ai vu
débuter en 89 à l'époque de Cray du
Foulard. Après ça s'est poursuivi à
Goussin-ville et cetera. Donc je pense
que c'est un combat qui va durer 50 ans.
Je veux dire on en reparlera encore
après. Donc il y a un moment où je pense
que pour gagner du temps et de l'énergie
vaut mieux s'en éloigner. Moi c'est mon
opinion. ça n'engage que moi et euh je
pense que ces gens-là font beaucoup de
mal en fait aux musulmans euh même aux
musulmans sociologiques, aux gens qui
ont rien demandé, je veux dire
clairement. Et euh et donc voilà,
clairement Baraca City pour moi, je suis
pas sûr qu'il prenait l'argent des
donateurs pour aller acheter du TNT et
le faire exploser dans le métro
parisien.
Ça c'est gratuit aussi ça.
Je pense pas. J'ai dit j'ai pas dit que
je pensais je pense pas qu'il fasse ça.
Mais en terme d'image franchement je
pense vivement qu'on ferme toutes ces
associations qu'on fasse le ménage aussi
dans les rangs des représentants de
l'Islam de France parce que c'est
catastrophique là dans dans l'état
actuel des choses. C'est une catastrophe
honnêtement.
Après sur les les fermetures de mosquée
ou d'association ce qui complique les
choses après c'est qu'au moins les gens
sont dans un endroit facile dans un
service de renseignement. On peut les
suivre, on peut les regarder. Je sais
que on a vécu ça dans les Yvelines. On
leur a dit bah du coup qu'est-ce qui se
passe demain ? Bah demain, ils sont
écartés, ils sont hop, ils vont partout.
Donc faut recommencer le travail à zéro.
Et jusqu'à présent, c'est jamais une
association, une mosquée qui a commis
l'attentat, même c'est un bâtiment,
c'est des statuts juridiques, c'est les
gens qui sont dedans. Donc je veux dire,
compliquons pas les services de
renseignement. Agissons sur les gens qui
sont à l'intérieur qui commettent des
exactions ou qui peuvent en commettre ou
qui sont soupçonnés de le faire. Donc
surveillons-les ou présentons-les à la
justice si jamais il y a des faits
avérés mais arrêtons de fermer des
choses pour dire on a fermé une mosquée
pas je veux dire et alors bah ils vont
se réunir ailleurs. Donc on a rien
changé de fondamental. Il faut que les
mecs un discours clair. Je veux dire
très honnêtement sur Samuel Patti la
mosquée de Pentin comme d'autres je veux
dire ils ont relayé le message de de
China ou c'est pas la mosquée Carlé
c'est les gens dans la mosquée Facebook
qui a des humains derrière. Mais quand
quand il a écrit mosqué de pentin sur le
compte Facebook, bah tu sais à qui tu
donnes les codes. Je veux dire, c'est
pas, tu vois, il y a quand même une
responsabilité derrière. Il y a une
jeunesse qui écoute. Euh non, faut faut
c'est plus des choses, c'est pas des
choses qu'il faut prendre à la légère.
Et après sur le sur l'abattage aussi de
statistique parce qu'il y a des gens qui
sont des fichiers s, il y en a qui sont
fichess à mauvais ession juste parce
queil faut faire de l'abattage et je
raconte l'anecdote parce que ça m'a
marqué et c'est pas une anecdote, ça
peut briser la vie de quelqu'un. C'était
un Moi, j'étais au niveau social et il y
avait un cheminot euh qui voulait euh
travailler à la conduite de train de
voyageur et malheureusement euh bah
l'employeur suite à la loi sécurité
intérieure, enfin le le code de la
sécurité intérieure, donc la SNCF a
interrogé la police nationale pour
savoir si cette personne avait le droit
de conduire un train de voyageur.
Réponse non, c'est pas possible. Euh
résultat des courses, il apprend qu'il
est fichier parce que l'administration
pour justifier son truc parle à tout le
monde. Donc son N + 1, son mec qui gère
qui gère le garage chez lui, il dit
"Moi, je parle pas aux gens qui font qui
soutiennent les terroristes en Syrie."
Il fait "Bon bah". Il dit "D'accord,
très bien et du coup il essaie de
comprendre pourquoi." Bah en fait, il
était ami avec il avait joué au football
dans son enfance avec un des gars qui
avait fait les attentats du 13 novembre.
Il avait été interrogé par la DGSI puis
il avait dit bah qu'il connaissait,
qu'il allait le saluer, qu' allit dans
son quartier. Mais ça s'arrêtait là. Là
déjà ici pour pas prendre de risque
ceinture et bretell on le fiche s euh
c'est ce qui a été relaté euh aux gens
de de la SNCF. Donc ce gars-là, il a
perdu son travail parce que comme
c'était aussi un délégué syndical, il a
été viré euh par la SNCF, ce qui n'est
pas pour le coup prévu par la loi hein.
Normalement, il doit être classé sur un
autre emploi. Euh résultat des courses,
il est allé au tribunal. Au tribunal, il
a gagné parce qu'il avait pas le droit
d'être viré. Le ministère de l'intérieur
a poursuivi une deuxième fois en disant
"Nous, on veut qu'il soit viré, qu'il
puisse pas faire les choses. On
maintient qu'il y a une fiche sur lui et
qu'on a les bonnes raisons pour pas
qu'il soit conducteur de train euh de
voyageur."
Euh mais il se trouve que au final euh
il y a pas de derrière ça pas tenu parce
que même le ministère de l'intérieur a
annulé son appel. Ils ont dit voilà la
SNCF a dit "Bah écoutez, on va le
réintégrer du coup comme le ministère de
l'intérieur veut pas suivre les choses,
donc on va le réinterroger pour savoir
s'il est fiché ou pas."
Et comme la fiche va pas comme il
connaît pas quelqu'un comme Laurent
Nunes pour la supprimer, il va refaire
son truc. Euh donc voilà et c'était
quelqu'un euh qui n'a jamais mis les
pieds en série. Euh j'ai pu consulter
son passeport. Euh j'ai me consulter son
passeport parce qu'il était binational.
Donc j'ai vu ses deux passeports. Jamais
aller mettre un pied en Syrie ni à
proximité. Au pire, il allait passer des
vacances en Thaïlande, donc il passait
par les Émirats arabes mais juste le
temps du transit. Euh et il avait une
particularité euh c'est qu'il était dans
un des rares enfin le seul syndicat
section syndicale de France, je peux en
parler parce que ça a été aussi mis dans
les journaux. Donc c'est pour ça je ne
dévue aucun secret. euh qui avait
prenait à l'époque de soutenir la
brigade Krazuki en Syrie. Donc la
brigade Krazuki, c'est une brigade
internationale euh qui luttait avec les
Kurdes contre Daesh et donc c'est le
seul section syndicale de France qui
soutenait cette brigade. Donc je veux
dire voilà et cette personne était
connue des services. Peut-être sa Takia
pardon
peut-être sa Takia c'est un mec qui
l'appel et puis il s'est dit c'est bon
c'est terminé et à côté il était connu
des services français pour conduite en
état d'ivresse. Bon ben je veux dire
pareil ça ça colle parfaitement avec le
profil de l'intégrist religieux et au
final le pire de tout c'est que dans les
papiers que le ministère de l'intérieur
lui envoyé dans ces procédures, ils ont
fait des copiers collées de procédures
dans les procédures au tribunal et en
fait il y avait le nom d'un autre
fichier qui travaillait à la RATP parce
qu'ils ont dit monsieur machin RATP qui
va donc en fait il y a même des
divulgations d'information parce qu'on a
des amateurs même au service juridique
il a dit moi je ce monsieur-là je le
connais pas par contre il y a toute la
chaîne judiciaire qui a eu le truc toute
la scène CF a eu ce nom d'un mec qui
travaille à la RATP donc à partir de là
voilà il y a des gens qui sont fichés
juste pour faire du chiffre et à côté on
a une incompétence générale des
services.
Ah mais je pense que clairement cet
épisode bah dramatique hein, je veux
dire cette vague de terroriste qu'on a
traversé comme celle qu'on a traversé
sur les dernières années, ça a permis de
régler un certain nombre de différents
entre les gens. C'est-à-dire que bah
quand on avait un délégué syndical un
peu casse-couille, je veux dire dans une
entreprise, bon bah il suffisait pour
peu qu'il soit accusé de ça non ?
Oui, ils ont essayé ça. Il y a pas eu
d'accusation. Moi, j'ai jamais eu de
dossier radicalité ou quoi que ce soit,
mais disons que dans la procédure
disciplinaire, ils ont beaucoup rappelé
que j'aimais pas le cochon, que je mange
jamais la pizza qu fromag, que bon, ma
chef était une nana et puis que j'avais
quand même beaucoup de mal à à otempérer
au aux conneries qu'elle leur donnait,
hein, parce que non, parce que c'est
celle qu'on a retrouvé bah entre-temps,
depuis notre dernière interview, elle a
été rendue célèbre par une association
de policiers parce qu'elle a interdit le
port du masque au sein du Cras sous
menace de sidciplinaire et elle a eu
droit à BFM TV en prime justement.
justement parce que au début de la crise
Covid soldat des confinements, elle a
interdit le port du masque par une note
de service et elle a dit "Attention au
récal citran, si on chope un
fonctionnaire avec le masque au sein du
centre de rétention, il fera l'objet de
poursuite disciplinaire." Et donc ça a
fait scandale parce que non seulement
l'administration fournissait pas les
masques, mais elle interdisait le port
du masque au début du au premier
confinement. Donc voilà, elle a été
rendue sève. Bon, du coup, moi c'est pas
un hasard si à un moment j'avais quand
même un peu de mal à obtempérer parce
que bon, quand c'est que ça devient
vital, tu sais. Mais bon, bref, oui, ils
ont essayé. Bah c'est tellement facile
hein en même temps. Mais effectivement
le problème c'est que bah tu sais quand
ils ont ouvert la ligne verte hein parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a des lignes vertes un
peu pour tout des plateformes et cetera.
numéro vert. Oui. Euh bah on a eu tout
un tas d'appels un peu fantaisistes.
C'est-à-dire que bah quand tu avais un
couple qui divorçait et puis quelqu'un
voulait garder les enfants, bon bah
l'homme ou la femme disait attention il
ou elle a dit Akbar, j'ai entendu Siri
au téléphone quand il était dans la
salle à manger pendant que je prenais ma
douche. Puis voilà, il va amener les
enfants et puis bon, tu vois, il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont joué là-dessus
et puis bah parfois ça a créé du fichage
à outrance puis bon bah ça ça a pu à un
moment être assez confortable pour
certaines personnes pour disqualifier
des gens là où ils se trouvaient. Et
puis parfois on est passé à côté aussi.
Quand on veut tuer son chien, on dit
qu'il a la rage.
Ouais, c'était une sale période et je
pense que cela c'est reparti pour un
tour hein, faut pas se leurer.
Question sur les fichages et tout ça là.
Imaginez-vous euh
vous collectez des informations sur une
personne
et vous en parlez à quelqu'un. Cette
personne, elle doit être habilitée
secret défense, elle doit être habilitée
police nationale plus poli.
Voilà. si l'information est classifiée.
Alors en fait pour un passage
d'information, il y a trois conditions
légalement prévues pour une information
classifiée. Donc il faut que le
destinataire de l'information soit lui
aussi habilité secret défense. Il faut
qu'il ait le besoin d'en connaître parce
que ça permet pas de passer toutes les
informations. Par exle à la DGSI euh ils
ont des open space mais les open space
sont orientés d'une certaine manière.
C'est l'organisation spatiale c'est que
tous les écrans en fin de compte sont ne
sont pas tu as pas de visibilité. Si tu
travailles dans le même bureau de
quelqu'un, tu as pas de visibilité sur
son écran. et l'écran sera plutôt
orienté vers le coin de la salle parce
qu'il faut pas que tu puisses passer
derrière le bureau pour bah si tu as
besoin de discuter avec un collègue pour
voir son écran. Donc il y a des
processés qui font que qui organisent
ça. Donc il faut que la personne ait le
besoin d'en connaître et il faut que ça
se en fait ça se fasse également dans le
cadre professionnel. C'est dans le cadre
d'une enquête ou qui a une justification
qui permettent justement voilà que ça se
fasse également dans un lieu classifié
aussi parce que les lieux on parle des
personnes habilité mais il y a aussi des
lieux classifiés. C'est-à-dire que tu
peux pas euh par exemple passer une
information euh comment dire secret
défense bah dans un salon de de massage
ou dans un bistro ou quoi que ce soit,
il faut que le lieu soit classifié
aussi. Donc voilà que le canal soit
sécurisé. Donc
si le mec c'est juste son pote son pote
si par exemple on est la DGSI voilà il y
a il y a un de ses potes qui vient et il
dit "Oh bah tu sais pas ce mec làop
moi j'étais à la DGSI il y a il y a il y
a un certain temps. Bon en fait j'étais
à l'ASdat j'avais fait un passage là-bas
et c'est les locaux sont partagés avec
la DGSI c'est pas un secret parce que
des fois il y a des gens qui s'excident
sur dis oh là là mon dieu il a livré un
secret dans l'ASdat partage ses locaux
avec la DGSI 84 rues de Villier à
Levalois Perz et dans le botin il y a
pas de problème. Donc voilà
c'est chez Balcani ça non ? Ouais, c'est
ça. Ouais. Ouais, c'est voilà, c'est
dans sa ville. Et donc euh en fait et
puis bon, je j'y vais et puis en bas, tu
as des tu as des fonctionneur en tenenu
à l'accueil qui font le filtrage, les
fouilles et tout le nécessaire. Puis
derrière moi, je vois un petit blondinet
qui arrive et puis bon, l'agent lui dit
oui, c'est pourquoi ? Il lui dit "Oui,
alors on a rendez-vous." Il dit "Ouais,
vous avez rendez-vous avec qui ?" Il dit
"J'ai rendez-vous avec 236." Il lui dit
"Vous êtes". Il dit, "Je suis numéro 8."
Puis il me regarde avec un air un petit
peu inquiet parce qu'il savait pas qui
j'étais. Il savait pas si j'étais flic,
si j'étais convoqué ou puis bon moi ça
m'avait amusé quoi. Je veux dire
franchement si tu as besoin de savoir
com comment le mec s'appelle, bon tu as
deux solutions. Soit tu joues la
finesse, c'est-à-dire que bah tu bon
globalement tu le suis, tu traces son
véhicule, tu mets une balise et puis tu
arrives à savoir comment il s'appelle.
Je veux dire, c'est pas parce que tu dis
je m'appelle numéro 8 que au contraire,
tu vois, ça te il peut dire je m'appelle
Bertrand et on sait que c'est pas vrai.
Bon, tu vois, je veux dire mais ils ont
des process de sécurité qui sont
amusants, quoi. Moi je trouve que je
sais pas, je me dis merde, le mec a un
peu trop regardé la télé. Je veux dire
dans le pire des cas, si allez, on va
dire que tu es une organisation
terroriste, tu es un état étranger, tu
veux lui tirer les verres du nez, tu
chopes dans un coin, c'est un blondinet
qui faisait 1,70 kg, tu le tabasses et
tu le fais parler quoi. Je veux dire, tu
vois, il y a un moment où face à un état
ou face à une organisation terroriste
déterminée, c'est pas ce genre de
process verrouiller l'impôt. Carré
sucre. Le carré de sucre, tu connais le
carré de sucre ?
Alors ouais. Alors, il y a si on pense à
la même chose euh ça on est formé
d'ailleurs, j'en parle dans mon livre La
France doit savoir et qui a très bon
livre comme l'ennemi de l'intérieur qui
est le livre d'Alexandre Langlois. Alors
euh j'en parle effectivement les moyens
de compromission, ce que tu appelles toi
le carré de sucre euh des États
étrangers ou des organismes terroristes,
c'est trois choses. C'est d'une part les
relations avec le sexe opposé ou le même
sexe, he tout dépend des préférences.
C'est que c'est la première chose qui
permet de tamponner. Euh la deuxième
chose, le deuxième niveau de
compromission en général, c'est
l'argent. Donc quand le mec est pas
sensible au sexe parce qu'il a ce qu'il
faut à la maison, tu lui proposes de
l'argent. Et si ça fonctionne pas avec
l'argent, c'est la contrainte. La
contrainte, c'est toujours le dernier
niveau hein, naturellement. Donc voilà,
c'est c'est peut-être c'est c'était ça
répond à ta question.
C'était pas une question mais
la contrainte à genou à genou sur des
des carrés de sucre sur un carré de
sucre sous la rotule.
Ah oui, pardon. Ah oui, d'accord.
Ça c'est c'est
Je pense pas qu'il fasse autant dans la
finesse en général. Je pense que le jour
où il décide de passer à la phase
contrainte. Alors la contrainte c'est
pas la baguette racise. On peut on peut
s'expliquer.
La contrainte c'est pas forcément la
contrainte physique. Bah souvent ça
passe par bah les secrets. C'estàdire
bon bah le mec qui est marié puis qui
qui bon tu vois quand je te parlais
justement des des femmes ou des hommes
je veux dire bah la compromission ça se
fait soit bah par la femme qui va
séduire le mec et qui va le faire parler
parce que le mec a une grande gueule et
puis il aime raconter ses exploits et
donc ça c'est facile. ou soit bah
justement par la contrainte, c'està-dire
bah l'idée de bah de le de le
compromettre par le sexe et ensuite de
menacer justement de scandal public.
C'est ça aussi inversement, c'estd que
est-ce que nous on envoie des agents à
les serrer des nanas ? Est-ce que nous
on paye ? Est-ce que
ce serait pas l'intérieur ? Ça ce serait
ça ce serait plutôt de de du ressort du
ministère de la défense parce que nous
on n'est pas compétent. Quand je dis
compétent, c'est au regard de des
missions qu'on a pu exercer pour aller
compromettre les agents de l'étranger.
C'est-à-dire que en territoire étranger,
c'est la DGSE. La gueule. Merde
moi. Oh non mais moi je attends, j'avais
déjà assez de boulot ici hein. Et si tu
veux m'envoyer en Égypte ou je sais pas
où pour aller chercher de l'info, tu as
intérêt à me payer cher hein. Parce que
là par contre c'est pas le même c'est
pas le même terrain d'action là. C'est
Mais je veux dire ouais franchement euh
je pense la France je pense que comme je
t'ai dit ils sont tellement bons euh au
plan technologique euh que déjà d'une
part ils ont pas besoin de faire ça. Ça
c'est ça c'est les techniques du pauvre
ça ou mais ils sont tellement bons au
plan technologique que je pense qu'ils
ont quand même un peu d'avance. Euh et
euh ils ont aussi la la France, ce
qu'ils ont, c'est que tout le monde a
envie de venir vivre en France. Je veux
dire, très honnêtement, ils ont juste à
proposer un titre de séjour un peu
d'oseille et puis les mecs au tempè, ils
ont pas besoin d'aller ruser, d'aller
faire ça. Ils ont un tel volume
d'information à gérer que franchement ça
c'est plutôt les étrangers qui font ça.
C'est bon, je te parlais tout à l'heure
du Maroc et cetera. Ouais. Les Marocains
passent beaucoup par ce biaislà, par
exemple, les Israéliens un petit peu
parce qu'on a tendance à mettre le
Mossade sur un piédestal mais je pense
que c'est il bénéficie de ça justement
le Mossade par exemple, ils sont pas
aussi bons qu'on le prétend. Je dis pas
qu'ils sont mauvais mais je veux dire en
poul position effectivement tu as plus
bah des pays comme la France, la DGSE,
le Royaume-Uni, bon tu as quelques pays
étrangers aussi, la Jordanie, la Turquie
et cetera parce que ils ont pas de
Jordanie, ils sont
Ouais, mais parce que ils ont les droits
de l'homme, c'est pas leur spécialité si
tu veux globalement. Voilà. Non mais
nous on a je te parle de des moyens,
nous on obtient de l'information avec
les moyens qui sont les nôtres hein dans
le cadre de notre réglementation. Eux
ils se ils prennent pas de gant hein, je
veux dire
voilà pour le coup j'ai pas mieux à dire
quoi. Après euh pourquoi on voit pas les
héros euh dans les manifes ? Pourquoi on
voit maintenant des policiers cagoulés ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
que on voit pas les ros les gars là ?
les réo. Ben les héros en fait c'est un
les héros, c'est le numéros
d'identification des des fonctionnaires.
Ça avait été mis en place par Vals euh
sous la contrainte populaire parce qu'il
fallait identifier les policiers et en
fait euh Vals a agité un petit chiffon
rouge pour faire diversion. Euh pourquoi
déjà il a commandé ça coûtait quelques
millions d'euros il a commandé des
choses qui étaient scratchées c'estàd
qu'en fait pas mettant le budget donc
même même pas avec c'est ils ont pas
pris des choses ça se descratche
réellement parce que c'est pas adapté à
des missions opérationnelles. Si on veut
des rigous qui bougent pas ben on fait
comme en Allemagne on les épince sur
l'uniforme comme ça ça bouge pas
les brassards parce que les brassards
étaient pas équipés de velc pourer les
riau pour les effectifs en donc en fait
c'est c'est complètement voilà donc ça
ne sert à rien. Deuxième chose
également, qu'est-ce qui si jamais
personne veut frauder réellement, elle
peut mettre un faux iréo également. Je
veux dire, personne ira le vérifier à
tellement de chiffres que son chef, il
sait pas les numérosé de toutes ses
toute son unité. Troisième chose
également, il y a pas de sanction si on
porte pas le RO. Voilà, c'est une
obligation et on est sanctionné à quoi ?
À rien. Voilà, c'est les les 10
commandements de Moïse. Tu ne tueras
point et alors ? Ah bah, il y a pas de
précision après. C'est c'est on pense
que tu le feras gentiment. Et donc
voilà, donc il y a ça. Et dernière chose
en fait, c'est le où il y a une
diversion.
Euh c'est que c'est pas là le fond du
problème en fait. C'est que moi pour
avoir retrouvé des avoir besoin de
retrouver certaines unités dans mes
missions opérationnelles, j'avais
recherché, j'ai mis 5 minutes à savoir
quelle patrouille de police était à
l'endroit qui m'intéressait. Donc je
veux dire le problème c'est une fois pas
le RO, c'est le problème c'est le
contrôle de la police. Donc on en
revient à l'IGPN dire que le LIGPN va
dire on sait pas qui c'est, il y a des
HOS, on retrouve pas les gens. C'est
quand même marrant. Donc je veux dire à
partir de là c'est un faux problème.
Contrôlons la police de façon efficace
et là on pourra faire des choses parce
que sur un maintien de l'ordre par
exemple toutes les unités constitué on
sait où elles sont. Les unités qui sont
pas constituées comme les bacs et sinon
on sait à peu près où elles sont. Et
après, il y a une volonté après de
cacher les choses comme les braves ou
c'est des unités constituées pour la
journée qui se dispersent après. Donc en
fait c'est là le problème et une fois de
plus c'est le contrôle derrière comment
ça se passe. Voilà parce que le Réo n'a
rien résolu du tout à part créer en
disant "Ah, il a pas son RO." Bah oui,
mais en fait c'est pas le fond du
problème.
Clairement, tu me connais euh avec le
depuis le temps maintenant, je suis je
suis sans langue de bois et puis je me
suis pas beaucoup trompé dans tout ce
que j'ai dit depuis 2 ans. D'ailleurs,
c'est on dérangerait pas autant si euh
on disait des bêtises.
Euh bon, ce qui se cache derrière euh
cette ce fameux article 24, la loi
sécurité globale, c'est qu'en fait dans
la police, on a un problème
d'exemplarité. C'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui les flics qui sont
inquiets pour leur sécurité parce que ça
existe hein, ils sont pas tous de
mauvaise foi, il n pas que des mauvais
flics.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et ce ceux qui sont
inquiets pour leur sécurité et ceux qui
font aussi des bêtises et qui veulent le
faire en toute impunité, qui sont bien
entendu minoritaires, on va on va le
rappeler, ils ont un problème parce que
si effectivement ils portent des
cagoules, bon, on a un problème
d'exemplarité parce qu'aujourd'hui
depuis le début de la crise des gilets
jaunes, on a on en a fait un délit un
délit tout simplement. C'est-à-dire que
avant c'était une infraction donc
c'était contraventionnel le la
dissimulation du visage dans l'espace
public. C'est ce qu'on appelait la loi
sur la burka mais en fait qui était
beaucoup plus vaste. On avait pas le
droit de se couvrir le visage sinon
c'est une amende forfaitaire d'environ
150 €. Puis là depuis le début de la
crise des jeunes, on a fait un délit.
Donc aujourd'hui les policiers bah
cachent leur visage. Problème c'est
qu'on leur dit les gars article 7 du
code de déontologie l'exemplarité. Donc
toi tu vas verbaliser un type ou tu vas
placer un type en garde à vue parce
qu'il masque son visage mais par contre
toi tu as une cagoule. Comment est-ce
qu'on
WTF comme disent les jeunes ? OK.
Et en plus pour rebondir sur ça, c'est
qu'il y a des unités qu'on comprend bien
qu'elles a des cagoule qu' a pas de
matricule comme certaines unités bah de
la DGSI, certaines unités de la police
judiciaire, le raide et cetera mais
c'est déjà cadré légalement. Donc ces
unitésl qui ont besoin d'être protégé et
leur anonymat c'est déjà fait. Donc
voilà, on est sur une inversion
effectivement. À la fin, ce qu'ils vont
faire
à mon avis, c'est qu'ils vont dire "Bon,
OK, l'article 24 c'était une bêtise mais
vous comprenez bien que les policiers
sont inquè anné en ville et cetera."
Donc on va dire bon, on va éditer une
note de service qui va autoriser les
policiers à dissimuler leur visage sur
les terrains de manifestation et en
échange, on vous laisse la liberté de
filmer et on maintient justement la
criminalisation, la délectualisation
justement bah de la dissimulation du
visage pour les manifestants. Donc on va
en fait vous expliquer par un processus
négocié que les policiers et les
manifestants c'est pas pareil parce que
les policiers auront droit de cacher
leur visage. et moyennant ou pas
d'ailleurs et euh et que bon pour les
manifestants, bah on continuera à vous
placer en garde à vue.
Alors, on va faire un peu de futurologie
ensemble euh et et on va essayer de
réfléchir.
On a vu euh notre état sécuriser son
organe répressif,
la rassurer. Moi, je parle de la police
en disant voilà on est derrière vous, on
vous baque, on a vu des procédures de
plus en plus violentes, des des gens qui
se faisait taper dessus de plus en plus
violemment. La question c'est qui
d'internet, l'ambiance est très tendue
en ce moment. Croyez-vous qu'il peut y
avoir une guerre civile en France ?
Est-ce que vous ne voyez pas
un état qui dans un contexte de guerre
économique, de crise économique, de
récession, de perspectives économiques
qui sont relativement bouchées pour
employer des mots calmes, est-ce que
vous ne voyez pas un état se préparant à
voir des gens très énervés parce que pas
de proposition politique, pas de
perspective, une capacité à vivre
correctement de plus en plus réduite.
Donc un état qui se prébarre, je vais
parler trivialement, à se faire cogner
sur la gueule mais d'une violence dont
les Français ont ça dans leur ADN
et sécurise sa police, militarise sa
police, militarise son espace urbain
pour gérer une guerre civile en
approche. Alors pour la première
réponse, j'invite tout le monde à
réécouter le discours de Gérard Colomb
quand il est parti du ministère de
l'intérieur. Voilà, il a été très clair
en disant que c'était ça allait on
allait vers une guerre civile qui allait
avoir des graves problèmes et qui
partaient avant et queon avait rien fait
pour le régler. Lui pas plus que les
autres d'ailleurs, mais en tous les cas,
il avait une analyse assez lucide de la
situation. La la deuxième chose
également, oui, on militarise
aujourd'hui, je veux dire, c'est qu'on
est un des rares pays avoir géré une
crise sanitaire euh en mettant des
contraventions et cetera. Je pense à mes
collègues italiens euh pour le premier
confinement, ils ont distribué des
masques. Nous, on mettait des amendes.
Donc, je veux dire, voilà, en fait, il y
a il y a un problème, mais on prend pas
la bonne réponse au problème. C'estd que
le policier, on a été suréquipé, on a
commandé des grenades et pendant ce
temps-là, on fermé des lits d'hôpitaux.
Donc, je veux dire, si on lutte contre
une crise sanitaire, équipe l'hôpital.
Nous, c'est pas notre rôle. Nous, notre
rôle, c'est un rôle de voilà, là, on est
sur du contrôle social de la population.
Et d'ailleurs, les mots sont très
importants parce que si on avait mis des
gestes barrières ou des distanciations
sanitaires et on a le mot est très
important, c'est des distanciation
sociale dire que là c'est le c'est bien
ce voilà ça veut dire son mot. Donc en
fait on joue pas sur les mots, ils sont
très clairs dans ce qu'ils veulent
faire. Deuxième chose aussi, ils ont
rapatrié l'opération sentinelle sur le
territoire qu'ils ont augmenté. Là c'est
des militaires. Nous on a toujours été
opposé à des militaires déployés sur le
territoire. On préfère avoir des
renforts en police nationale et qu'on
ait les effectifs suffisants. Un
militaire, c'est pas sa place sur le
territoire national en dehors de la
gendarmerie qui un attaquat particulier.
Et aujourd'hui, ils veulent libérer le
tir des militaires de l'opération
Sentinelle. Donc en fait, on arrive à
vraiment de la militarisation. Ils
avaient déjà commencé à militariser la
police en nous donnant des grades de
lieutenants, capitaines, commandant à la
place d'inspecteurs qu'ils ont supprimé.
On est le seul service public hors armée
qui défilonce sur les le 14 juillet.
C'est un défilé militaire, c'est pas le
défilé de la fonction publique. Donc la
police techniquement n'a rien à faire
sur le défilé du 14 juillet. Donc en
fait, on est sur toute cette préparation
et aujourd'hui bah quand on voit un
policier, ça fait un petit peu c'est des
Robocopes quoi. On est suréquipé et
c'est pas ça donne pas un lien de
confiance quoi. Donc effectivement il y
a ce côté on commande des armes, on
commande plein de choses mais on ne
règle pas les problèmes. Et c'est là la
ce qui est dramatique c'est que faute de
réponse politique, on utilise la force.
Moi je comprends pas pourquoi la
question est conditionnelle et au futur.
Moi je veux dire là on est en période de
couvre-feu 21h. On nous parle d'un
couvre-feu à 17h dans les prochains
jours. On a
c'est quelle est une rumeur en fait qui
circule là ? Je sais pas si c'est pas si
ça a été évoqué. Je je saurais pas dire
si c'est Jérôme Salomon premier
ministre. En tout cas ça a été évoqué.
C'est c'est un chiffre qui que j'ai pas
inventé. Il faudrait poser la question.
Oui. Et euh bon, en tout cas, on a un
couvre-feu. Je veux dire, couvre-feu, ça
a été les techniques des États moyen du
Maghreb et d'Afrique he très clairement
qui ont pas de politique sanitaire ou de
politique de santé efficace. Moi, en
Algérie, je veux dire, il y a eu un
couvre-fe à 17h au début du confinement
quand nous on était confiné en mars. Je
crois que c'était le cas également au
Maroc et dans certains pays d'Afrique.
Bon voilà, on a repris ça. Je veux dire,
bon clairement entre-temps, qu'est-ce
qu'il y a eu ? Il y a eu des mecs qui se
sont fait trancher la tête dans la rue
en Algérie dans les années 90, on
appelait ça une guerre civile. Pourquoi
est-ce que chez nous ça s'appellerait
différemment ? Euh je dire bon l'État,
les services de l'État tirent sur les
manifestants. On a d'ailleurs un demeuré
là de d'une association policière. Donc
d'ailleurs, je sais pas ce que c'est que
tous ces assauts policières là qui qui
florissent, qui poussent comme des
champignons et qui s'expriment. Donc on
a un type là qui a envoyé un message
hier qui a appelé justement à tirer à
balle réelle sur la population.
il il s il s'est rétracté un peu. Il a
dit que c'était de la légitime défense
ou des choses comme ça.
Moi j'ai lu le message, il appelle à
tirer sur les manifestants. Je veux dire
à tirer sur les manifestants si jamais
les policiers sont agressés en titre de
la légitime défense. Après c'est
c'est là où il y a la défense
proportionnelle. Si la manifestation est
bien gérée, on a les canons en haut et
cetera parce que légalement il a raison.
Mais si jamais on commence à tirer sur
les manifestants d'un point de vue
légal, c'est pas forcément légitime.
Bref, quoi, c'est pas si tu veux, c'est
pas un message de paix, quoi. Si la
police tire euh s'amuse à tirer dans les
manifestants euh euh ça va être un bain
de sang. Mais c'est bien ce que je dis.
Donc en fait, son message ne met que de
l'huile sur le feu et des
contre-productifs. En fait, ce gars-là
en plus, c'est une association de gens
qui sont plus dans la police qui était
policier. Donc d'ailleurs, c'est pas eux
qui vont prendre les coups par la suite.
Ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent sur
les réseaux sociaux, balancer autant
d'huile qu'ils veulent sur les ou
normalement un type qui envoie un
message comme ça, je veux dire, il y a
une suite disciplinaire. Normalement, le
ministère de l'intérieur réagit et dit
"Non, non, ce mec-là, il est pas
légitime à s'exprimer. Euh bon, on va
remettre un peu d'ordre et euh mais mais
aujourd'hui, c'est du n'importe quoi. Je
veux dire euh clairement euh tu prends
par exemple sur la loi sécurité globale,
c'est c'est le député Faverg de
Sénémarne qui a l'initiative du rapport
qui aurait donné naissance au projet de
loi. Euh député Faverg et madame Tourau.
Donc bon bref, bon on a je veux dire bon
on a on a tout un
tout un collège comme ça de personnes
qui qui s'expriment. Je crois qu' il y a
il y a bon, j'ai rien contre hein, mais
je veux dire, il y a une association des
femmes de force de l'ordre en colère
contre qui j'ai rien, je les connais pas
et je veux dire, je savais pas que
toutes les policiers étaient des hommes.
Je veux dire, il y a aussi des policiers
femmes qui ont des maris. Donc les
femmes de force de l'or invité à
l'Assemblée nationale par un député
marchiste marcheur pardon pour pas
marchiste, c'est c'était George Marchet.
Donc donc qui pour pour s'exprimer, je
veux dire bah pourquoi vous invitez pas
les femmes de chirurgien ou les femmes
de médecins généralistes pour justement
s'exprimer sur la crise Covid ? Je veux
dire, non mais là c'est quoi ce délire ?
Je veux dire, il y a un moment où mais
hors service, je sais pas ce que c'est.
Je savais pas que c'était un ancien
policier. Je tiens, qui c'est ? Je veux
dire, c'est du n'importe quoi là en ce
moment. C'est pour ça moi je pas je je
pense qu'il y a une anarchie. Il y a un
truc, tu vois dans l'air, il y a on a
traversé des périodes de conflits
sociaux. Tu sais, on a en 95, il y a eu
Jupé, on parlait de de Vaak en 86 tout à
l'heure, on a eu Rafara en 2003, je veux
dire. Mais là, il y a un truc dans l'air
qui est qui est assez inédit. Moi, je je
trouve que ça va pas là. Ça il y a
et même pour aller plus loin pour
rebondir sur tous ces groupes et cetera
qui se produisent mais il y a même même
sans aller chercher sur les groupes il y
a les syndicats de police qui sont dit
majoritaires. On j'ai pas bien compris
pourquoi le syndicat alliance avait fait
une cagnotte pour les quatre collègues
qui avaient agressé Michel Zler à limite
éventuellement si c'est suite une
défense syndicale en disant on défend
tous les policiers quoi qu'ils aient
fait et ils auraient dû faire une
cagnotte pour notre collègue qui a
failli se faire lych en assurance sa
mission et là il y a pas eu de cagnotte
pour lui. Donc c'est très clairement
orienté en défant les plus pourris. Et
deuxièmement, je finis juste aussi. Al
ils ont pas été encore jugés, je crois
bien.
Non, mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que
à ce moment-là, la cagnotte, soit on l'a
fait pour tous les policiers, y compris
sur ceux, il y a pas de doute, ils
étaient en service, ils ont fait ce
qu'ils ont pu pour assurer l'ordre
public, ils ont été blessés plutôt que
sur ceux-là. C'est je veux dire si on
doit faire un choix entre un et deux, on
commence par ceux qui sont blessés en
service. Et sinon, bah on fait on met
tout le monde même si je partage pas la
vie. Et la deuxième chose, c'est que là,
on a eu unité GP qui a dit maintenant on
fait plus de contrôle parce qu'on a
accusé de contrôle aux facièes. Donc je
veux dire, ils ont dans les ils donnent
au passant des petits papiers marqué
unité SGP. Nous ne vous contrôlons pas
pour pas être accusé de contrôle au
faciè. Neutralité de service public
zéro. Ordre d'insubordination, c'est
qu'on voit une infraction, on doit quand
même la constater, hein. C'est c'est ça
fait partie de notre travail. Est-ce que
le ministre les a poursuivis ? Non. Ils
ont une lettre de monsieur Macron qui
leur a dit "On va faire un grenel en va
pas faire enfin un beau de la sécurité
au mois de janvier. et il aura écrit
personnellement et que à ce syndicat
dire qu'en fait ils commettent des
actions illégales et c'est eux qui sont
félicités. Non mais je veux dire voilà
le message qui envoyé voilà où on en
est. Donc à partir de là et je rappelle
que ce syndicat n'est pas à son coup
d'essai. C'était eux qui avaient dit sur
un plateau de télé [__] c'est
presque convenable pas de sanction
administrative. Ah ben c'était Luc Poign
en 2017 [__] c'est presque
convenable faire.
Voilà
et la journaliste l'a repris. Il a dit
mais dis donc enfin ça va pas. Et ben il
a dit "Est-ce que vous croyez qu quand
se fait traiter de fils de [__] ? C'est
bien la journaliste a dit mais non c'est
pas bien non plus mais il y a pas de
vous êtes policier vous devez être
exemplaire quoi.
Donc le secrétaire général de l'époque
qui est toujours le même Yve Le Fè avait
dit oh il a eu un coup de fatigue.
Il est parti.
Ouais il est parti. Ça il a changé il y
a pas longtemps. Exact. Mais du coup il
avait dit voilà c'est un coup de fatigue
donc on l'excuse quand même. Ce même
syndicat qui avait qui s'était réjoui de
la main arrachée d'un manifestant bien
fait pour sa gueule. Bon on ramasse pas
une grenade c'est pas très fut mais de
là de se réjouir de que la personne ait
la main explosée je veux dire il y a un
pas. pas de sanction non plus. Et pire
dans ce syndicat, c'est qu'il y a encore
plus récemment plus récemment mais c'est
pour montrer à quel point la il y a un
problème de quel policiers sont
défendus. Ils ont eu un délégué qui
tasait ses subordonnés qui lui plaisait
pas. Donc il y a eu une plainte avec des
ITT constaté. Le syndicat a écrit, c'est
dans le Canard enchaîné. Ils ont écrit
au préfet de police en disant c'est
notre délégué donc vous allez quand même
pas le sanctionner quand même sinon on
vous met le fouttoir. Mais c'est a des
traces de tout ça.
Mais alors canard enchaîné. Oui tout ça
il y a les traces. C'est dans la presse,
je peux te faire tout le listing. C'est
même on l'a mis dans un communiqué là
récemment pour montrer ce qu'il faisait
quoi.
Après là en ce moment bon ben
il y a les vidéos, il y a tout. Enfin
voilà, en fait c'est orchestré, il faut
prendre un petit peu de recul par
rapport à tout ça, de hauteur même, j'ai
envie de dire. C'estàd que là on nous
dit "Ah, les syndicats sont furieux
contre Emmanuel Macron." Oui. Pour qui
ils ont appelé à voter en 2017.
C'est-à-dire que syndicat Alliance a
donné une consigne de vote favorable à
Emmanuel Macron en dans l'entre deux
tours en 2017. Est-ce que c'était leur
rôle ? Je pense que voilà, ils en
reviennent un petit peu et donc
aujourd'hui bah comme les élections
approchent, la campagne va démarrer dans
quelques mois. Il faudrait surtout pas
que l'opinion puisse penser une seule
seconde que les syndicats de police sont
liés à la majorité en place. Donc il
faut regagner un petit peu en
neutralité. Donc on fait semblant de se
fâcher puis voilà, on participe ou pas à
la campagne qui arrive parce que de
toute façon les les syndicats de de
police ont toujours été politisés. Bon,
il y a le syndicat UNSA euh qui qui à
l'époque était dirigé par Joaquim
Mazanet qui était directeur de la
sécurité sur la campagne de Sgolen Royal
en 2007. Donc, il y a toujours eu des
liens entre les syndicats de police et
les partis politiques. Et donc, bon,
nous, on nous accusé régulièrement
d'être proche de la France insoumise. Je
crois pas que ce soit le cas. Très
honnêtement, en tout cas, il y a pas de
de lien officiel. Bon, d'ailleurs nous
on dérange beaucoup hein parce que
moi moi j'étais candidat au municipal
dans ma ville pour un alors moi j'étais
sans étiquette mais le le la tête de
liste était UDI moi sur sur la campagne
à laquelle j'ai participé. Moi je pas
moi je vote moi je Ça dépend c'est
variable euh je
répondre
non alors là au premier tour
des là j'ai voté moi au deuxème tour
j'ai voté Macron là en 2017 contre Le
Pen si c'était à refaire je voterai
Blanc honnêtement je revotterai pas pour
Macron en tout cas en 2022 au 2e tour
euh je voterai Blanc euh et donc j'ai
voté au premier tour il me semble que
j'ai voté pour la droite pour les
Républicain euh voilà au premier tour
Après euh
moi je sais pas là quelle position
j'adopte, je déteste la politique en
fait parce qu'il s'est placé plein de
choses entre-temps et je m'appresso que
c'est un monde d'opportunisme en fait.
Les gens sont pas très humains.
Ouais puis de toute façon c'est un monde
de trahison donc je pense qu'il faut il
faut garder un peu de distance par
rapport à ce monde-là. S'ils ont besoin
de nous sur bah pour une réforme de
l'institution policière, ils peuvent
compter sur nous. Il y a pas de
problème. S'ils ont besoin d'une
expertise, oui, mais s'ils ont besoin de
gens pour distribuer des tractes ou
coller des affiches, c'est pas moi. Très
honnêtement, voilà, moi je peux je parle
pour moi. Bah, la ligne du syndicat
avait été claire, c'est qu'on répond à
toutes les sollicitations de personnes
élues parce qu'il y a des gens qui
l'auront fait confiance. Voilà, donc on
répond queles que soient les étiquettes
politiques parce que on pense que c'est
bah si les gens ont été élus, c'est que
pour le moment c'est les règles du jeu
donc c'est avec eux qu'il faut faire du
lobbying. Suant sur ce que je vote, moi
j'estime qu'on doit mériter mon butin de
vote. Donc j'ai regardé les débats. Donc
par exemple à l'élection présidentielle
de 2017 au second tour, j'ai regardé le
débat et j'ai estimé que personne
méritait mon bulletin de vote. Donc il
faisait beau le weekend. C'est la
première fois de ma vie que je n'ai pas
allé voter.
Tu es sans étiquette au municipal ? Et
au municipal oui, j'ai été je suis élu
dans ma petite commune, on était liste
sans étiquettes compte sans étiquettes
et je suis encarté nulle part c'est pas
mal quand même dans
il y a liste sans étiquett dans une
petit un petit village. Donc c'est pas
le même contexte
ou mais c'est bien. Nous on a fait 35
dans ma liste. Voilà
et donc voilà donc c'est sans étiquette
sur
un message à faire passer. Merci
messieurs les policiers de redonner les
leur lettres de noblesse à la police.
Respect messieurs.
Euh question internet. Ah oui, j'ai ma
mère qui t'embrasse. Ah ben
tu passeras le bonjour et un jour quand
elle veut on va prendre un café dès
qu'on pourra.
Non non non non.
Ah non. Bon ben, prendra pas de café. Et
et
question question d'internet. Noam, tu
as commencé à parler de la mafia à 20
minutes, tu pourrais développer s'il te
plaît ?
Je pense pas que ce soit un point. C'est
c'est une expression. C'estàd l'idée
c'est de dire que finalement un état
théoriquement on en comprend les
rouages, on en comprend le
fonctionnement et l'État doit
fonctionner en tout cas en démocratie,
en toute transparence. Quand je dis bah
c'est une mafia, ça signifie
qu'aujourd'hui bah il y a des gens qui
sont au-dessus de toutes les règles.
C'estàdire qu'il y a des nominations qui
obéissent à aucune logique. Il y a des
gens qui devraient plus être là et qui
sont encore là. Je veux dire malgré les
appels à démission et cetera. Tu sais
moi j'ai connu moi je suis un enfant des
années 80 je veux dire quand j'ai grandi
ben je parlais de de vaquet tout à
l'heure j'ai connu aussi l'époque
Bergovois quand les mecs étaient
impliqués de façon indirecte et très
lointaine dans un scandale financier ils
étaient tellement couverts de honte
qu'il démissionnaient dans la foulée.
C'estàdire que le premier jour le mec
posait sa démission. Aujourd'hui les
mecs ils sont accusés de viol pédophilie
de trucs et tout. Les mecs, je
sais c'est peut-être des fausses
accusations.
Ouais, mais je veux dire, il y a des
choses, il y a ce qu'on appelle, tu
sais, euh il y a des conditions par
exemple quand tu veux être, je sais pas
moi, éducateur, policier ou quoi que ce
soit, comme je dis, on est soumis à des
enquêtes de moralité, hein. C'est un
terme qui existe juridiquement. Et donc
bah, si tu réponds pas aux conditions
d'honorabilité, tu es pas voilà, tu
passes pas quand tu passes à la trappe
aujourd'hui quand même, [__] on t'a
mis comme chef de la police un type qui
est quand même accusé. Donc il aurait
fallu, je pense, résoudre, je dis pas
qu'il aurait pas fallu le nommer, mais
il aurait fallu résoudre le problème
avant de confirmer sa nomination. Tu
prends Bruno Lerou qui a été ministre de
l'intérieur il y a il y a 2 ans. Je veux
dire, le mec, il a embauché sa gamine de
15 ans à l'Assemblée nationale pour
50000 € annuel. Je veux dire, tu
imagines, c'est un crach. Il a
démissionné pour ça en direct de la
préfeture de Bobini. C'est un crach
travail en plus à partir d'Allemagne
boulot justifier. C'est un crachat à la
gueule de tous les gens qui travaillent
au supermarché. Je veux dire, tu as des
pères, des mères de famille qui bossent
pour 1000 balles et au supermarché, le
mec il embauche sa fille de 15 ans comme
collaboratrice parlementaire. Je veux
dire ça, tu vois. Et après le mec, il
est chef de la police quoi. Donc tu vois
à un moment je veux dire si tu veux
cracher à la gueule du français moyen
qui se lève tous les matins pour aller
au boulot, tu peux pas faire mieux quoi.
Et des affaires comme ça, il y en a
plein. Donc tu vois, je veux dire, oui,
je c'est je sais pas si c'est une mafia
ou pas, mais je veux dire, il y a un
vrai problème. Franchement, il y a un
vrai problème. Et euh
sur les nominations, il va falloir pour
2020, moi de toute façon, je pense que
jusqu'à 2022, c'est mort. Moi,
j'encourage même, ça reste que mon avis,
hein. Je veux dire, peut-être que ce
sera pas partagé par Alexandre. Je dire
aux gens, n'allz pas dans la rue vous
faire massacrer, vous faire tabasser. On
a encore une main arrachée samedi et
cetera. Faites l'économie de votre
santé. Ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
se mobiliser mais franchement l'État est
en train de faire une démonstration de
force. C'est quand les Tunisiens ont
fait la même chose en 2011, Michel
Alomarie a dit "On a des experts qu'on
va pouvoir vous envoyer pour vous
conseiller." Tu vois ? Donc à un moment
et
on a envoyé un ministre en fonction dans
un territoire qui était en période
insurrectionnelle tranquille mimil. Hm
hm. pour vendre nos services de
contre-insurrection. Tranquille
hein. Non mais tranquille.
Ouais. Donc si tu veux c'est pas il s'en
rappelle hein.
Ouais bien sûr bien sûr. Bah oui oui oui
oui. Et donc du coup je pense qu'il faut
faire l'économie. De toute façon moi
honnêtement j'en verrai pas des gens que
j'aime aujourd'hui sur le terrain pour
manifester honnêtement. Donc je peux pas
le conseiller aux gens parce que moi
j'aime les gens. Je je suis pas dans un
numéro de séduction ou quoi que ce soit,
mais j'ai envie de dire faites
l'économie de tout ça, ça sert à rien.
Ils ont une ligne de conduite, ils ont
un programme qui vont faire appliquer.
Depuis trois mandats, aujourd'hui, on a
de toute façon des présidents qui sont
élus pour ne pas être réélus, hein, très
clairement, même s'ils font semblant
d'avoir la volonté quoi que ce soit. Je
pense que Sarco, il croyait un peu, mais
il savait très bien que c'était fragile.
Hollande, c'est pas ça, il a même pas
Hollande a même pas fait semblant. Il
s'est pas ça a été d'ailleurs le premier
président de la 5e République à pas être
candidat à sa propre réélection. Je
pense que Macron donne des signes
d'incertitude, mais en réalité, il sait
très bien que de toute façon à part
l'humiliation, il risque il gagnerait
pas grand-chose à se représenter. Donc
c'est des présidents à usage unique, je
veux dire aujourd'hui et donc ils sont
là pour appliquer des programmes, ils
sont financés. Sarco après ça, ça j'ai
rien contre lui hein, je veux dire, j'ai
c'est pas personnel, mais il a il a fait
des conférences à 200000 € au Qatar la
suite, à 200000 € de l'heure, je crois
au Qatar après son mandat euh avec de
Villepin d'ailleurs qui était aussi au
Qatar. Donc alors que c'était son
adversaire au moment de l'affaire
CLstream donc je veux dire bon il y a un
moment où ça va quoi. Il était aussi
engagé ça bah s'il y a des vérifications
à faire il aussi il était aussi engagé
comme conseiller je crois pour du roi
Mohamed 6 Saint-Sarco au travers de son
activité d'avocat. C'est légal he je
veux dire mais euh donc comme conseiller
politique du roi Mohamed 6 donc je veux
dire bon voilà les mecs ils ont ils ont
une retraite dorée. Je je suis pas
inquiet pour eux. Bon voilà, c'est comme
ça. Aujourd'hui, ça fait partie du
processus. Donc le prochain, celui qui
viendra après, peu importe qui il sera,
il sera exactement dans la même lignée
si on laisse les choses se dérouler de
la sorte. Donc il va falloir des gages,
demander des gages, il va falloir y
travailler. Donc bon,
Alexandre, question d'internet. La vidéo
du bisutage dans un commissariat, on en
parle, est-ce exemplaire ?
Ouais, j'ai vu la vidéo. Alors, c'est
exemplaire, non, si c'est le cas. Voilà.
Après, j'ai pas eu le temps de me pocher
sur le dossier parce que la vidéo est
filmée d'un peu loin et j'ai pas eu le
temps d'avoir le les contacts sur place
pour avoir une analyse plus poussée.
Mais si tu si tu auditionnes le mec, le
fonctionnaire qui qui était noir hein,
je veux dire sur qui on a mis de la
farine blanche, bon est-ce que c'était
de bon goût ou pas ? Je pense pas. Je
lui va dire non mais moi je fais je suis
dans je suis dans le game he il y a pas
de problème. Je suis pas victime, je
dépose pas plainte ou quoi que ce soit.
Si aujourd'hui euh dans le dans parce
que tu vois les les représentants de
l'institution policière disent "Ouais
mais par exemple quand moi je dénonce le
racisme dans l'institution", il disent
"Ouais mais toi tu es aigri, tu as eu
plein d'emmerdes, c'est pour ça de toute
façon euh non mais si aujourd'hui tu
veux prospérer euh dans l'institution
policière en étant noir ou arabe, il y a
des gages à donner, il y a des choses
auxquelles tu dois répondre et il y a
des choses que tu dois pouvoir encaisser
en fermant ta gueule. C'est comme ça.
Donc là, bah tu en as eu une
démonstration filmée. Je veux dire, moi
j'ai j'ai une collègue pour qui j'ai une
pensée. D'ailleurs, elle se reconnaîtra
parce qu'elle a pris la parole dans la
presse, elle a fait une tentative de
suicide, pas dimanche dernier, mais le
dimanche d'avant. Donc, elle est en
hôpital psychiatrique là en ce moment.
Et elle, elle a fait un témoignage parce
qu'elle avait elle avait fait des
captures sonores justement de ce à quoi
elle avait eu droit. Et en fait, c'est
ça. Tu arrives en patrouille, on te dit
tiens regarde ça [__] ça boug là-bas,
on va aller le contrôler et cetera et tu
es obligé de fermer ta gueule. Si tu
ouvres ta gueule, bah tu finis comme ça,
je veux dire, tu vois. Voilà,
globalement il y a des gages à donner.
Donc le bisutage, il y avait une
dimension de cet ordre là à mon avis. Tu
vois d'ailleurs le 19e, le commissariat,
il est connu. Il y a Valentin Jandre qui
a fait un témoignage écrit, donc
journaliste qui a fait un témoignage
écrit de ce qui se passait là-bas. Donc
la vidéo se passe dans ce commissariat.
Je veux dire le mec, ils lui ont dit
tiens, regarde, vas-y, on va C'est un
journaliste qui a infiltré.
Ouais. parce que il s'est fait il a
passé le diplôme de de
il était à DS, il a fait la formation de
3 mois puis il alors lui il a exercé
pendant je crois presque 2 ans à l'I3P
c'est à l'Institut psychiatrique de la
préfecture de police. Il a fait des
pieds et des mains pour être muté. Donc
il il a exercé au commissariat du 19e et
il a dénoncé le racisme. Naturellement
la réponse de l'institution ça a
toujours été la même he des syndicats.
Oui c'est pas vrai. Il ment il raconte
n'importe quoi et cetera. Et alors qu'en
plus le drame du racisme encore dans la
presse 2010 ou 2012, voilà, je
m'excuserai pour la date exacte, des
collègues antillet qui avaient déposé
plainte pour ce qui se faisait traiter
de [__] par leur hiérarchie dans une
compagnie de CRS. Dénitis de justice par
la France, cour européenne, la France
obligée de juger. Finalement, ils sont
déplacés. L'administration dit "Écoutez,
on vous envoie où vous voulez les gars,
on échange." Voilà. Et au final, au
final non, mais c'estd qu'il y en a
trois qui sont partis. Le dernier, il a
dit "Bah moi j'ai pas de problème en
fait c'est moi je suis victime, pourquoi
je devrais partir ?" Les donc les
brimades ont continué. s'est suicidé et
du coup résultat le commandant lui a dit
c'est pas bien faut pas recommencer
quoi. Donc je veux dire il y a même un
problème raciste dans l'institution et
qui n'est pas réglé parce que la justice
est dans le déni. Voilà, ça a été jugé
également et voilà donc ça pose
sur la vidéo d'ailleurs du 19e, parmi
les fonctionnaires qui pratiquent le
bisutage, il y a aussi des
fonctionnaires issu de la diversité, tu
sais c'est ces fameuses chances pour la
France et cetera. Donc il y a des
fonctionnaires, il y en a un qui est
identifié comme étant d'origine
maghrébine et il se marre avec les
autres. Et tu vois, ça fait partie du
jeu. Moi par exemple, je sais qu'à un
moment, j'étais sur Twitter et tu sais,
il y a un déchaînement là de policiers
fachaot sur Twitter, c'est
insupportable. Donc j'ai décidé à un
moment de clôturer mon compte et en fait
ils ont lancé la rumeur que c'est
Twitter qui avait fermé mon compte, ce
qui était absolument faux. Et donc il y
a un syndicat de commissaire bon qui est
absolument minoritaire mais qui est donc
qui dit oui voilà regardez il s'est fait
fermer son compte enfin justice est
faite et puis tu as un rebeu tu vois qui
qui crie ch tu vois et puis tu vois en
parlant de moi je veux dire tuis pour en
fait donner desg il y a un processus
extrêmement malsin chez les
fonctionnaires d'origine de magrib on le
dit bah tu vois il faut surtout pas être
solidaire des des fonctionnaires qui
luttent contre le racisme il faut les
isoler et le mec écrit cherche tu sais
ça avec un peu d'exotisme. J'ai lu ça
j'ai dit [__] la bal tringue quoi.
vraiment les mecs se couchent mais en
fait au final ils sont tous de toute
façon un moment ostisé ostracisés à un
moment ou à un autre. Tu peux donner
autant de gage que tu veux. Il y a un
moment où ça te rattrape. Et là bah ce
qui s'est passé dans le 19 écoute voilà
c'est le fonctionnaire je suis sûr que
tu vas le voir, tu vas le choper, il va
te dire non moi j'étais partie prenante,
j'étais consentant justement pour jouer
à ce petit jeu, je suis pas victime, mes
collègues sont super cool et cetera. Il
y a tu sais, ils sont formatés. Je veux
dire, c'est comme ça, c'est quelque
chose qui
Oui, mais il va te dire que c'était pas
du bisutage, que c'était un jeu, que
c'était bon voilà tu de toute façon
est-ce que tu as entendu le ministre de
l'interprimer sur le sujet depuis la
vidéo est sortie il y a trois ou qu
jours je veux dire il y a rien eu.
Voilà, fin de l'histoire.
Alexandre Langlois, un policier parisien
à la tête d'un incroyable trafic de
voiture volée, une fraude rarement vue,
ça existe des pourris, des ripou comme
on dit.
Oh, ça existe.
Ça en mange où il y en a de plus en
plus. Plus la crise économique avance,
plus les violences avancent. Est-ce
qu'on voit ça comme en exonion
soviétique une police qui est en train
de se corrompre ?
Bon, il y a toujours eu des cas de
corruption qu'on fait la une dans le 93.
Il y en a aussi déjà qui vendait des
voitures. Voilà. Après,
il vendait des voitures mais il les
vendait comment ? Mais
il les vendait, je sais plus. C'est
pareil dans la presse là. Voilà. Je sais
plus comment il faisait. Il venait
choper. Comment il faisait si tu suivi à
l'époque ? Je crois qu'il
Je crois que c'était sur la
réimmatriculation il me semble. Il y
avait un truc euh ils avaient un filon.
Je sais qu'il y avait des fonctionnaires
du service des cartes grises à la
préfecture de Bobini qui avait été chopé
aussi dans le cadre de cette affaire.
C'était un réseau assez vaste hein où je
crois que je sais plus, il y avait une
affaire de corruption active en tout
cas, ça c'est sûr et de corruption
passive. Il y avait les deux. Donc
j'étais la bague départementale du du de
Bobini du 93. Euh je crois qu'ils
étaient trois ou quatre à avoir été
interpellés à cette époque. Il y avait
des gens du service des cartes grises
aussi. Après bon, j'ai pas les détails,
je m'en souviens plus.
Mais donc voilà, donc ça existe. Il y en
a qui se font choper et après bah les
autres on sait pas parce qu'ils se font
pas choper justement. Ah si tu veux,
c'est ce que je te disais tout à
l'heure. Au début, tu arrives avec un
bac pro et encore avant 2005, il y avait
pas de condition de diplôme. Tu as 2000
balles assez vite. Bon, quand tu arrives
à à cirer les pompes des syndicats, à
passer brigadier ou brigadier chef au
choix, c'est-à-dire sans condition
d'examen, tu arrives un chef, c'est 2006
dans la police. Moi, je suis brigadier,
c'est 2004 quand tout va bien, quand on
me laisse bosser. Donc bon, ben voilà,
quand tu as pas de diplôme, si tu veux,
quand tu as loupé le BEPC puis tu te
retrouves flic à l'époque avant 2005,
c'était ça et tu te retrouves avec 2006
par cooptation. Je veux dire, c'est
bien. Mais après, tu as des gens qui
savent pas s'arrêter, qui ont pas de
limite parce que souvent bah quand tu es
policier euh tu si tu as les bonnes
adresses, tu peux bouffer à l'œil, tu
peux te faire réparer ta caisse et
cetera. Bien sûr. Bah oui, bien sûr il y
a des cantines. Bah ouais,
il y a plein de cantines où les mecs bah
tu sais comme tu as les contrôles CODAF
et puis les mecs bon bah c'est un
système tu vois. Bon ça c'est pas c'est
pas le plus grave. Je veux dire les
mecs,
ça c'est le film avec Thierry l'ermite.
Moi quand je suis arrivé, non, quand je
suis arrivé au SOP au mois du 93, euh il
y avait une kebaberie, hein, ce qu'on
appellerait une kebaberie qui servait
les fonctionnaires. Tu avais le kebab à
2,50 donc tous les midis tu passais ta
commande et puis les mecs, il y a un
équipage qui allait en voiture
sérigraphiée. Pour 2,50 € tu te ramenais
le kebab avec la boisson. Après, moi je
me souviens que une fois je suis allé
dans le resto comme ça et parce que moi
j'ai j'ai participé je dire une fois,
j'y suis aller une fois. Je je le dis
hein très honnêtement, c'était dans les
années 2007 et les le mec le chef de
brigade me dit "Allez viens, on va
chercher les kebabs là pour l'équipage."
Donc les mecs il prend il prend le
laaffiche et tous les mecs posaient 250
dans la tierre et puis hop, on allit
chercher kebab et puis euh quand je suis
rentré, le mec m'a regardé de travers,
il m'a dit "Attends, toi tu es pas tu es
pas flic et tout parce queil me
connaissait pas puis en plus il me voit
rebeux tout ça." Et je dis "Si si, je
suis avec monsieur Intel là, il me dit
"Ah ok" et puis il me donne le sac avec
les kebabs et puis le mec il m'attend,
il dit "Allez, on y va." Et donc c'est
un système après bon moi c'est un
système que j'ai dénoncé après par la
suite
en contrepartie c'est quoi c'est parce
qu'il est content de donner
le mec il flip de se faire contrôler et
tout ça donc tu vois faut toujours être
pote avec les flics donc voilà il était
pas raqueté hein je pense que c'était
consenti et donc bon bah je moi je pense
que j'ai dû en bouffer une ou deux fois
de de ce truc là de ce système là et
après on est allé bah voilà et puis
après ça moi je l'ai dénoncé après par
la suite j'ai dit non c'est pas normal
le mec en fait après quand je suis
arrivé au RG parce qu'à l'époque j'étais
stagiaire donc je pouvais que fermer ma
gueule he j'avais pas de Et donc du coup
quand je suis passé au RG à la fin de
mon anestage, j'ai dit il y a un mec là
qui qui qui en joue un petit peu qui va
être pote avec les fogues. J'en ai parlé
à mon boss, j'ai dit bon faut comment
est-ce qu'on peut casser le système ?
m'a dit "Bah, on va lui on va lui coller
un codef et puis comme ça il va se
rendre compte que ça le protège pas." Et
puis bon, on a fait puis ça c'est mais
globalement tu vois comme je te dis bon
tu touches 2006, tu es plutôt bien, tu
as pas le tu vois, tu as même pas tu as
un bac pro dans le meilleur des cas ou
et puis bon tu tuas tu as plein de
petits business comme ça à droite à
gauche, bah tu sais, tu en as qui savent
pas s'arrêter. Je veux dire, bon si tu
arrives à bouffer ton sandwich un peu
moins cher, c'est pas le plus grave
honnêtement c'est pas grave. Mais
payer le café au flic, on a droit de
payer le café au flic.
Bah ça dépend après, c'est si tu
demandes rien en contrepartie, je veux
dire, c'est pas grave, ça le fait. Mais
euh bon après faut trouver les limites
et puis bon tu en a qui disent bah 2006
c'est pas assez moi je veux 4000 5000
6000 et puis ça s'arrête pas. Donc les
voitures tu sais le trafic inter
véhicules je pense que c'est pas mal tu
vois ça tu multiplies facilement ton
salaire quoi. Tu
aussi bah c'était la bac nord à
Marseille sur du stup enfin voilà il y a
toujours des dérives malheureusement qui
sont pas très bien encadré quoi ça cette
histoire là
c'était la baque nord de Marseille qui
prenait un peu la
runer les indiques. Non
je sais plus comment il se débrouillait.
La seule chose que j'ai retenu de
l'histoire, c'est que le gars qui a
dénoncé le truc avec l'accord du
procureur qui a mis des écoutes, c'est
le seul qui a été emmerdé le plus
longtemps et qui a pas été reclassé tout
de suite quoi. Il a mis 2 ans moins 2
ans parce qu'après j'ai pu regarder
l'affaire mais et c'est lui qui était le
plus embêté alors qu'il avait agi sous
couvert du procureur pour mettre tout en
place. Donc donc voilà, donc c'est
toujours la problématique de qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quand on a des choses entre
les mains. Voilà, il y a eu des cas
aussi bah par exemple à Orle qui vendait
des informations à des services
marocains. Donc il y a toujours des
petits billets à se prendre à droite à
gauche.
Un voyage he il a même pas pris le tune.
Lui c'était il se faisait inviter sur
des semaines à Marrakech. Bon à mon avis
il devait se faire tu vois bon il devait
y avoir des petites services de finition
on va dire mais bon voilà après je veux
dire de toute façon on l'a dénoncé à la
DRPP c'est arrivé. On en a parlé de ma
dernière interview. On a un un
contrôleur général, c'est tu peux pas,
il y a qu'un seul grade au-dessus, c'est
inspecteur général. Le mec il a il a
tapé dans la caisse des frais d'enquête
pour rénover son château en province.
Quand ça vient du sommet à l'époque, lui
il s'est fait toper pour 2000 € mais
puis il les a restitué. Bon c'est comme
tous les délit, je veux dire, tu te fais
sur 100 fois, tu vas te faire toper une
fois et puis tu vas dire c'est la
première fois que ça m'arrive, je vous
le jure. Mais quand ça vient du haut, je
veux dire tu peux pas tu peux pas en
vouloir au gardien de la paix. Tu vois
quand c'est une minorité,
on sait pas comment tu Oui, je vais te
dire oui moi naturellement. Bah oui,
mais tu peux pas savoir. Voilà. Moi
quand je suis passé en con discipline
euh moi j'ai pris 6 mois ferme sur la
vie du conseil de discipline et 18 mois
avec surcis. Lui, il a pris 6 mois ferme
et 6 mois avec surcis. Je pense qu'il y
a des facteurs aggravants chez moi qui
ont fait que
6 mois ferme, c'est-à-dire
de suspension de salaire.
De suspension de salaire.
Ouais. Ouais. Et avant moi, il y a un
type qui est passé au conseil de
discipline de la DRPP d'ailleurs et il
s'était fait choper pour une
escroquerie. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'en
fait, il avait oublié les clés de chez
lui dans son appartement et il a appelé
le serruier. Le serruier dit "Ah tiens,
tu es flic toi et tout, vas-y, je vais
t'arranger. Je te fais une facture à
1500 balles en fait, tu me donnes 600 en
liquide puis ton assurance va te
rembourser comme ça tu te fais même un
billet sur la transaction." il l'a fait.
Puis après, bon bah c'est une affaire
qui est passée dans la presse. Le Cruier
s'est fait choper pour bah pour ça pour
euh pour escroquerie en bonne organisé
d'ailleurs parce que c'était un système
dans les commissariats qui étaient rodé,
les mecs prenaient un billet tout ça. Et
bon le sérier bah naturellement
en bon escroc, qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ?
Bah quand il s'est fait choper, il est
passé chez les bœufs carottes, il a dit
"Ouais mais de toute façon, j'ai des
infos pour vous. Si ça peut alléger mon
fardeau, bah je vais vous donner des
noms." Il a donné le nom de ce collègue
et ce collègue, il se trouve qu'il est
passé avant moi au conseil de
discipline. Quand je dis "Ah, tu es là,
pourquoi C'est parce qu'on fait la queue
pour l'abattoir. Il m'a il m'a raconté
l'histoire. Bon voilà, le pauvre he il a
mordu à l'hameçon. Le pauvre. Bon ben
voilà, il s'est fait choper pénalement.
Il a payé pénalement. Je crois qu'il a
eu un rappel à la loi ou à une COPJ ou
je sais plus. C'était pas très lourd en
pénal. Et euh il est passé en conseil de
discipline. Lui, il a pris un mois ferme
et 8 mois avec surcis je crois ou un
truc comme ça. Quand il est sorti, je
dis "Fais pas appel he tu t'en sors
bien, c'est bon quoi." Et à mon avis he
je lui ai donné ce conseil là et euh
et donc ouais, comme je te dis, ça fait
partie du truc quoi. Je veux dire ça,
voilà le le mec ça la corruption, elle
est partout à des niveaux plus ou moins
graves. Mais là, c'est pas grave. C'est
une affaire de clé, de serrerie. Quand
tu vas toucher au stupéfiant, à tout ça,
je pense que c'est un tu vois, c'est un
autre monde. Avais tapé 25000 € là euh
qui est chargé de l'agrégation de Non,
non,
25000 € le chiffre me dit rien comme ça.
Euh, je dois confondre. Question
d'Internet : Est-ce que la BAC est
performante stratégiquement dans la
lutte contre la le trafic de drogue ?
Si elle était utilisée correctement, ça
pourrait. Le principe d'une BAC quand
ils étaient mis en place, ça a été de la
discrétion, le civil pour pouvoir choper
les gens en flagrant délit. Aujourd'hui,
ils sont dès que la BAC arrive n'importe
où, ils sont connus comme le loup blanc
parce qu'ils font des interpellations
parce qu'on leur a demandé aussi de
faire du chiffre. Donc, ils font des
interpellations pour la boulette de
cheat et cetera et tout le quartier les
connaît. Et il y avait encore quelque
chose qui sauvait dans certains
départements, c'est qu'il y avait des
bacs départementales, c'estàd qu'elle
tournait sur tout le département pour
justement éviter de se faire des
troncher très rapidement. Et ça, ils ont
dit non, on veut plus, on va les mettre
au niveau des commissariats. Donc en
fait sur le principe comment ça avait
été pensé au départ, oui, aujourd'hui
enfin ça sert à rien parce que
finalement ils font du contrôle
d'identité, ça dérape, tout le monde les
connaît et euh bah leur rôle initial
n'est plus n'est plus là.
Mais la question est mal posée. La BAC,
elle est pas là pour lutter contre le
trafic de stupéfiant, elle est là pour
faire du flagrant d'élit. Euh le trafic
de subvivance, c'est plutôt le rôle de
la police judiciaire, des services comme
ceux du 36 et les BSU au minimum, les
brigades de sûreté urbaine, les sûretés
territorial ou départementale et euh
dans le haut du de la pyramide, c'est
l'octrice de la police judiciaire ou les
services de police judiciaire, les
services départementaux. la bac, elle
est là pour faire du flagrant d'élit et
c'est en fait si tu veux c'est un peu le
c'est un peu les les gros biceps, on va
dire des services de l'État quoi. Je ils
sont appelés pour faire du flagrant des
lit mais ils ont pas de suivi sur la
procédure et le ce qu'on appelle le
trafic hein au sens propre du terme,
c'est le trafic international ou quoi
que ce soit, c'est pas leur job.
Alors tu avais raison, c'est les pistes
envisagées couvre-feu des 17h en cas de
non déconfinement le 15 décembre.
J'ai souvent raison.
Euh po je juste je je je feuillette les
les milliers de questions que tu
feuillettes. Il y avait un truc que je
voulais rajouter tout à l'heure sur le
contrôle aux facièes euh parce qu'il y a
plein de syndicats de police qui sont
montrés au créneau en disant voilà le
contrôle au faciè on va arrêter et
cetera mais je je rappelle que les
policiers appliquent la loi et que le
contrôle au faè ça a été légalisé par
Oui. a été légalisé comme une lettre à
la poste dans la loi qui a mis dans la
loi normale l'état d'urgence permanent
en fait en novembre novembre 2017 et
dedans il y a marqué que pour la lutte
antiterroriste, on doit pouvoir
contrôler les gens sur leur type
étranger et leur aspect extérieur
objectif étranger. Et on avait posé la
question défin ce que c'est
qu'objectivement une apparence
extérieure étrangère, on n pas eu de
réponse. Donc en fait déjà la défense
est très mauvaise, c'est qu'en fait la
défense c'est ça a été voté en 2017 par
le gouvernement de monsieur Macron donc
ça a été légalisé.
C'est joyeux le fichage pour vos
opinions politiques tendances sexuel
c'est la suite d'Edvig le fichier viigez
du coup c'est au goût du jour là ils
s'en ont reparlé c'est sorti là hier ou
avant aujourd'hui ou je ne sais plus bah
c'est la suite logique du contrôle de la
population en fait on est sur quand on
prend tout le schéma on a eu le
changement du code de déontologie en
2014 on défend plus les libertés
individuelles mais les lois on a eu la
loi enseignant sur laquelle on s'était
rencontré à l'époque, on était opposé
parce que le premier ministre peut
mettre sur écoute qui veut. On a eu
l'état d'urgence, l'état d'urgence
permanent et maintenant on a la loi
sécurité globale. Donc on arrive au
fichage des des gens qui posent
problèmes pour le gouvernement. Donc on
est sur une police qui va devenir sur du
politique et je donne l'anecdote parce
que ça m'avait choqué au service du
renseignement territorial. On nous a
demandé une ou deux fois euh de demander
que pensent les gens des discours du
président de la République. Non mais je
veux dire voilà où on en est rendu.
C'est dire que s'il veut savoir ça, il
s'interroge l'OP LRE face n'importe quel
institut de sondage mais c'est pas le
rôle de la police de s'enquérir de
l'opinion des gens. Et bah du coup on
est toujours sur la même chose et c'est
que légalement c'est interdit mais après
ils vont pouvoir contourner le truc sauf
s'ils se font prendre la main dans le
sac. ce qu'ils avaient fait par exemple
pour les gilets jaunes. Au début, ils
avaient demandé de ficher les gilets
jaunes, leur nom, leur prénom, leur
profession et plein de détails. Ils
avaient oublié de le déclarer. Donc du
coup, ils ont dit "Ah, c'est un oubli,
on va modifier puis hop, c'est passé à
la trappe". Parce que quelqu'un avait
dénoncé la manipe. De toute façon, ça
existe déjà. Je veux dire, moi je suis
je suis presque pour en réalité au
risque de choquer un peu l'auditoire
parce qu'aujourd'hui, par exemple, cette
semaine, j'ai été saisi à titre syndical
du cas d'un collègue de l'ASdat français
de souche, blanc comme neige et qui
s'est converti à l'islam. Ils l'ont
désarmé. Ils l'ont demandé de de de de
laisser son arme, je dirais dans le
coffre. Donc à un moment, tu vois bien
que de toute façon, il y a des
problématiques. Si tu veux, on essaie de
formaliser ça d'une façon
il s'est converti à l'islam. Et pourquoi
ils lui ont demandé de se désarmer ?
Bah justement, c'est pour ça qu' qu'on
m'en a parlé. C'est pas lui qui est venu
m'en parler, c'est quelqu'un
il s'est converti à l'islam
qui est déjà surveillé. Bah le mec si tu
veux, il a donné des signes, il il était
blanc et cetera puis ça a surpris quoi
parce que le mec a arrêté de manger euh
bah il a mangé d'une certaine manière et
cetera et le mec l'a assumé hein. Il a
dit "Oui oui, si effectivement je dois
m'en justifier, je suis converti à
l'islam, il y a aucun problème." Et il a
essayé de s'en défendre. Si un moment on
considère que ça pose un problème, c'est
qu'on parle de fichage religieux, on va
pas ficher les raéliens ou ou euh dans
la police ?
J'en sais rien, je sais pas. Mais ce que
je veux dire par là, c'est que bon,
globalement, on sait très bien que ce
qui est dans le cadre de toute façon de
ce qui se profile de la loi
antiséparatisme, on va dire que c'est
bien c'est l'islam en tant que religion
qui est dans le viseur un petit peu des
autorités. Donc si effectivement
aujourd'hui on officialise le fait qu'il
y a un lien entre l'islam et le
terrorisme, bon sachant que l'islamisme
ou le terrorisme serait des dérives de
la religion musulmane et on qu'on le
définit comme tel. Bah à limite qu'on
nous le dise et puis on organise ça en
fichier et puis voilà. Et comme ça au
moins tu as une base légale pour te
défendre parce que quand c'est du non
dit quand on va chercher des prétexte
euh bah justement tu as au plan
judiciaire tu as pas les armes pour te
défendre. Et donc quelque part en
réalité si on élabore un fichier
discriminatoire parce que c'est de ça
dont il s'agit que moi il manque que
l'orientation sexuelle he je veux dire
si la base du fichage c'est le le le le
le la conviction politique et les
convictions religieuses effectivement
bon ben il manque que ça et on on
retourne survige justement donc tu vois
bien que quelque part il y a un rouleau
compresseur je veux dire on veut passer
des réformes bon ben quand ça bugueule
un petit peu dans dans les rues, c'est
qu'une question de temps mais à un
moment ou un autre on revient à la
charge et ça passe au final. Donc je
veux dire si ça peut donner les armes
légales pour se défendre face à un
tribunal et qu'on peut faire annuler les
décisions face au tribunal
administratif, pourquoi pas ? Je veux
dire parce que de toute façon ça
s'applique actuellement ça
ça n'arrivera pas non plus parce qu'au
tribunal le ministère dit il y a une
note blanche et vous aurez pas le
contenu.
Donc du coup et c'est arrivé pour des
personnes qui ont été jugées et
sur ça donc en fait ça va pas régler le
problème par contre ça va
si ça fichier c'est à la limite le
fichier il a une base légale à l'acnil
donc on est plus dans la note blanche
donc ça va quoi. Je dire ça.
Question d'internet. Euh, suite au
scandale Claude Guéan, existe-t-il
toujours des primes en liquide ? Les
gratification donné au bon flic ?
Alors, c'est pas il y a pas de voilà,
c'est pas des primes en liquide, c'était
des c'était pour les frais de mission et
les des fois les rouages et cetera.
c'était euh quand les fonds un petit peu
dans certains services de police
judiciaire ou de renseignement, on a des
enveloppes qui sont pas forcément
mirobolante mais qui permettent de payer
un café, un contact sans pour autant
engranger enfin je veux dire faire des
notes dans tous les sens de facture
parce que dès qu'on descend pense 1 €
dans l'administration c'est des papiers
dans tous les sens. Donc ils ont dit
pour faciliter la gestion, on va vous
filer à les 100 € pour le mois à tant de
fonctionnaire et puis ça vous pai les
cafés, un sandwich sur la kebab avec vos
contacts, ce sera bien quoi. Donc c'est
pour ça et Claude Garant lui ce qu'il a
fait c'est qu'il s'est attribué des
frais d'enquête pour lui alors qu'il
était ministre. Ça pose des Non, il
était fond les fonds les fonds existent
toujours si c'est la question. Ouais en
fait l'idée c'est que tu peux pas
rémunérer un indique de toute façon
parce que ça sert à rémunérer les
indiques. On va pas employer d'autres
termes entre autres. Donc du coup bah il
faut pas que ce soit traçable. Ça
signifie que si tu bosses à la banque et
que tu vois qu'il y a un virement que
qu'un plombier reçoit un virement du
ministère de l'intérieur pour un montant
de 500 € ou de 1000 € toutes les
semaines, je veux dire bah ça crée une
suspicion et ça crée une trace une
traçabilité et donc bah pour pas que
justement les ind pour la sécurité des
indiques parce que il faut savoir que
pour pour un indique qui travaille
notamment sur le terro ou ou même les
commités étrangères dans certaines
communautés tout ce qui est curde turc
et cetera, pacos ça rigole pas. Donc ils
se font ils se font ils se font
pakistanais.
Pakistanais. Oui. Voilà. Bon c'est ils
se font ils se font désinguer hein les
mecs he quand ils se font découvrir.
Donc du coup pour leur sécurité ils sont
rémunérés en liquide et donc il faut
qu'il y ait une base d'argent en
liquide. C'est les fonds secrets du
premier ministre qui sont plus à
disposition du ministre de l'intérieur
en réalité et du ministre de la défense
d'ailleurs que que du premier ministre.
Ça existe toujours. Ouais. Est-ce que
vous avez peur quand vous voyez alors
est-ce que vous avez peur en tant que
policier parce que vous êtes encore
policier quand il y a des manifestation
de chechen dans les rues
qui s'affiche ostentatoirement
récemment on a eu les Turcs contre les
Arméniens aussi c'était chaud aussi hein
parce que le le le fait qu'il y ait des
communautés qui se permettent d'aller
dans les rues pour
En fait c'est pas en tant que policier
que j'ai peur j'ai plutôt peur sur les
institutions du pays moi. Parce qu'en
tant que policier les chechen ils sont
toujours très gentils avec les policiers
he techniquement c'est pas nous qui vont
attaquer
avec les profs parfois pas tous mais
voilà mais du coup c'était pas la
communauté de chechen là c'était sur un
cas de radicalisation donc c'est autre
chose et les chechen sont organisés et
en fait pourquoi ils ont agi par exemple
à Dijon ils ont dit on a voir les
pouvoirs publics ils ont rien fait donc
nous on est organisé de façon nationale
c'est qu'on passe un coup de fil et les
tchchenes de toute la France vont
rappliquer et on va régler nos problèmes
comme comme chez nous enchenie donc en
fait moi c'est un problème des services
publics un problème d'ordre public Mais
euh des collègues à Renn me disent "Il y
a des chechen qui sont dans un immeuble
parce que leur technique c'est de
dégager tous les autres occupants au fur
et à mesure pour avoir l'immeuble que
pour eux. C'est l'immeuble plus calme de
la cité quoi. C'està dire qu'ils font la
loi. Mais est-ce que c'est admissible
dans une République que des gens ou des
communautés fassent la loi sur leur
territoire ? La réponse est non. Donc
c'est pas en tant que policier que j'ai
peur parce que ces gens-là nous
attaquent pas spécialement, mais c'est
pour les valeurs de la République et
l'égalité sur le territoire de dire on
accepte que des gens fassent la loi chez
nous.
Alors au risque, moi je suis pas
spécialement d'accord mais je suis pas
non plus contre ce qu'il dit mais j'ai
une opinion qui est tout autre en fait
sur le sujet parce que j'ai beaucoup
bossé sur certaines communauté pas
spécialement sur les chechen chaînes
quoi qu'on avait un vivian oisil grand à
l'époque dans le 93 justement un
immeuble une sorte d'hôtel de fortune
qui était squatté bon bref déjà lescchen
il y en a pas eu qu'un il y en a eu deux
he on a eu un attentat aussi sur la rue
de l'AP là pas loin de l'opéra il me
semble que c'était la rue de l'appe
pendant l'été 2018 il me semble hein
plus chaque Ouais, il avait poignardé
des passants. Donc ça fait deux pour une
communauté quand même extrêmement
minoritaire. Bon, il y a matière à se
poser la question. Je pense que euh
c'est des gens qui nous nous on troit le
statut de réfugié à des gens qui qui
viennent se réfugier en France, c'est il
y a pas de souci. C'est ça fait partie
de nos traditions. Et par contre, il
faut il faut aussi les formater en
quelque sorte. Faut leur expliquer que
la France c'est un pays paisible, que
nous on a de problème avec personne et
que chez nous bah justement c'est pas la
peine d'aller importer les conflits
étrangers. Donc si donc on peut pas
finalement leur décerner comme ça des
titres de de séjour et pas leur
expliquer ce qu'on attend justement
d'eux en contrepartie parce qu'on a eu
aussi un soudanais he roman surizer qui
a poignardé. On en a eu un autre à
Toulouse dans la foulée. Donc je veux
dire ça mérite quand même de
d'approfondir un petit peu le sujet.
Après euh par opportunisme politique, je
pense que les les les hommes politiques
successifs ont joué avec le feu.
C'est-à-dire que quand Sarkozy a décrété
une loi mémorielle sur le génocide
arménien, euh Erdogan lui a répondu
"Ouais, mais est-ce que vous avez
travaillé déjà sur la mémoire de ce qui
s'est passé en Algérie avant d'aller
vous mêler de ce qui se passe chez les
autres ?" Je donne pas tort là-dessus.
C'estàdire qu'on aujourd'hui, on en fait
un portrait, je veux dire, mais il a il
a eu raison. Je veux dire, quel à quel
titre est-ce qu'on s'est permis nous de
légiférer ? parce que c'est pas rien.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a créé un délit
d'opinion sur la mémoire collective des
Arméniens alors qu'on n'est pas du tout
concerné ni de près ni de loin par le
génocide arménien. Même si au plan
humain bien sûr qu'on est concerné et ce
qui s'est passé là-bas c'est sans doute
terrible. Mais je veux dire tu vois ce
qui s'est passé quoi récemment. Je veux
dire, on a eu de la chasse réciproque à
l'arménien puis au Turc, hein, sur le
territoire français. Et la police, je
veux dire, franchement, ils étaient pas
en ils étaient pas en mesure de
s'interposer quoi. Très concrètement,
euh, tu as vu les images comme moi sur
internet, les chaten à un moment, on
s'est emballé après ce qui s'est passé à
Dijon. Les gens se sont dit "Ouais, dans
l'opinion publique, ouais, vive les
chaten". Enfin, on a la solution
justement antidélinquence maghrébine, he
c'est comme ça que ça a été présenté sur
les réseaux sociaux. Et dans la foulée,
on a même eu dans dans le Parisien 77 un
article sur une milice quoi, une police
privée qui faisait le ménage dans les
immeubles à Meline.
Ouais. avec des chetchen chen en disant
"Ouais bah voilà, avec eux au moins bah
voilà et hop de semaines après Samuel
Patier, les gens disent "Ah ouais, mais
finalement peut-être qu'on aurait dû
réfléchir." Donc c'est pas la bonne
solution. Nous, on a jamais fonctionné
comme ça. Et même pour prolonger, je
dirais l'interview qu'on avait fait la
dernière fois, je veux dire un mec qui
veut se casser de France parce que la
francité l'intéresse pas et qui veut
aller se faire citoyen de l'État
islamique en Syrie. Moi, limite je le
subventionne. C'est c'est choquant ce
que je dis. Je lui paye le billet
d'avion, je dis casse-toi mais surtout
ne reviens pas quoi. Ici en France, on
mobilise des moyens de surveillance pour
les empêcher de partir. Et à la fin,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Saint-Étienne
du Rouvret, les deux mecs qui sont sous
bracelet électronique, ils vont égorger
un prêtre. Cassez-vous les gars. Je veux
dire, si ça vous intéresse pas, moi je
vous subventionne. Je veux dire, tu
vois, il y a un moment où la politique
de l'État français, moi je il y a des
moments où j'ai du mal à avoir de la
lisibilité sur les objectifs de l'État
français en la matière. Euh donc
effectivement, bah à la fin, c'est un
terrain d'affrontement communautaire.
Là, j'ai parlé de ces communautés-là,
mais dans le 93, moi j'ai vécu les
tamoules contre les Saint-alais, je
crois ou tu vois les les Sri Lankais,
ils sont pas à Goussin-ville là. La
semaine dernière, on a eu un scalp, tu
vois, il y a de semaines, pardon, un
mail des tu vois un conflit interne là
au Sriilanquais et les trois les quatre
étaient de nationalité silankaise. Il y
a un type qui s'est fait scalper mais
dans le 93, moi j'avais eu des mecs qui
s'étaaient fait couper les avant-bras
là, tu sais c'estàd que qui s'étaaient
fait sectionner au niveau des avant-bras
et cetera. C'était assez c'était pas
fréquent mais ça arrivait. On a même un
collègue de la police judiciaire euh
dans le 93 qui s'est fait tirer, qui
s'est fait dérober des Sri Lankais. Ils
lui ont tiré 9 balles dans la tête. Je
veux te dire ça rigole pas quoi. C'est
un type de la PJ je c'était en 2000 en
2009. Donc euh
donc je pense que c'est pas en fait on
peut pas c'est pas un discours d'extrême
droite que de dire ça même si souvent
mais je veux dire on peut pas accueillir
un volume de personnes comme ça qui
viennent de zone de conflit sans les
reformater en leur disant bah ici du
calme vous pouvez respirer par contre et
sans contractualiser en fait le statut
de réfugié. C'est leur expliquer que
c'est pas quelque chose de définitif.
C'est pas quelque chose d'acquis qu'ici
il y a un comportement adopté. Il y a
des codes culturels et tu vois c'est ce
qui s'est passé sur Nice dont on parlait
tout à l'heure. Pardon je c'est c'est
dramatique ça. Le mec il il est en
Italie, il prend un train, il vient en
France, il égorge des gens. En plus
franchement l'avion médicalisé quand
même de Nice pour Paris pour aller
l'auditionner, c'est quand même choquant
pour moi. C'est que le mec limite il
aurait fallu, tu vois, l'interroger dans
les règles de l'art, peut-être même
l'envoyer en Tunisie pour ça.
Non mais je veux dire les Tunisiens
auraient auraient auraient apporté leur
concours, je veux dire, à l'enquête.
Mais tu tu as dépêché un avion
médicalisé sur le tarmac avec des
équipes de chirurgien, de médecins et
cetera pour le transporter à Paris.
C'est choquant en période de Covid quand
tu sais qu'on a pas de moyens pour
l'hôpital pour soigner justement nos
aînés. Je veux dire bon, il y a un
moment où tu vois c'est moi ça me pose
problème, je peux pas te dire le
contraire.
Après après si c'est pour aller chercher
de l'information pour lui montrer que
voilà, il sera bien traité donc il donne
de l'information peut-être non, on sait
jamais.
Bah à condition qu'il y ait de
l'information, je veux dire franchement
que le mec doit avoir un cuit d'huître.
Il a fait ça parce qu'il a été sans
doute bon. Je pense que les me les mecs
qui l'ont envoyé doivent doivent savoir
ce qu'ils font. Donc je pense qu'ils ont
quand même pas donné ils ont pas donné
la la possibilité de d'être
particulièremente.
Question pour Alexandre Langlois.
Que dire aujourd'hui à un jeune qui
souhaite servir en devenant policier ?
Mais c'est un bel engagement par contre.
C'est un bel engagement mais qui est
beaucoup dévoyé par nos politiques
depuis des années. Donc soit il y a deux
tactiques, soit il y a un engagement
massif de personnes qui veulent rentrer
dans la police et pour dégager tous ceux
qui posent problèmes et qui savent
qu'ils vont avoir les ners d'acier pour
aller jusqu'au bout des choses. Soit
sinon ça va être bah ça va être le
désespoir. Donc ne pas y aller. Ne pas y
aller. Et je le dis le désespoir
d'autant plus c'est que je vais reparler
du suicide des policiers. Les suicides
dans la population française, c'est la
première cause de mort violente en
France
de en dehors de du crime organisé et
cetera. Mais et du coup euh les tranches
d'âge où les gens suicident, c'est moins
de 25 ou plus de 65 ans. Dans la police,
c'est quarantaine. On a l'exception
française dans les statistiques. Moment
où on est en pleine ascension
professionnelle, on a déjà une vie
familiale stabilisée. Donc c'est des
gens qui n'y croient plus, qui ne savent
plus comment s'en sortir. Donc si on
rentre dans la police, faut savoir qu'il
faut avoir des ners d'acier plus pour
lutter contre l'administration que
contre les criminels. Parce que les
policiers à l'heure actuelle n'ont pas
peur d'aller s'occuper d'un braqueur,
d'un terroriste. Ils vont sur le
terrain, ils prennent des risques. Ils
ont peur du gars dans son bureau qui
tient un stylo qui peut casser leurs
carrière, leurs vacances et cetera. Donc
si on a ça dans sa tête, on peut venir
parce que c'est un beau métier qui est
utile. Si on na pas ça dans sa tête,
faut mieux faire autre chose parce que
du coup on risque de mal finir. Sauf s'
a une évolution positive de la police et
avec un GPN citoyen, des réformes
républicaines et cetera. Mais pour le
moment, c'est pas à l'ordre du jour.
Alors quand on est policier, on doit
tirer combien de cartouches par an pour
s'entraîner ? On doit on a trois dans
les policiers lambda hein, je parle donc
dont je fais partie. On a 3/ ti3 par an
de 30 cartouches. Donc ça fait 90
cartouches par an. Euh sauf que
l'administration ne les assure même pas.
La Cour des comptes avait fait un
rapport l'année dernière 2 ans en disant
que 51 % des policiers ne faisaient pas
leurs trois tirers réglementaires euh
pour l'avoir vécu sur mon département.
Le stand de tir par exemple, ils avaient
pas payé le contrat d'entretien. Donc
pendant un an pas de stand de tir. Euh
toutes les toutes les traces qu'il y a
dans les murs, c'est c'est les policiers
qui viennent s'entraîner ou quoi ?
Dans les murs où ça ?
Dans les stands de tir ? Ouais. Il y a
pas mal de traces à côté. Ouais, des
frappes à côté. Il y en a il y en a
beaucoup. Les murs sont sont criblés de
balles.
Ouais, ça disons qu' il y a des cas.
Ouais, je pense que il faut il faudrait
aussi je pense qu'il faudrait installer
un cabinet de d'oftalmo
à l'entrée des stands de tir parce qu'il
y en a tu te demandes comment ils font.
Ah ouais, même le plafond, il y a pas
que les murs le plafond est criblé
aussi. Des fois des fois c'est un peu
flippant. Après euh ouais, il y a alors
comme il disait, ouais, il y a trois
séances obligatoires, on peut en faire
plus en fonction des services. Donc
c'est 30 euh ces deux chargeurs garnis,
donc 30 cartouches. Et effectivement euh
en au plan théorique, euh les cartouches
peuvent être réformées au bout d'un
certain temps. Donc bah on tire avec les
cartouches qu'on a et puis elles sont
renouvelées à cette occasion en fait.
Voilà.
Euh autre question ?
Non, les traces de ball, on a déjà
parlé. Il paraît qu'ils font pas de
sport dans la police.
C'est vrai. Alors dans les textes, c'est
pareil, c'est un peu comme le RO. On a 2
heures de sport obligatoire par semaine.
Le chef de service doit les organiser,
c'est jamais fait. Et donc c'est au
fonctionnaires de se débrouiller pour
forcer l'administration à faire cette 2
heures de sport. Donc dans certains
services, c'est possible, dans d'autres
non. Et c'est bien malheureux parce
qu'on a des notations surtout. Mais
comme disent certains collègues, ce
serait bien qu'on fasse un petit cooper
dans la notation pour savoir c'est bien
d'écrire des procédures, mais on doit
aussi courir après les voleurs.
Comment on passe ? de la police après
Charlie qui était adulé et au foudre des
gilets jaunes.
Bah c'est pas la même police en fait.
C'est deux contexte complètement
différents. Une un c'est les policiers
qui font de la lutte antiterrorisme et
l'autre côté c'est le maintien de
l'ordre en France. Donc à chaque fois
c'est des policiers avec des missions
différentes dans des contextes
différents. Donc effectivement qu'on
pose la question aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous êtes content d'avoir des policiers
qui vous protègent des attentats ? La
réponse de tout le monde sera oui.
Est-ce que vous êtes content d'avoir des
policiers qui mutilent et qui blessent
dans les manifestations des innocents ?
Euh la réponse sera non. Donc en fait,
c'est la question une fois de plus
médiatique à l'heure actuelle qui est
pas posée de façon honnête ou
pertinente, je ne sais pas. Voilà, c'est
"Est-ce que vous aimez ou pas la police
?" C'est toujours pas le la le fond du
problème. C'est quel policier vous
voulez, quel policier vous voulez et
quel policier vous aimez et quelle
police vous voulez. Donc si on pose
cette question là, en fait les policiers
qui font leur travail correctement sont
toujours aimés. Par contre,
malheureusement, c'est les dérapages des
policiers qui ne sont pas sanctionnés,
qui donnent une mauvaise image et qui
fait que certaines personnes gardent
cette image en tête et disent "Bah moi,
j'aime pas la police ou je l'adule pas
comme au moment de Charlie. parce que
c'est ces policiers là de l'affaire
Michel Zcler, Zinebrine et cetera euh
que j'ai en tête.
L'histoire, elle est remancée de toute
façon. Tu c'est l'histoire Charlie 13
novembre, Bataclan et cetera. En France,
on a quand même la faculté de raconter
des histoires et parfois bah de
transformer des histoires un peu euh on
va dire à l'odeur un peu sulfureuse.
On a on a le don de les réécrire et de
les parfumer un peu à l'eau de rose. Je
le 13 novembre en réalité tout comme
Charlie, ce sont des fiascos. Le le
procès de Charlie a lu en ce moment.
Bon, je crois qu'on a les réquisitions
qui ont été prononcées ce matin
d'ailleurs. Bon, 30 ans de réclusion
qu'on travaille de Bouédien alors qu'on
sait même pas si elle est encore en vie.
on a la quasi certitude qu'on la
retrouvera jamais et qu'elle remettra
jamais à pied en France. Je pense que
c'est ça fait partie du processus de
deuil psychologique pour les familles de
victimes. Mais on sait très bien que ça
a cloché à un moment. Je veux dire le
vrai procès en réalité il serait pour
ceux qui ont laissé qui qui ont fait en
sorte que ça puisse arriver. En réalité
très clairement les Kachi se retrouvent
comme ça sans surveillance à reince
reviennent en région parisienne
tranquillou. Je veux dire euh c'est ça
la vraie question, c'est pas c'est pas
savoir ce qu'on fait d'adbumien ou de
des seconds couteaux et le 13 novembre
c'est pire encore. Je veux dire pardon
hein.
Je vais juste finir sur Charlie comme ça
tu f 13 novembre. En plus c'est qu'il y
a un syndicat de police qui avait dit
faut Charlie on en a marre de les
surveiller donc faut alléger la
surveillance de Charlie et de ses
locaux.
Ils ont supprimé le point fixe
d'ailleurs c'est ça qui leur a permis de
prendre la décision. Donc je veux dire
une fois de plus pour faire plaisir à
certains syndicats qui aimaient pas
Charlie parce que pour eux c'était des
gens salgants des gens d'extrême gauche
qui voulaient pas voir voilà pour des
raisons idéologiques et pas des raisons
opérationnelles. Ils ont réussi à faire
le préfet que le préfet de police
supprime le point fixe.
Le point fixe c'était la patrouille
statique en fait avec des policiers qui
étaient en bas de l'immeuble. C'est
peut-être ça, hein. C'est peut-être la
suppression du du point fix qui a qui a
qui a fait que à un moment les quasis se
sont dit "Bon bah c'est bon, il y a plus
personne en bas, on peut y aller." On
sait pas, on sait pas ce qui s'est passé
dans leur tête parce que de toute façon,
ils ont été tués au moment de
l'attentat. Mais il y a plein
d'histoires, c'est-à-dire que bon, par
exemple, c'est facile à dire, c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire, mais à un
moment sur les images de l'intervention
à l'hypercacher, on voit un policier qui
rampe, qui se prend une balle. Tu l'as
vu ? Euh et les gens disent "Ouais, il
s'est pris euh c'est pas Koulibali qui a
répliqué, c'est un de ses collègues qui
était derrière qui lui a tiré dans le
bras, tu vois." Et on le sait
aujourd'hui rétrospectivement.
Est-ce qu'il était nécessaire comme ça
de d'envoyer des policiers de la brigade
d'intervention en meut pour tirer, vider
leur chargeur ? Vaut mieux peut-être
deux policiers, deux snipers qui vont
faire le boulot plutôt que des gens
comme ça qui se pointent et qui le
criblent de balles. Tu vois,
stratégiquement, c'est c'est quelque
chose qui a été mal pensé. Le 13
novembre, c'est pareil.
Après, il y a des gens à l'intérieur, il
est armé jusqu'aux dents.
Ouais, mais on sait faire ça. Je veux
dire, quand le mec à un moment sort et
pointe le bout de son nez à l'extérieur,
un sniper efficace vaut mieux que 60
policiers en meutre. La preuve, c'est
qu'on a un type qui a été blessé par son
collègue qui se trouvait derrière et
heureusement qu'il lui a pas tiré dans
la tête. Ouais, mais quand tu te la
prends dans le bras, tu peux dire ça
arrive. Si tu te la prends dans la tête,
je veux dire bon à un moment euh c'est
un peu plus gênant, tu vois. Donc euh
donc du coup euh c'est pas bien ce que
je dis, mais c'est la réalité, tu vois.
C'est ça ça c'est des vrais
cher le mec, il s'est pas jeté sur les
policiers
Koulibali.
Oui
oui, mais je veux dire à un moment il
s'est jeté de façon un peu grossière
mais compte tenu du dispositif qu'il y
avait autour. Bon après les mecs, ils
sont allés tous en même temps, ils ont
vidé
s'il a une ceinture d'explosif.
Bah raison de plus, j'ai envie de dire.
Raison de plus. S'il a une ceinture
d'exposition avec de la quincaerie, je
veux dire, au moment quand il sort, tu
lui tires dans la tête et tu lui tires
pas dans le corps comme ça. Tu vois, je
sais pas le le 13 novembre, il y avait
le GIGN qui était présent parce que le
13 novembre, ça a été un théâtre
d'affrontement police gendarmerie. En
réalité, le GIGN était là et la
préfecture de police a interdit au GIGN
d'intervenir dans les lieux alors que la
police avait rien de plus à apporter. la
BRI intervenue mais ils avaient pas les
plans. Donc il aurait mieux valu
peut-être laisser le GGN intervenir en
amont. Euh GGN, ils sont quand même
assez bons en plus he faut être
réaliste. Bon théoriquement sur le
papier avec le raid, ils sont à peu près
à armes égales. Mais moi j'aime bien le
GIGN si tu veux. Ils ont quand même une
expérience sur le
très bons médiateur.
Ouais. Ouais. En 94, ils ont été très
bons hein quand même à Marseille he faut
pas c'était pas les même mais je veux
dire et et sur le laboratoire central il
y a eu la même chose. Il y a eu un
investissement à Sergie la gendarmerie
un laboratoire de de bon en fait une
médecine légale très performante.
Et la la PP a dit "Non non, on laisse le
labo central traité." Et puis à un
moment quand ils ont fait la restitution
des amplis à la société de spectacle,
ils ont retrouvé la jambe de Samiour
sous un ampli. Il l'avait oublié. Tu as
vu ça dans la presse ? Une jambe he je
veux dire c'est pas un doigt ou quoi que
ce soit. Donc à un moment pour les
familles je pense que ça a dû être assez
ou pour les techniciens aussi ça a dû
être tu vois ça a dû être assez hard
quand même.
Oui c'est très hard
tu vois. Bon donc après on a du la
police parce que tu sais c'est l'état
refuge. Je te parle de l'Algérie. Ça a
été un peu ça quand les quand le le on
va dire l'État communiste a perdu les
manettes un moment au plan démocratique
les gens ont voté pour les islamistes.
Bah tu sais un moment après les gens
disent non finalement avec l'armée
c'était pas si mal puis on va revoter
pour l'armée tu vois. Donc globalement,
c'est un petit peu ça. Les gens ont
cherché une valeur refuge et à ce
moment-là, ça a été la police. Mais moi,
je pense que ça s'est pas tellement bien
passé en réalité hein.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Ouais.
Et ça aurait pu encore continuer des
heures mais on commence à accuser le
coup. On a fait faut aller cuisiner là.
Il est l'heure d'aller pour les gens
conseiller trois bouquins chacun. Ça
fait six bouquins. Ça va aller.
Alexandre l'anglois.
Ah ben tu veux que je commence ? Moi je
conseille trois bouquins. Euh alors j'ai
plus le titre exact. C'est sur la la
propagande ce que c'est que je suis en
train de lire. C'est les trois que je
suis en train de faire. C'est sur la
propagande et l'ingénierie sociale qui a
été écrit par le neveu de Freu en voilà.
Donc le titre c'est propaganda de
mémoire dans les démocraties. Le
deuxième c'est le violage.
Alors j'ai plus le titre aussi mais là
je suis en train c'est dans le prochain
que je vais lire aussi. Puis après,
c'est juste parce que ça me fait plaisir
et que j'aime beaucoup le personnage,
c'est le livre des du philosophe Diogène
le Cynique et tous les philosophes de
l'école cynique parce que bon, ça met un
peu de légèreté et ils avaient déjà une
analyse très critique de leur société à
l'époque et finalement ça fait du bien
de le lire de temps en temps.
Trois, j'ai dit trois propagande avec la
propagande viole de la des foules par la
propagande et puis bah Diogène le cyque.
Ouais. Alors moi, j'aime bien Christophe
André
donc j'avais déjà conseillé un célé
dernière fois. Donc là, je conseille
l'estime de soi particulièrement pour
une amie là en ce moment qui qui va pas
bien. Et je pense que c'est des livres
des livres en fait thérapie. Je trouve
qu'ils sont assez intéressants à
explorer. Christophe André, j'aime bien
mes salutations s'il nous écoutent
d'ailleurs, je vous conseille même
pourquoi pas un jour de de l'inviter.
Ensuite
je je bah pour changer plutôt que de
rester dans l'actualité plutôt des
classiques. Donc bah le
je sais pas si ça vous l'a déjà fait
mais vous lisez un livre quand vous avez
15 ans et puis vous le relisez à 30 ans
et vous avez pas du tout la même lecture
en fait. Donc moi j'aime beaucoup le
mariage de Figaro de Beau Marchet. que
j'avais lu quand j'étais adolescent et
et je je l'ai recommandé là justement
pour le relire parce que je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est constitutif
en réalité du monde dans lequel on vit
aujourd'hui et de ce qu'est la France en
réalité parce que clairement je pense
que la France c'est pas qu'un pays c'est
pas que c'est pas qu'une terre c'est
aussi un patrimoine. Voilà c'est ça. Et
puis bah justement il a parlé de
Rousseau tout à l'heure. J'ai envie de
relire le contrat social parce que je
pense qu'à l'époque où je l'ai lu,
j'avais pas toutes les armes au plan bah
au plan de la maturité, au plan
intellectuel pour pouvoir savoir ce qui
renfermait en terme de trésor, en
réalité de civilisation. Et bah
aujourd'hui, pour savoir qui je suis,
dans quel pays je suis né et pour savoir
quel discours tenir aux gens et aussi à
mes enfants parce qu'on a un auditoire à
nous deux, je pense qu'on on a pas
beaucoup de policiers derrière nous mais
on a quand même beaucoup de Français qui
nous soutiennent et qui nous suivent.
Euh le contrat social de Jean-Jacques
Rousseau. Euh oui, euh je voilà je le
conseille également. Euh c'est voilà
un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Bah faut pas tomber dans le fatalisme au
bout d'un moment. J'allais dire euh
aujourd'hui on essaie de nous noyer sous
des informations diverses et variées et
ce qu'avait expliqué Anarette en disant
on va savoir que les gouvernements
mentent. Ils vont le savoir. Le problème
c'est pas que savoir qui mente, c'est
qu'ils veulent nous noyer sous des
informations diverses et variées pour
qu'on soit plus capable de former notre
opinion et de réfléchir par nous-même.
Et ça c'est la dangerosité vers la
dérive totalitaire. Et c'est ce qu'on
vit dans la crise Covid par exemple.
Plus personne peut se former un opinion.
Est-ce qu'on aime la police ? À chaque
fois on mélange toutes les cartes pour
plus personne puisse réfléchir par
soi-même. Donc gardez ça à l'esprit. Et
moi, je me suis fait une ligne de
conduite. En fait, au bout d'un moment,
il faut savoir vivre, il faut savoir
être libre. Donc garder un esprit
critique et trouver les les choses
auxquelles on veut se raccrocher. Si on
ne sait pas quelle opinion choisir, bah
du coup qu'est-ce qui va nous rendre
heureux et quelle action veut faire pour
pouvoir vivre normalement ?
Alors euh bah je vais profiter justement
de l'occasion puisqu'on nous a annoncé
euh dans les les les ces derniers jours
le le la mort de Giscar. Il y a un
moment où je me suis fait la réflexion,
je me suis dit bah il est à l'origine du
regroupement familial et s'il y avait
pas eu Giscar, quoi qu'on en dise, quoi
qu'on pense de son action, je pense que
j'aurais été gardien de chèvre à Tlemsè
et j'aurais pu éventuellement voilà vous
donner quelques conseils en la matière
et aujourd'hui je viens vous parler de
renseignement, de police, de
contrerrorisme et cetera. Donc je pense
que la France m'a donné cette
opportunité de m'élever
intellectuellement et spirituellement
pour ce qu'elle est. Et aujourd'hui, on
est en train de le perdre en fait tout
ça de façon évidente, hein. Je veux dire
que j'ai je discute avec des enseignants
de cette Saint-Den d'ailleurs, j'adresse
mes salutations à bah tous les
enseignants Tamara
et et tous les autres qui nous écoutent,
Claris et tous ceux qui se
reconnaîtront. Et eux me disent bah
qu'aujourd'hui on a des enfants qui
arrivent en 6e en fait dans certains
collèges du 93 et qui savent toujours
pas lire. Donc tu me demandes quelques
conseils de lecture donc pousser
jusqu'en terminale et voilà. Et donc
clairement euh j'ai j'ai envie de dire
tout ça on est en train de le perdre en
fait. Il faut se bardre pour le garder.
Et euh
comment dire en fait je on regarde
toujours vers les États-Unis et puis
aujourd'hui on regarde vers d'autres
cultures parce que tu sais en France on
a un petit peu un complexe injustifié he
je veux dire d'infériorité au plan
culturel parce qu'on sait pas vraiment
qui on est. Quoi que ça revient
aujourd'hui, il y a beaucoup de gens qui
repartent en province, des Bretons
d'ailleurs et d'autres des Vendéens et
cetera. Et je leur adresse mes
salutation
et euh j'ai envie de vous dire
franchement alors pour moi qui suis
d'origine algérienne qui qui a un peu
voyagé ou quoi que ce soit, vous pouvez
pas et je le dis franchement avec
beaucoup de sincérité, c'est pas
démagogique mais la France c'est de la
bombe atomique les gars franchement
pourquoi est-ce que vous allez chercher
ailleurs ? Non mais franchement vous
vous rendez pas compte de la chance
qu'on a. Tu fais 500 bornes, tu es sur
les côtes Atlantiques, tu as les côtes
juste tu as la côte d'Opale, tu as la
côteas, tu as la Méditerranée, tu as la
montagne, tu as tout. Et en même temps,
il y a un bagage culturel. Je parlais,
on parlait de Rousseau, hein, tu en as
parlé avant moi. Je veux dire, un bagage
philosophique, culturel, politique,
ethnique, mais c'est un truc de malade
quoi. Je veux dire, franchement, une vie
suffit pas pour explorer le patrimoine
et vous allez pourquoi pas s'ouvrir sur
les autres cultures ou quoi que ce soit,
mais réaliser un moment que sortez un
petit peu du 93, du 92 de la cité,
délaisser un moment, c'est les codes
culturels qui sont profondément toxiques
en réalité de tous ces milieux-là. et
aller voir ce qui se passe. On sortez du
minérabilisme et vous allez entrevoir
euh ce qui est ce que renferme
l'histoire de ce pays et c'est forcément
et indéiablement gigantesque en fait.
Voilà.
Star Skiutch, merci.
Merci
Hugy.
Les bons tuyaux.
Merci les enfants. Merci. Bonne soirée
et merci encore. À bientôt.
[Musique]